SOCIAL DISTANCING AT BASE
COVERING GUIDELINES IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
THE SENATE HAS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT THE
PUBLIC CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS
TO THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS.
WE'RE HOLDING OUR COMMITTEE
HEARINGS HERE IN CAPITAL ROOM
FORTY TWO OH THREE WITH NONE OF
OUR COMMITTEE MEMBERS
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY IN ROOM
FORTY TWO OR THREE WITH ME OUR
SENATORS CORTESE DOLLY GLACIER
MCGUIRE BUT CHAU BOTH AND PAM.
TO ALLOW THE PUBLIC ACCESS WE
HAVE ADMITTED MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC TO TWO HEARING ROOMS TO
THE EXTENT THAT SOCIAL
DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS ALLOW
AND WE WILL BE USING A
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE FOR
THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY TODAY. FOR INDIVIDUALS
WISHING TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT THE PARTICIPANT TOLL
FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS CODE IS
POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE WEBSITE
IT WILL BE DISPLAYED ON THE
SCREEN AND I ARE NOW SET.
COPLINK TODAY'S PARTICIPATE
NUMBER. ONE EIGHT FOUR FOUR TWO
NINE ONE FIVE FOUR NINE ZERO
AND THE ACCESS CODE IS. FIVE
NINE ZERO SIX ZERO THREE EIGHT
FOR DETAILED INSTRUCTIONS ON
HOW THE TELECONFERENCES TO
WORKS PLEASE REFER TO THE
SENATE INDOOR COMMITTEE WEBSITE
WHEN WE MOVED PUBLIC COMMENT
YOU WILL BE PROMPTED BY A
MODERATOR TO DIAL ONE THEN ZERO
FOR SUPPORT. AND OPPOSITION.
PURPOSES ONLY ONE TIME AND
PLEASE WAIT PATIENTLY FOR AN
OPERATOR TO ASSIGN YOU A LINE
NUMBER THIS CAN BE A SHORT
WAIT. ONCE YOU RECEIVE YOUR
LINE NUMBER YOU'LL WAIT IN THE
QUEUE FOR THE MODERATOR TO CALL
YOUR CALL YOUR LINE NUMBER. AT
THAT TIME YOU WILL BE ON MUTED
AND YOU ARE NOW READY TO
ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE.
INDIVIDUALS USING A VIDEO RELAY
SERVICE TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT SHOULD CALL EIGHT FOUR
FOUR. TWO NINE ONE FIVE FOUR
NINE ZERO. AND THE ACCESS CODE
IS. EIGHT NINE EIGHT SEVEN NINE
TWO SEVEN. PLEASE NOTE THAT IN
ORDER FOR US TO HEAR YOU
CLEARLY AND TO AVOID ACOUSTIC
FEEDBACK YOU MUST MEET THE
DEVICE YOU'RE WATCHING HEARING
ON PARTY GIVING TESTIMONY OVER
THE PHONE. IT IS IMPORTANT THAT
WE HEAR FROM YOU AND WE THANK
YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE. I WILL
MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING THE
HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY IN ANY
INDIVIDUAL WHO IS DISRUPTIVE
MAY BE REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE
MEETING SERVICE. OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS MUTED WHILE EVERY
EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO
STREAMLINE THE HIRING PROCESS
AND CONDUCT OUR HEARINGS IN AS
CLOSE TO THE SAME MANNER AS IS
CUSTOMARY. THERE MAY BE SOME
LEAD TIMES FOR PARTICIPANTS WHO
ARE JUST INTO THE NEW USE OF
ONLINE TOOLS AND TECHNOLOGIES.
PLEASE BE RESPECTFUL AND
PATIENT TOO SO ALL INTERESTED
PARTIES CAN BE HEARD. WE HAVE
TEN BILLS ON TODAY'S AGENDA.
ONE BILL IS ON CONSENT THE BILL
AND CONSENT IS ITEM THREE SB
FOUR SIXTEEN. ITEM SEVEN SB SIX
TWENTY TWO BY SENATOR ROTH HAS
BEEN PULLED AT THE REQUEST OF
THE AUTHOR. OR WE HEAR
PRESENTATION ON BILLS WHAT'S
ESTABLISH A QUORUM BETTER
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
LEYVA HERE LIVE HERE- TOWBOAT-
THE TROUBLE CARE CORTESE
FURTIVELY DAILY DAILY HERE
GLAZER HERE GLAZER HERE MCGUIRE
PAN. SACRAMENTO CONSULTANT WE
KNOW THAT A QUORUM IS BEEN
ESTABLISHMENT BURST I WOULD
LIKE TO TAKE UP THE CONSENT
CALENDAR THIS TIME DO WE HAVE A
MOTION THANK YOU THE OF CONSENT
CALENDAR HAS BEEN MOVED BY
SENATOR GLAZERS MADAM
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. IN CENTER LEYVA- HIGH
LEVEL AYE OTOBO AYE THE
TROUBLED BY COURTESY OF THE
PROTEST THE AYE TALLY GLAZER HI
GLAZER AYE MCGUIRE. PAN WE WILL
LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS TO VOTE. MEMBERS WE
WILL BEGIN THIS MORNING WITH A
SPECIAL ORDER FOR SB SIX NINETY
TWO AUTHORED BY SENATOR CORTESE
WE HAVE A DESIGNATED LINE FOR
OUR DEAF AND HARD OF HEARING
COMMUNITY THIS LINE IS
DESIGNATED FOR INDIVIDUALS
USING A VIDEORELAY SERVICE. TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT ON SB
SIX NINETY TWO. INDIVIDUALS
USING A VIDEO RELAY SERVICE TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT SHOULD
CALL. EIGHT FOUR FOUR TWO NINE
ONE FIVE FOUR NINE ZERO AND THE
ACCESS CODE IS EIGHT NINE EIGHT
SEVEN NINE TWO SEVEN. SENATOR
CORTESE YOU MAY BEGIN YOUR
PRESENTATION ON SIX NINETY TWO
WHEN YOU'RE READY. THANK YOU
MANCHURIAN AND NORTH SENATORS
I'M PLEASED TO PRESENT SB SIX
NINETY TO THE SPECIAL EDUCATION
INCLUSION ACT. THE BILL WAS
FORMED IN CONSULTATION WITH AND
WITH INPUT PROVIDED BY NUMEROUS
PARENTS OF STUDENTS WITH
DISABILITIES. DISABILITY RIGHTS
GROUPS SPECIAL EDUCATION
EXPERTS TEACHERS AND
ADMINISTRATORS AMONG OTHERS.
INCLUSION OR PROVIDING THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR STUDENTS WITH
DISABILITIES TO LEARNING GAUGE
WITH THE CONGRESS IN GENERAL
EDUCATION COSTELLO. HAS BEEN
DEMONSTRATED TO INCREASE
ACADEMIC IN GRADUATION OUTCOMES
FOR NOT ONLY SPECIAL EDUCATION
STUDENTS BUT ALL STUDENTS.
STATES THAT HAVE INCREASED
INCLUSION- BAND L. R. E. RATES
OVER THE LAST DECADE HAVE SEEN
PARABLE INCREASES IN THE
ACADEMIC ACHIEVEMENT OF
STUDENTS WITH DISABILITIES.
THIS INCLUDES MASSACHUSETTS NEW
JRSEY AND FLORIDA AMONG OTHERS.
YOU'RE CALIFORNIA ONLY 53% OF
STUDENTS WITH DISABILITIES
SPENT A MAJORITY OF THEIR
SCHOOL DAY IN GENERAL EDUCATION
CLASSROOM THAT'S FAR BELOW.
OTHER STATES IN IS FAR BELOW
THE NATIONAL AVERAGE WHICH IS
63% INTHE LAST DECADE
CALIFORNIA'S MADE ALMOST NO
PROGRESS TOWARD GREATER
INCLUSION OF STUDENTS WITH
DISABILITIES IN GENERAL
EDUCATION CLASSES. THIS IS ALL
THE MORE CONCERNING CONSIDERING
THAT IN TWENTY NINETEEN
STUDENTS WITH DISABILITIES IN
OUR STATE SCORED ON AVERAGE
EIGHTY EIGHT POINTS. IN A ONE
HUNDRED AND NINETEEN POINTS
BELOW STANDARD ON STATE
STANDARDIZED ENGLISH MATH
ASSESSMENTS RESPECTIVELY. BY
ADDING AN EGG IN EXISTING
FEDERAL INCLUSION. FOUR IN
OTHER WORDS LEAST RESTRICTIVE
ENVIRONMENT TARGET THAT BEING A
TERM OF ART TO THE STATE
ACCOUNTABILITY DASHBOARD FOR
CALIFORNIA SCHOOLS THIS BILL
WOULD EXPAND AWARENESS OF
INCLUSIVE OPTIONS FOR STUDENTS
WITH DISABILITIES. IT WOULD
DISINCENTIVE EYES DISTRICTS
FROM INAPPROPRIATELY PLACING
THOSE WITH SPECIAL NEEDS INTO
SEGREGATED CLASSROOMS. THAT
BEING SAID- I'M I WANT TO
CLARIFY THAT WE UNDERSTAND THAT
THE LEAST RESTRICTIVE
ENVIRONMENT AGAIN L. O. R. E.
SORT OF AN ACRONYM FOR EVERY
STUDENT- MAY NOT BE A GENERAL
EDUCATION SETTING SO IT'S
IMPORTANT TO NOTE. THAT IN I.
E. P. AN INDIVIDUAL EDUCATION
PROGRAM TEAM AND FAMILY WILL
CONTINUE TO HAVE THE RIGHT TO
DETERMINE THE MOST APPROPRIATE
PLACEMENT OF STUDENTS WITH
DISABILITIES. THAT WON'T CHANGE
UNDER THIS BILL. THIS BILL
WOULD ONLY ADD BUT WHAT'S KNOWN
AS INDICATOR FIVE EIGHTY TO THE
STATE DASHBOARD AS A LOCAL
MEASURE. THE MEASURE OF THE
PERCENTAGE OF STUDENTS WITH
DISABILITIES AGES SIX THROUGH
TWENTY TWO WHO SPENT TIME
INSIDE THE STANDARD CLASSROOM
FOR AT LEAST 80% OF THE SCHOOL
DAY. BY DOING THIS THE BILL
WOULD ENCOURAGE DISTRICTS TO
OFFER MORE INCLUSIVE OPTIONS TO
STUDENTS WITH DISABILITIES.
INCENTIVIZE DISTRICTS USE
EXISTING RESOURCES TO PROVIDE
GENERAL EDUCATION TEACHERS WITH
TRAINING AND PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT AND TEACHING
STRATEGIES AND FRAMEWORKS
OPTIMIZE EDUCATION FOR STUDENTS
WITH INDIVIDUAL LEARNING
DIFFERENCES. THIS BILL SB SIX
NINETY TWO WILL THEREBY BE ABLE
TO IMPROVE THE EDUCATIONAL
OPPORTUNITIES AVAILABLE THROUGH
INCLUSION TO STUDENTS WITH
DISABILITIES LAYING THE
FOUNDATION FOR FUTURE
LEGISLATION FOCUSED ON
CALIFORNIA VALUES OF INCLUSION
UNDERSTANDING AND EQUITY.
BEFORE INTRODUCED MY WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL I WANT
TO MAKE NOTE. THAT I'VE
SUBMITTED AUTHOR AMENDMENTS IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH MANY ADVOCATES
ORGANIZATIONS AND LEADERS
PROTECTING THE DEAF AND HARD OF
HEARING COMMUNITY THE BLIND
COMMUNITY AND THE DELPHI
COMMUNITY. SOME ARE HERE TODAY-
AND WILL ALSO BE TESTIFIED. THE
BILL BE PROVIDING TESTIMONY I
BELIEVE WITH THE NEUTRAL STANCE
AS OF TODAY MY OFFICE IN A BILL
SPONSOR THE SANTA CLARA COUNTY
OFFICE OF EDUCATION. IT IS A
HAS BEEN WILL CONTINUE TO BE IN
REGULAR COMMUNICATION
CONVERSATION WITH THEM. THE
AMENDMENTS MADE IN PARTNERSHIP
WITH THEM SERVE TO MAKE
CLARIFICATIONS TO ADDRESS WHAT
WERE THEIR INITIAL CONCERNS
REGARDING THIS BILL. SO WANT TO
MAKE IT ABUNDANTLY CLEAR THAT
THIS BILL WOULD NOT ALTER THE
RIGHTS OF DEAF DEAF OR HARD OF
HEARING BLIND OR DEAF BLIND
STUDENTS AND FAMILIES. NOR
WOULD HAVE ANY IMPACT ON STATE
SPECIAL SCHOOLS OR SPECIALTY
PROGRAMS THAT SERVE LOW
INCIDENCE STUDENTS WITH
DISABILITIES. STATE SPECIAL
SCHOOLS AND SPECIALTY PROGRAMS
SUCH AS THOSE. DO NOT HAVE AN
INDICATOR FIVE. AND WE COLLATE
A SAID EARLIER THIS BILL UP
ONLY- MODIFIES INDICATOR FIVE
EIGHT THEY DO NOT HAVE AN
INDICATOR FIVE BILLION OR NOT
INCLUDED IN THIS FOR REPORTING
OR ACCOUNTABILITY. THE MINUTES
MADE TO THE BILL SERVE TO
CLARIFY THAT IN A I WANT TO
THANK EVERYONE WHO WORKED WITH
ME IN OUR OFFICE. TO MAKE THIS
CLEAR IN THE BILL LANGUAGE.
WITH US TODAY IS DOCTOR MILLION
TO ONE THE SANTA CLARA COUNTY
SUPERINTENDENT OF SCHOOLS. BUT
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT IN KEVIN
SCHAEFER DIRECTOR OF THE
SUPPORTING INCLUSIVE PRACTICES
PROJECT. OF THE OLD RUNDLE
COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION.
AGAIN BUT BOTH ARE HERE TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU-
COLLEAGUES THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND RESPECTFULLY ON TH AS
FOR RIVAL. THANK YOU SENATOR
CORTESE WE WILL NOW GO TO OUR
LEAD SUPPORT DR MERION TO ONE
AND KEVIN SHAFFER I THINK-
DOCTORED TO ONE YOU'RE GOING
FIRST. YEAH GOOD MORNING
EVERYONE I'M I'M BACK TO MARION
TO LINE SANTA CLARA COUNTY
SUPERINTENDENT OF SCHOOLS. WE
ARE REALLY PROUD TO SPONSOR
SENATE BILL SIX NINETY TWO I
WANT TO EXPRESS OUR DEEP
APPRECIATION TO SENATOR KERR
CATHY FOR BRINGING FORWARD THIS
IMPORTANT BILL. THAT
PRIORITIZES EQUITY AND
INCLUSION BUT OUR COLORS AT THE
SANTA CLARA COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION. I STARTED MY CAREER
AS A SPECIAL EDUCATION TEACHER
AND I'VE SEEN FIRSTHAND THAT
INCLUDING CAN CHANGE THE
TRAJECTORY OF A STUDENT BY.
STUDENTS WITH DISABILITIES YOU
ARE INCLUDED IN GENERAL
EDUCATION CLASSES ARE MORE
LIKELY. TO GRADUATE FROM HIGH
SCHOOL STAY ON TRACK WITH THEIR
PEERS. AND ENGAGE IN THE WORK
FORCE. THIRTY YEARS OF EVIDENCE
BASED RESEARCH DEMONSTRATE A
CLEAR AND CAUSAL RELATIONSHIP.
NGUYEN INCLUSION AND IMPROVE
THEIR PRACTICES AND ACADEMIC
GRADUATION AND EMPLOYMENT THANK
THAT. HOWEVER CALIFORNIA HAS
NOT MADE ANY SIGNIFICANT MOVES.
TOWARD GREATER INCLUSION OR
INCLUSIVE BACK. THE NATIONAL
RATE OF AN FOR STUDENTS THAT
THE THAT 63% HOWEVER CALIFORNIA
IN. ONLY FIFTY THREE PER OF
OURS WHAT DOES THE AND GENERAL
EDUCATION CLASSES. WE INDICATES
THAT IS A OR- BETWEEN
CALIFORNIA'S FAILURE TO
PRIORITIZE INCLUSION AND THE
FACT THAT STUDENTS WITH
DISABILITIES PERFORM WORSE ON
STANDARDIZED TESTS. THAN ANY
OTHER SUBGROUP INCLUDING LOW
INCOME STUDENT. SENATE BILL SIX
NINETY TWO WOULD NOT REQUIRE
THAT 1100% OF STUDENTS WITH
DISABILITIES THE INCLUDED A
100% OF THE TIME. BUT IT WOULD
SUPPORT DISTRICTS TO EXPAND
INCLUSION AND INCLUSIVE
PRACTICES PLAN FOR THOSE TYPES
OF PROGRAMS AND DEVOTE EXISTING
RESOURCES. TOWARDS PROVIDING
MORE OPPORTUNITIES AND MORE
OPTIONS FOR STUDENTS WITH IEPS.
WE AT THE SANTA CLARA COUNTY
OFFICE OF EDUCATION BELIEVE
THAT STUDENTS WITH DISABILITIES
ARE IMPORTANT AND ESSENTIAL
MEMBERS. OF THE GENERAL
EDUCATION COMMUNITY AND
THEREFORE SHOULD HAVE. EQUAL
ACCESS TO INCLUSIVE EDUCATION
WITH THEIR PEERS. WE URGE YOU
TO SUPPORT EQUITY AND INCLUSION
BY VOTING YES ON SENATE BILL
SIX NINETY TWO. THANK YOU.
MISTER SCHAEFFER. I GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS KEVIN
SCHAEFER DIRECTOR OF EQUITY AND
INCLUSIVE PRACTICES FOR THE
SUPPORTING INCLUSIVE PRACTICES
PROJECT FUNDED B THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION I ALONG WITH
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR KRISTEN
BROOKS ADMINISTER THE PROJECT
THROUGH THE EL DORADO AND
RIVERSIDE COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION RESPECTIVELY. OUR
MISSION IS TO SUPPORT
LEADERSHIP TEAMS IN THEIR
INTENTIONAL DESIGN AND REDESIGN
INCREASED MEANINGFUL INCLUSIVE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR STUDENTS WITH
DISABILITIES WITH PARTICULAR
FOCUS ON SPECIAL EDUCATION
INDICATOR FIVE EIGHT WHICH IS
AT THE CENTER OF THIS BILL.
ALMOST FIFTY YEARS AGO I WAS A
STUDENT WITH A DISABILITY WHO
EXPERIENCED EXCLUSIONARY
PRACTICES AS WELL AS THE AFTER
TAX. FIFTY YEARS AGO AND IT'S
STILL FAR TOO OFTEN WE CONTINUE
TO EDUCATE STUDENTS WITH
DISABILITIES IN SEGREGATED
SETTINGS AND TO WHAT END. EVEN
TODAY ROUGHLY HALF OF THE
STUDENTS WITH DISABILITIES IN
CALIFORNIA ARE EDUCATED IN
SEPARATE LEARNING ENVIRONMENTS
THIS SEGREGATION IN MOST CASES
NEGATIVELY IMPACTS POST
SECONDARY EDUCATION AND LIMITS
CAREER OPPORTUNITIES. WE MUST
DO BETTER AND DOING BETTER
INCLUDES ADDING INDICATOR FIVE
A LEAST RESTRICTIVE ENVIRONMENT
DATA AS A REQUIRED AND
TRANSPARENT MEASURE ON THE
CALIFORNIA ACCOUNTABILITY
DASHBOARD. THIS STILL ALLOWS
FOR THE INDIVIDUALIZED
PLACEMENT DECISIONS MADE BY I
EAT P. TEAMS TO BE FRONT AND
CENTER AS OPPOSED TO AN ABLEIST
AFTERTHOUGHT OR STYLO DISTRICT
PLANNING CONVERSATION. I KNOW
FROM PERSONAL EXPERIENCE HOW
NECESSARY INCLUSION IN IT AND
HAVE DEDICATED MY CAREER TO A
FEW CREATING MORE INCLUSIVE
LEARNING SPACES THAT ALL
STUDENTS DESERVE. REMEMBER THAT
SEPARATE IS NOT ALWAYS EQUAL I
URGE YOU TO VOTE IN SUPPORT. OF
SB SIX NINETY TWO. THANK MR
SHAVER WE WILL NOW GO TO FOR
TWO- THREE ANYWAY WHO'S WE TO
TESTIFY SUPPORT. SEEING NONE
WILL NOW GO TO ROOM TWENTY
FORTY. OKAY THANK YOU AND WE'RE
GONNA TAKE A QUICK FIVE MINUTE
BREAK APPLAUSE.
GO TOWARD
TELEPHONIC LINE FOR ANY
WITNESSES CALLING IN IN SUPPORT
OF SB SIX NINETY TWO MODERATOR
PLEASE OPEN THE LINES. THANK
YOU IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO SHOW
YOUR SUPPORT FOR SB SIX NINETY
TWO SIMPLY PRESS ONE FOLLOWED
BY ZERO ON YOUR TOUCH TONE
PHONE. NOT AT T. OPERATOR WILL
ACCESS YOUR LINE AND GIVE YOU
YOUR LINE NUMBER AND THEN PLACE
YOU BACK INTO THE QUEUE SO ONCE
AGAIN FOR QUESTIONS- TO TESTIFY
ON SB SIX NINETY TWO PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME.
AND MADAM CHAIR WILL BEGIN
TODAY WITH A LINE FIFTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I IS
POLITICALLY ACCURACY ON BEHALF
OF RIVERSIDE COUNTY
SUPERINTENDENT OF SCHOOLS IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU AND NEXT WE
WILL GO TO LINE FIFTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE FIFTY
SEVEN ARE YOU MUTED. HELLO I'M
NOT. WE CAN HEAR YOU. I
ACTUALLY- WAS NOT CALLING IN
SUPPORT OF CALLING IN
OPPOSITION OKAY WE WILL GET TO
YOU IN A MOMENT. OKAY THANK YOU.
AS A REMINDER PLEASE QUEUE UP
RIGHT NOW IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT
OF SB SIX NINETY TWO. AND NEXT
WE ARE GOING TO GO TO LINE
FORTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HER
BODY WAS CALIFORNIA CALLING THE
REPORT- THANK YOU TO THE AUTHOR
AND THE POSSIBLE WORKING WITH
THE DISABILITY COMMUNITY ON THE
L. ONE THING I DID WANT TO
MENTION LOW. BIG RITUAL HEARING
BOB AND CONSIDER THAT EVENING.
OR NAME AND YOUR SUPPORT. FOR
THE BILL THANK YOU NEXT CALLER.
THANK YOU MOVE ALONG WE GO TO
LINE SIXTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO WE CAN URBAN WHITE. SIXTY
I'M NOT SURE WHAT LINE NUMBER
WE WANT TO GIVE AN EXACT NUMBER
ON HERE YOU'RE PRETTY FOR
TESTIMONY. OKAY DID YOU WANT TO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. OKAY THE YOU
WANT ME TO GO AHEAD YES. I GOOD
MORNING MEMBERS FROM MY NAME IS
JANETTE AROUND I'M THE
PRESIDENT OF CALIFORNIA
EDUCATION EDUCATORS FOR THE
DEATH AND WE APPRECIATE OF
BEING ABLE TO HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO WORK WITH THE
AUTHORED OFFICE OF THE BILL
WITH THIRTY TURN TO ENSURE OUR
DEAF STUDENTS ARE NOT AFFECTED.
WHEN I STAYED UP CHILDREN I'M
INCLUDING THE FULL SPECTRUM OF
CHILDREN HEARING LEVEL
INCLUDING UNILATERAL AND MILD.
THE BILL NEEDED TO SPECIFICALLY
ALL DEAF CHILDREN FROM SB SIX
NINE TWO IN ORDER TO ADDRESS
LANGUAGE DEPRIVATION AND A VERY
INCONSEQUENTIAL BARRIERS FOR
DEAF CHILDREN. BECAUSE THE
CHILDREN BONTA LOW INCIDENCE
DISABILITY CATEGORY SPECIAL
EDUCATION PROFESSIONAL BLACK
THE WIDESPREAD UNDERSTANDING OF
WHAT THE TOTAL INCLUSION
IMPLICATIONS ARE WITH THEIR
CHILDREN. LOCK UP KNOWLEDGE AND
SKILLS RELATED TO DEATH
EDUCATION. WHAT THE SPECIAL
EDUCATION THAT THEM CONTRIBUTE
TO THE ALREADY SUBSTANTIAL
LANGUAGE DELAY DEATH CHILDREN
EXPERIENCE IN A TOTAL INCLUSION
ENVIRONMENT. FOR DEAF CHILDREN
INCLUSION MEANS BEING IN THEIR
LANGUAGE RICH ENVIRONMENT WITH
A CRITICAL MASS OF DEATH
POPULATION CALIFORNIA LAW AB
ONE EIGHT THREE FIVE CHILD BILL
OF RIGHTS. I FEEL LIKE THAT
WHEN THE IRAQI TEAM IS
DEVELOPING GOALS AND OBJECTIVES
FOR A DEAF CHILD THEY MIGHT
CONSIDER SEVERAL IMPORTANT
ISSUES ON RECOMMENDING. AN
EDUCATIONAL LANGUAGE RICH
ENVIRONMENT PLACEMENT FOR DEAF
CHILD NUMBER ONE THAT DIDN'T
HAVE TO HEAR THE MILLER IN AGE
LANGUAGE AND LEARNING ABILITY
AND AMERICAN SIGN LANGUAGE IN
ENGLISH NUMBER TWO TEACHERS AND
EDUCATIONAL PROFESSIONAL ARE
SKILLED IN THE DEAF CHILD
LANGUAGE AND WAY OF
COMMUNICATING. NUMBER THREE
TEACHERS AND EDUCATIONAL
PROFESSIONALS ARE TRAINED OR
CERTIFIED TO WORK WITH CHILDREN
WITH DEATH CREDENTIALED NUMBER
FOUR THE EDUCATIONAL PROGRAMS
CRITICAL ELEMENT MIGHT BE
ACCEPTABLE STEPCHILD WAY OF
COMMUNICATING AMERICAN SIGN
LANGUAGE AND BEING LESS AND IN
ALIGNMENT WITH BEST PRACTICES
FOR EDUCATING THEIR CHILDREN.
THE OPPOSITION TO SB DECLINE
HERE IS AN EXAMPLE OF WHY JACK
PROFESSIONALS AND EXPERTS AND
DECKER EDUCATION NEED TO BE
INVOLVED AND OVER ONE HUNDRED
YEARS OF A PROACTIVE
EDUCATIONAL PRACTICES WHICH
INCLUDES SPECIAL EDUCATION
NARROW. DEFINITION L. R. EAT
AND INCLUDE THE PRACTICES THE
TIME FOR US TO CREATE EFFECTIVE
REGIONAL PROGRAM FOR DEAF
CHILDREN ONE FINAL APPROACHES
AN AMERICAN BY LANGUAGE AND
ENGLISH THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA.
WE APPRECIATE SENATOR CORPUZ
NEEDS RESPONSE TO THE DEATH
PROFESSIONAL CONCERNED AND
ACCEPTANCE OF OUR PROPOSED
AMENDMENT LET'S CONTINUE TO
WORK TOGETHER IN TWENTY TWENTY
TO INTRODUCED A NEW BILL TO AND
CALIFORNIA'S ACADEMIC LANGUAGE
DEPRIVATION. AND DISMAL
EDUCATIONAL OUTCOME HAPPENING
DEATH CHILDREN OF ALL AGES.
OKAY THANK YOU VERY SO YOU VERY
MUCH THANK SO MEMBERS WE ARE-
FOLLOWING SO NEW FOR TODAY I'M
JUST TO ASK A TO BE PAY AND
THAT WAS ON ONE OF OUR LEAD
WITNESSES WHO IS NEUTRAL ON THE
BILL MISTER MODERATOR WE WOULD
LIKE TO STILL HEAR FROM PEOPLE
WHO ARE SUPPORTING THE BILL
PEOPLE WHO ARE SUPPORTING THE
BILL PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME AND
YOUR SUPPORT FOR THE BILL AND
YOUR ORGANIZATION IF YOU'RE
WITH AN ORGANIZATION. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR. AND AS SHE SAID
PLEASE ONLY QUEUE UP AT THIS
TIME IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT OF
SB SIX NINETY TWO THANK YOU.
SIX WE WILL GO TO A LINE SIXTY
TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY
NAME IS KRISTEN BROWN AND I AM
THE VICE CHAIR OF THE COMMUNITY
ADVISORY COMMITTEE FOR SPECIAL
EDUCATION PUBLIC FOR. SANTA
CLARA COUNTY- I- IN IN FAVOR OF
THE BILL INCLUSION IN PUBLIC
SCHOOLS IN CALIFORNIA COMPLEX
AND THIS PROVIDES A PATHWAY OF
MONITORING HOW TO CREATE A
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL R. J.
CANTWELL OF THE DATABASE ONE.
OKAY IT JUST YOUR NAME. AND
YOUR SUPPORT FOR THE BILL
PLEASE. WHILE SHE BELIEVES WHAT
SHE BELIEVED WE WERE GOING TO
AN EX ONE MOMENT EVERYONE.
IT'LL BE A FEW OKAY THANK YOU
SENATOR CORTESE SO WE'RE JUST
ASKING FOR PEOPLE WHO ARE IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL WE DO HAVE
ANOTHER LEAD WITNESS FOR WHO IS
NEUTRAL ON THE BILL AND WE WILL
GET TO THAT PERSON. BUT RIGHT
NOW IF YOU'RE CALLING IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL PLEASE
STATE YOUR NAME IF YOU'RE WITH
AN ORGANIZATION AND YOUR
SUPPORT FOR THE BILL MISTER
MODERATOR CAN WE GO TO OUR NEXT
LINE PLEASE. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR WILL MOVE ON TO LINE
FIFTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS MARLEY
NEGARA AND I AM A PARENT I'M IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL. THANK YOU.
TEXAS LINE. THIRTY EIGHT. HELLO
I'M MARIA DEHN UNATTRACTIVE
DIRECTOR FOR PARENTS HELPING
PARENTS. EXTENT OF THE DAMAGE
HERE THE READING CHILDREN WITH
DISABILITIES AND WE ARE IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL SIX NINETY
TO ENCOURAGE- PRETTY DOCTOR
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE-
VISUALLY AND HEARING IMPAIRED
THANK YOU. TO ADDRESS THANK YOU.
WE'LL GO TO LINE THIRTY TO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU MY NAME
IS JESSICA CORNELISON I AM A
NUMBER OF PARENTS FOR INCLUSIVE
EDUCATION CALIFORNIA AND
ANOTHER FOURTH GRADER WITH DOWN
SYNDROME AND I THE COURT
BUILDING THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
PUTTING ONE POINT FORTY ONE YOU
ARE NOW OPEN. DR LISA GONZALEZ
CHIEF BUSINESS OFFICER IN THE
MOUNT DIABLO UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT AND TWENTY SEVENTEEN
PRESIDENT OF THE ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
ADMINISTRATORS SUPPORT FOR
SENATE BILL SIX NINETY TWO.
THANK YOU. NINE ELEVEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HELLO I'M ANGELA
SUTHERLAND AND I'M SPEAKING ON
BEHALF OF THE GREATER
SACRAMENTO DYSLEXIA SUPPORT
GROUPS EUREKA INCLUSIVE-
MISSION FOR STUDENTS WITH
DISABILITIES MORGAN HILL. SLASH
CALIFORNIA CONCERNED PARENTS
ASSOCIATION PARENTS WHO ARE
ACTIVE AND CURRENT OR PAST
MEMBERS OF THE COMMUNITY
ADVISORY COMMITTEE FOR SPECIAL
EDUCATION EL CAP PARENT
ADVISORY COMMITTEES AND SCHOOL
SITES WE ARE ALL- CURRENT OR
PAST MEMBERS OF THESE GROUPS.
WE SUPPORT SB SIX NINETY TWO
AND CLEAR IT HOWEVER WE DO HAVE
CONCERNS ABOUT YOUR ABILITY
OVERALL BATES OF INCLUSIVE
EDUCATION WRITER HOUSE CORNIA
USE AND WILL BE SUBMITTING A.
LETTER TO YOU THANK YOU. OKAY
LET ME SAY ONE MORE TIME PLEASE
JUST CALL WITH YOUR NAME YOUR
ORGANIZATION AND IF YOU SUPPORT
THE BILL THANK YOU. AND AS A
REMINDER IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
SHOW YOUR SUPPORT ONLY AT THIS
TIME FOR SB SIX NINETY TWO
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO ON YOUR
TOUCH TONE PHONE. THANK YOU AND
WE WILL GO TO- LINE FORTY SEVEN
MEDICARE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS COMPLETE THIS READER
AND I AM A PARENT- OF A FIFTEEN
YEAR OLD- WHO HAS AUTISM. I
ALSO REPRESENT AN ORGANIZATION
CALLED PROJECT MANAGER FOR NEAR
DIVERSITY- WOULD BE TRAIN
ALLIES- TO BE SUPPORTIVE OF
STUDENTS AND INCLUDING
INTEGRATE THEM. I AM SPEAKING
ON BEHALF OF. YEAH AND ALSO AS
A PARENT. AND I AM IN SUPPORT
OF COMPLETE INCLUSION. ALL
STUDENTS ARE NOT MA'AM THANK
YOU JUST YOUR NAME ORGANIZATION
AND THE SUPPORT THE BILL. THANK
YOU NEXT CALL PLEASE. SIX WILL
GO ALLOW SIXTY THREE YOU ARE
OPEN. I THANK. PLEASE GO AHEAD.
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR WITH THE
SUPPORTING CHRISTIAN PRACTICES
PROJECT OUT OF RIVERSIDE COUNTY
OFFICE OF EDUCATION AND SUPPORT
SENATE BILL SIX NINETY TWO.
THANK YOU. THE FINAL REMINDER
IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO QUEUE UP
FOR- IN SUPPORT OF SB SIX
NINETY TWO PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO ON YOUR TOUCH TONE PHONE.
AND WE WILL GO TO LINE FORTY
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. TWENTY
FORTY SIX YOU ARE OPEN PLEASE
ON MUTE. HELLO YOUR OPEN.
PLEASE GO AHEAD WE CAN HEAR YOU.
I PREVENTING AS NEUTRAL WHY GO
NOW OR DO I WAIT WE WILL GET
YOU IN JUST A MOMENT. OKAY
THANK YOU. OKAY THEN WE'LL GO
TO LINE FORTY TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING THIS IS
DOCTOR VICTORIA GRAFT PROFESSOR
OF EDUCATION AT LOYOLA
MARYMOUNT UNIVERSITY AND FORMER
MEMBER OF THE SPECIAL EDUCATION
STATEWIDE TASK FORCE AND I AM
DEFINITELY IN STRONG SUPPORT.
SB SIX NINE TWO THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU. MADAM CHAIR
THERE KNOW WHETHER A
PARTICIPANT QUEUED UP AT THIS
TIME THANK YOU MR MODERATOR
MEMBERS WE ARE NOW GOING TO DO
SOMETHING A LITTLE DIFFERENT
WE'RE GOING TO GO TO LEAD
NEUTRAL. THE TEST PEOPLE WHO
ARE TESTIFYING WE DID HEAR FROM
ONE OF OUR NEW LEAD NEUTRAL
FOLKS EARLIER. I APOLOGIZE I DO
NOT KNOW WHO THAT WAS IF IT WAS
BRUCE A BILL. YANNI OR IF IT
WAS JENNETTE DURANT SO- WE'RE
GOING TO HEAR FROM ONE OF THOSE
WILL NOW GO TO OUR DESIGNATED
LINE FOR INDIVIDUALS USING A
VIDEO RELAY SERVICE. TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT SB SIX NINETY
TWO MODERATOR IF YOU COULD
PLEASE OPEN THAT DESIGNATED
LINE. SH ABSOLUTELY YOUR LINE
SHOULD BE OPEN SIMPLY ON MUTE
YOURSELF. PRETTY NEAR THE MONEY
WAS GIVEN BY- JANET MORAN THANK
YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH SO
WE'RE LOOKING FOR ROSA BILL WAS
A BILL ARE YOU READY TO TESTIFY
B. OF TWO MINUTES. I AM THANK
YOU VERY MUCH GOOD MORNING
EVERYBODY THANK YOU FOR THE
TIME MY NAME IS BOTH AND
PLANNING I AM THE PRESIDENT OF
CALIFORNIA CANS VOICES. AN
ORGANIZATION WHICH THE COURT
HERE AT THE DEAF AND HARD OF
HEARING CHILDREN STATEWIDE. I
AM ALSO A MOTHER OF A THIRTEEN
YEAR OLD CHILD IN THE SEVENTH
GRADE IN SAN DIEGO CALIFORNIA.
OUR NOT WHETHER IT'S HOW NEEDS
MERICAN LANGUAGE OR ENGLISH
WHICH COULD BE BROKEN OR- WHERE
THEIR WITHOUT VISUAL. R. OR-
THE COURT HEARING AND DEAF AND
HARD OF HEARING CHILDREN
REGARDLESS OF WHETHER THEIR
CHILD IS FALLING. DOWN ALL THE
SAME CLASSROOMS. IN THE BATTLE
EDUCATION CLASSROOM. ALL OR
PART OF THE DAY. OR EVEN A NON
SCHOOL OR AN ACCOUNT SCHOOL FOR
THE DEAF. WE THE OPPORTUNITY
WORK WITH THE ARE OF AT LEAST
NINETIETH ABOUT R. P. AND GLASS
THAT HE IS EXCEPT OUR AMENDMENT
EXEMPTING DEATH IN HEART OF
HEARING CHILDREN. INCLUDING
CAPTAIN HARD HEARING CHILDREN
WHO HAVE A DIGITAL DISABILITY.
FROM THE REQUIREMENTS OF THE
BILL. CALIFORNIA HEARING VOICES
STRONGLY BELIEVES THAT. YOUR
SON DOESN'T HARD HEARING
CHILDREN THE GENERAL EDUCATION
CLASSROOM IS THE MOST
APPROPRIATE PLACEMENT IT IS NOT
THE MOST APPROPRIATE PLACEMENT
FOR ALL OF THAT CAN HARD OF
HEARING CHILDREN. WE SUPPORT A
FULL CONTINUUM OF OPTIONS FOR
DEAF AND HARD OF HEARING
CHILDREN SHOULD THEREFORE
CALIFORNIA HANSEN VOICES HAVE
CHANGED IN THE VISION FROM
OPPOSED TO NEUTRAL WE RETAIN
THE OPTION COULD JACK THE
POSSIBLE FUTURE AMENDMENT OF
THE BILL WE. THANK YOU FOR
LISTENING TO OUR CONCERNS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE WILL NOW
GO TO ANYONE WHO IS NEUTRAL
THAT IS HERE IN ROOM FORTY TWO
OH THREE PLEASE GO TO THE
MICROPHONE. STATE YOUR NAME AND
THAT YOU WERE NEUTRAL ON THE
BILL PLEASE. FIFTEEN NO ONE.
SORRY. IF I COULD COME. WELCOME
PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME AND THAT
YOU WERE NEUTRAL ON THE BILL.
HI MY NAME IS. JERRY. SHARE FOR
F. A. R. BY H. A. I CAN
UNDERSTAND THIS RECOGNITION.
I'M WORKING FOR THE COLFAX DEAF
AND HARD OF HEARING SERVICE.
ALL RIGHT TIME I'M A TALK FOR
MYSELF COMMUTER MY CRUNCHES AND
TALK FOR HERSELF. TECHNICALLY
YOU'RE JUST SUPPOSED TO STATE
YOUR NAME AND YOUR SUPPORT
OPPOSITION OR RIGHT NOW
NEUTRALITY FOR THE BILL WE'VE
ALREADY HEARD FROM THE
WITNESSES WHO ARE NEUTRAL. YEAH
I AM TRYING TO READ THEATER. IN.
MY NAME IS SHERRY FOR ENOUGH.
ZERO FIVE NINE CHAPTERS. GOING
HERE AND BACK IN MY- AND I CHEN
CAL CALLED EVERY SENTIMENT AND
HOW TO HEARING WE ARE TAKING OF.
TRYING TO WORK WITH TO THE
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
SHERRY WILL NOW GO ROOM TO FOUR
IF THEY ANYONE THERE TWENTY WHO
IS NEW TO SEEING NO ONE WILL GO
TO THE PHONE LINES IF THERE'S
ANYONE WHO IS NEUTRAL ON THE
BILL. PLEASE QUEUE UP AT THIS
TIME. AND I LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
QUEUE UP AND SHOW YOR NEUTRAL
SUPPORT- FIRST WE ARE GOING TO
GO TO THE ABA LINE. SO ANYBODY
ON EIGHTY A LINE WILL GIVE IT A
MINUTE HERE. TO GIVE YOURSELF
TIME TO QUEUE UP PLEASE PRESS
ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO. ONE FILED
BY ZERO ONE EIGHTY A LINE. SHOW
YOUR NEUTRAL SUPPORT FOR BILL
SB SIX NINE TWO. M. ADAM SURE
ONE MOMENT PLEASE WE DO HAVE
SOMEBDY QUEUING UP ON THE A
LINE THANK YOU MR MODERATOR.
THANK YOU.
THE PERSON IF YOU
WANT TO REACH YOU OUT PLEASE GO
AHEAD AND HIT ONE FILED BY ZERO
AGAIN LOOKS LIKE YOU TOOK
YOURSELF OUT OF Q. OKAY MISTER
MODERATOR WE'RE GOING TO GO TO
THOSE IN OPPOSITION TO THE BILL
IF THAT PERSON QUEUES UP WHEN
WE COME BACK WE WILL.
ABSOLUTELY LET THEM IN SO IF
THERE IS ANYONE WHO IS IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL I HAVE
NO ONE AS LEAD OPPOSITION. IS
THERE ANYONE IN ROOM FORTY TWO
OR THREE WHO IS OPPOSING SB SIX
NINETY TWO. SEEING NONE WILL GO
TO ROOM TWENTY FORTY. SEEING
NONE NOW WE WILL GO TO THE LAW
OF THE TELEPHONIC LINE MISTER
MODERATOR DO WE HAVE ANYONE IN
Q. WHO WISHES TO TESTIFY
AGAINST SB SIX NINETY TWO.
ACTUALLY MADAM CHAIR I THINK
THERE MIGHT BE ONE OR TWO THAT
I WANT TO SHOW THEIR NEUTRAL
SUPPORT ON THE MAIN LINE THAT
THE FIRST INSTRUCTIONS WERE PUT
EIGHTY EIGHT ABA LINE ONLY NO
PROBLEM AT ALL I THINK. OKAY
THANKS SIX MINUTES. AND WE WILL
GO TO LIGHT FORTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. ONE FORTY SIX YOU ARE
OPEN. THE W. FORTY SIX. FORTY
SIX WE CAN HEAR YOU. BOB MOVING
ALONG WE WERE LINE SIXTY FIVE.
HELLO THERE WE GO. ABOUT FORTY
SIX THIS WEEK YOU'LL- OR RIGHT
NOW WE'RE GOING TO KEEP A IN
PLEASE RE QUEUE. FOR SIX. ONE
EIGHT ONE ZERO FORTY SIX AND
ONE SIXTY YOUR OPEN. DODD BRAD
KNIGHT. IS WORKING. AND I
HIGHLY SUPPORT THE BILL. THANK
YOU. FORTY SIX PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AGAIN. THEY'RE NOT REACH
SO IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO. YOUR
APPLE TO S. B. SIX NINETY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. SO OPPOSITE
FOR BILL SIX NINE TWO GOING.
MADAM AT NOVA IS Q. UP OKAY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISS
MONTEREY. WE'RE GOING TO BRING
IT BACK TO THE K. HOW MANY
QUESTIONS YEAH SENATOR PLEASE
PROCEED. DOES NOT TURN ON A
VERY VERY GOTCHA. FIRST OFF I
WANT TO JUST. THANK THE CHAIR
FOR ALLOWING PEOPLE WHO ARE
DISABILITIES TO BE ABLE TO
PARTICIPATE IN OUR PUBLIC
PROCESS I THINK THIS IS
OUTSTANDING- I'M AND I DO HAVE
A COMMON SUPPORT YOUR BILL I
WANTED TO SHARE THOUGH- I'M
ACTUALLY HEARING IMPAIRED I'D
BUY. AND WEARING HEARING AIDS
RIGHT NOW- AND I. IN THE
PROCESS OF IT SO I WANT TO GIVE
A CLARIFICATION IS THE FIRST
TIME WE'VE EVER SEEN A NEUTRAL
POSITION THAT WE'VE ALLOWED SO
IT REALLY. I THINK BRINGS TO
LIGHT SOME OF THE- MAYBE SOME
OF THE DIRECTION THE BILL MAY
NEED TO GO- SO I JUST WANNA
SHARE MY OWN EXPERIENCE-
SUCCESS WE'VE HAD COBIT. SO I
WEAR HEARING AIDS I. DID NOT
REALIZE HOW MUCH I READ LIPS
UNTIL EVERYBODY WAS WEARING A
MASK. OKAY AND THEN ON TOP OF
THAT I HAVE SINUS PROBLEMS SO.
THE DIFFICULTY OF WEARING A
MASK THAT'S PROBABLY WHY MOST
YOU DON'T KNOW I SAID IN THE
BACK ROOM WITH THE BOX AROUND
YOU SO THAT I CAN ACTUALLY TAKE
THIS THING DOWN AND BREED. ONCE
IN A WHILE TO TRY TO KEEP MY
SINUSES CLEAR. THE MASK ALSO
CAUSES MOVEMENT WHEN YOU TALK
AND YOU GET BACK IN YOUR EAR
SO- I'M JUST SHARE A LITTLE BIT
I CAN ONLY IMAGINE WHAT IT'S
LIKE FOR STUDENTS WHO ARE
HEARING IMPAIRED AND ARE TRYING
TO BE IN THE ENVIRONMENT THEY
SHOULD BE IN I BELIEVE WHICH IS
IN THE NORMAL. CLASSROOM SO CAN
YOU MAYBE HELP ME FIGURE OUT-
WHAT WHAT THE ISSUE IS WITH THE
NEUTRALS AND WHAT AND WHERE
THEY'RE TRYING TO GO BECAUSE I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE
INCLUDE THESE. STUDENTS AND- OR
OR- AND I DON'T UNDERSTAND THE
LAWSUIT CAN YOU HELP ME OUT A
LITTLE BIT ON WHERE WE'RE
TRYING TO GO BECAUSE I THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT WE MAKE SURE
THAT THEY'RE- INCLUDED. OR ARE
THEY ALREADY I DON'T KNOW THAT.
YES OF THE MANAGER YES PLEASE
THANK YOU- YES THIS IS THE
FIRST OF ALL I TO WANT TO THANK
EVERYONE INVOLVED IN- CREATING
ACCESSIBILITY HERE TODAY THE
OPPOSITE THAT PROBABLY ALL FUEL
SHOULD ALWAYS BE. THE CASE AND
ALWAYS BE PRESENT- THANK YOU
SENATOR FOR SHARING YOUR LIVED
EXPERIENCE OF WITH US- WHAT
HAPPENED THE ISSUE THAT REALLY-
PROVOKED A LOT OF THE- ON THIS
BILL. EARLIER IN A GOOD WAY-
UNINTENTIONALLY BUT IN A GOOD
WAY IN TERMS OF ONGOING
DIALOGUE. WAS THE QUESTION OF
WHETHER OR NOT THIS FEDERAL
INDICATOR THAT. ESSENTIALLY
WE'RE BRINGING OVER- AS AS A AS
A TARGET FOR CALIFORNIA
SCHOOLS. AND LOCAL SCHOOLS IN
CALIFORNIA. QUOTE WE BY
SHORTHAND RECALLING FIVE A
LEAST RESTRICTIVE ENVIRONMENT-
WHETHER OR NOT THAT APPLIES. A
CROSS THE BORDER TO DISABLED
STUDENTS OR NOT AND THAT WAS
PARTICULARLY OF CONCERN-
FORWARD. THE COMMUNITY THAT WE
JUST HEARD FROM HE WAS SPEAKING
FROM A SAMPLE OF NEUTRALITY
BECAUSE IN EFFECT THE THEY DID
NOT WANT TO APPLY BECAUSE WHAT
FIVE THEY WOULD DO IS
INCENTIVIZE- IT POPULATING
CLASSROOMS YOU KNOW BY
INCLUSION- THAT COULD IN THEORY
INTERFERE WITH SOME OF THE BEST
PRACTICES- FOR THE DEAF
COMMUNITY- IT AND OTHERS WHERE
WERE GROUP ACTIVITIES ARE ARE
ACTUALLY VERY VERY CONDUCIVE.
TO FURTHERING EDUCATION. THE
BILL FUNDAMENTALLY DOESN'T
MANDATE ANY POPULATION QUOTAS
FOR REQUIREMENTS BECAUSE IT
STILL RELIES ON THE INDIVIDUAL
I E. P. P. THE- R. M. THE IN
THE IEP PLAN THAT SET UP
BETWEEN THE SCHOOLS AND THE
PARENTS FOR THE CHILDREN AS AS
THE FINAL- SORT OF DEMARCATION
AS TO WHAT HAPPENS WITH THAT
STUDENT WHETHER THEY ARE ARE
PUT INTO A MAINSTREAM CLASSROOM
WITH THEIR PUT IN ALL DAY.
WHETHER THEY'RE NOT PUTTING ALL
DAY ALL THAT'S IN THE I. E. P.
IN THIS BILL DOESN'T CHANGE
THAT PROCESS AT ALL SO THAT'S
REALLY. WHERE THE DECISIONS
WILL ACTUALLY BE MADE BUT BACK
TO- WHAT WE'RE HEARING FROM- I
THINK THE MOST THE NEUTRAL
TESTIMONY WE WERE PREVIOUSLY
OPPOSE THEY WERE PREVIOUSLY
OPPOSED- AT THE RISK OF PUTTING
WORDS IN THEIR MOUTH BECAUSE
THEY WANTED TO MAKE SURE THAT
THIS FIVE EIGHT INDICATOR
DIDN'T CAPTURE. THERE COMMUNITY
THERE'S THEIR STUDENTS THEIR
KIDS- IN IN. IN THE INCLUSION
TARGETS SO WE ARE TRYING TO GET
INCLUSION UP BY ABOUT 10% IN
CALIFORNIA FROM 53% ON AVERAGE
TO. CLOSER 263% WHICH IS THE
NATIONAL AVERAGE- IN. WITHOUT
MANDATING THAT JUST BY BRINGING
THIS THIS LEAST RESTRICTIVE
ENVIRONMENT TARGET AND PUTTING
ON A DASHBOARD WORDS IT'S THE
TRANSPARENCY WORDS HOW ARE WE
DOING- THE BELIEF IS THAT WILL
LEAD TO. TRAINING THERE'S
ONGOING THREE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS A YEAR IN THE BUDGET
FOR THAT KIND OF TRAINING. THIS
YEAR THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED
BUDGET AS ANOTHER TWO HUNDRED
FIFTY MILLION SPECIFICALLY FOR
THAT TYPE OF TRAINING- SO WE SO
WE THINK THE PIECES ARE THERE
TO START MOVING THAT UP FOR THE
FIRST TIME IN OVER A DECADE
THAT'S REALLY WHAT'S HAPPENING
PUT IN ORDER TO. FOR NOW
SATISFIED IN- CONCLUDED CENTER
TO SATISFY. THOSE VERY
LEGITIMATE CONCERN AND REQUESTS
FOR CLARIFICATION- WE WENT BACK
IN IN DRAFTED WITH THE HELP OF
THE COMMUNITY. OF VERY VERY
SPECIFIC. UNAMBIGUOUS
AMENDMENTS THAT- WE WERE HAPPY
TO BRING IN THE BASICALLY SAY
THIS INDICATOR WILL NOT. APPLY
TO THEM. GOOD TO THE COMMUNITY
OF OPPORTUNITY COMMITTEE
ESPECIALLY SCHOOLS DEAF BLIND
BUT DEAF BLIND- AND SO FORTH
SO. I DON'T WANT IF YOU IF YOU
HAVE A MOMENT BECAUSE I DON'T
WANT TO EXTEND THE HURRY TO
LONG BUT- IF YOU WERE TO LOOK
AT- IN THE BILL AN AMENDMENT
THAT'S MARKED- SEE. TWO LITTLE
EYES IT STARTS OFF OF LEAST
RESTRICTIVE ENVIRONMENT AS
MEASURED BY FEDERAL INDICATOR
FIVE EIGHTY IT GOES ON TO SAY.
THAT- THIS MANAGEMENT SHALL NOT
INCLUDE STUDENTS WHO ARE DEAF
HARD OF HEARING BLIND VISUALLY
IMPAIRED AND DEAF BLIND. AND
THEN IT OES ON TO SAY THAT IT
WILL ALSO NOT IMPACT ANY OF THE
RULES AROUND IDPS RIGHT NOW SO
WE WANTED TO DO IS BE VERY
INFORMATIVE ABOUT THAT IN THE
BILL EVEN THOUGH FIVE EIGHT
DOESN'T. ORDINARILY INCLUDE THE
POPULATION ANYWAY WE WANTED AB
LANGUAGES SAYS. AND THIS BILL
SPECIFICALLY CARDS OUT. OF THAT
COMMUNITY. I THINK IT'S BEEN A
BEAUTIFUL OPPORTUNITY IF I
COULD JUST SAY FOR THE FOR- THE
COMMUNITY- AROUND. THE TOUGH
BLIND DEAF BLIND. COMBINED FOR
THAT COMMUNITY TO ENGAGE IN THE
PASSION. THAT HAS ARRIVED AT
THE CAPITOL AROUND THESE ISSUES
ALMOST FEELS LONG OVERDUE AND
IT AND I HOPE. YOU KNOW THAT AS
WE ALL CONTINUE TO WORK- WITH
THE PARENTS OF THOSE STUDENTS
GOING FORWARD PERHAPS IN OTHER
LEGISLATION THAT WE ARE ABLE TO
FIGURE OUT IF THERE'S ANYTHING
MORE THAT WE CAN DO IT SOUNDS
LIKE THERE IS. A TO HELP WITH
THE ENRICHMENT OF THOSE
STUDENTS IT'S JUST NOT AS FIVE
A. INDICATOR SO THAT'S WHAT THE
COURT DID OUT. THANK YOU I HOPE
THAT WASN'T TOO LONG
EXPLANATION BUT I CREATION IS
EXCELLENT QUESTION. THAT'S VERY
HELPFUL THANK YOU I JUST- IT
MIGHT JUST. NEW TO THIS
COMMITTEE AND THESE ARE ALL
NEW- ASPECTS OF EDUCATION THAT
I WHO I'VE LEARNING I'M
LEARNING SO MUCH I'LL TELL YOU-
AT THE YEAH I THINK IT'S VERY.
PAUSE FOR. THE FOLKS HAVE JUST
TO BE ABLE TO BE IN. THE
CLASSROOM MY DATE WITH THAT
WITH I THINK IT'S GOOD FOR NOT
ONLY FOR THAT THAT STUDENT BUT
FOR THE OTHER STUDENTS AS WELL
TO UNDERSTAND. HOW DIFFICULT IT
IS SOMETIMES TO- YOU KNOW. WORK
TO SOCIETY. BUT THERE'S ALSO A
FINE LINE OF YOU KNOW. IS IT
TAKING AWAY FROM THE LEARNING
ABOUT OF ALL THE OTHER STUDENTS
AS WELL AND SO THAT IS THAT
ABILITY TO BE ABLE TO. DEFINE
WHERE THAT WHERE THAT LINE IS
UP TO THE LOCALS I HELPED AND
MAKE THAT DECISION AND SO.
ANYWAY I APPRECIATE YOUR
COMMENTS I DID READ THAT PART
WAS A LITTLE BIT CONFUSING TO
ME SO I WANT TO THANK THE CHAIR
I THINK THIS HAS BEEN. AWESOME
TO SEE THE- THE COMMUNITY BE
ABLE TO ACCESS THE LEGISLATURE
THROUGH- IN THE PROCESS WE WENT
THROUGH TODAY SO THANK YOU. NOT
BE SUPPORTING YOUR BILLS WELL.
THANK YOU CENTER DOLLY BEFORE I
GET TO- OTHER COMMITTEE MEMBERS
I WANT TO CHECK IN WITH OUR
INTERPRETER AND SEE IF SHE
NEEDS A BREAK. VERY GOOD WE'RE
GONNA TAKE A FIVE MINUTE RECESS.
GOING TO BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE SENATOR PAM. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH SECRETASE A FOR
THE FIRST FOUR MONTHS THANK YOU
FOR BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD-
IS A PEDIATRICIAN TO ACTUALLY
FOCUS ON CHILDREN WITH LEARNING
DISABILITIES- MAINLY PATIENTS
ARE IN SPECIAL EDUCATION AND- I
THINK IT'S VERY IMPORTANT THAT
WE TRY TO WE CAN FOR INCLUSION
APPRECIATE THE WORK YOU'RE
DOING A DEAF COMMUNITY TO THE
ORAL HEARING LOSS. HE TO
ADDRESS- THEIR ISSUES BUT I
THINK THE OVERALL THEME OF THE
BILL IS VERY IMPORTANT- AND-
ACTUALLY IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE
DO HAVE- STUDENTS WITH
DISABILITIES. IN SCHOOL. WHERE
FIRST OFF. SHOULD BE PRIMARILY
FOR THEIR OWN BENEFIT- BUT ALSO
IT IS FOR THE BENEFIT OF THE
OTHER STUDENTS TO. SUCCEED TO
HAVE THAT INCLUSION RIGHT AND
THEY SHOULD NOT BE INVISIBLE IN
OUR SCHOOL DISTRICTS NOT AND TO
SUPPORT IT OR NOT WHERE THEY
CAN'T CONNECT IN PLACE WE'RE
NOT INTERACTING WITH OTHER
STUDENTS ARE. WE SHOULD ALL
THAT'S A LEARNING LESSON FOR
ALL OF US SO. BUT CERTAINLY-
THANK YOU FOR READING THIS BILL
FORD CREATE THE WORK YOU'RE
DOING WITH THE OPPONENTS
OFFICIALLY DRESS THERE. ARE
CONCERNS WHO NOW SOUNDS LIKE A
GOOD NEUTRAL AND- WOULD BE
PLEASED WITH THE BUILT
APPROPRIATE TIME THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SENATOR PAN
ANY OTHER MEMBERS. ALL RIGHT
VERY GOOD MEMBERS WE HAVE A
MOTION BY SENATOR PAN BUT
BEFORE WE VOTE WE'RE GOING TO
GO BACK TO OUR RELAY SERVICE.
BECAUSE THIS IS NEW FOR ALL OF
US AND IT'S NEW FOR THE PEOPLE
CALLING IN WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT EVERYONE HAS AN
OPPORTUNITY. TO BE HEARD SO I'M
GOING TO GIVE THE NUMBER ONE
MORE TIME. EIGHT FOUR FOUR. TWO
NINE ONE FIVE FOUR NINE ZERO.
AND THE ACCESS CODE IS EIGHT
NINE EIGHT. SEVEN NINE TWO
SEVEN. MISTER MODERATOR CAN YOU
QUEUE UP ANYONE WHO WOULD. LIKE
TO SPEAK ON THIS BILL. STATING
THEIR NAME AND SUPPORT OPPOSITE
OR NEW. ON THE BILL. THANK YOU
AND THIS IS STILL FOR SB SIX
NINE TWO YES SIR. THANK YOU AND
IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO SHOW IT
SUPPORT. NEUTRAL OR OPPOSITION
ON SB SIX NINETY TWO PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT
THIS TIME. MAY T. T. OPERATOR
WILL GIVE YOUR LINE NUMBER
OFFLINE AND THE PLACE YOU BACK
IN THE QUEUE. SO SIMPLY PRESS
ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME TO QUEUE
UP. ONE MOMENT. AND THIS IS ON
THE EIGHTY A LIGHT IF YOU WOULD
LIKE TO QUEUE UP PLEASE PRESS
ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO TO SHOW
SUPPORT UTRA OR OPPOSITION TO
THIS BILL SIX NINE TWO M. ADAM
SURE WE DO HAVE A LINE AND
WE'LL GO TO LINE FIFTEEN.
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO THIS IS
A VIDA. IF ONLY A I'M WITH THE
CALIFORNIA. OF THE DEAF AND THE
PRESIDENT. I'M HERE OUR
POSITION WITH SB SIX NINE JUNE.
MITCHELL THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME THANK YOU. AND AGAIN
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO TO SHOW
OUR SUPPORT NEUTRAL. OR
OPPOSITION TO SB SIX NINETY TWO
AND WE ARE ON THE ABA LIKE. AND
WE WILL GO TO THE INTERPRETER
ONLINE NINETEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THE INTERPRETER AND I AM
REPEATING THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION A DOCTOR IS IN
NEUTRAL POSITION PRESIDENT OF
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
ADAPTER AT THE SIX NINE TWO
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. S. FINAL
REMINDER PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO ON EIGHTY A
LINE IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY ON BILL SB. SIX NINE
TWO. MADAM CHAIR THERE IS NO-
SKEWS ME WE DO HAVE A LINE
NINETEEN QUEUING UP PLEASE GO
AHEAD. AND THEY TOOK THEMSELVES
OUT. OKAY SO DOES THAT LOSE
WITH NO ONE IN Q. CORRECT
NOBODY ELSE'S QUEUED UP AT THIS
TIME. THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR
MODERATOR WE HAVE A MOTION BY
DR PAM ON SB SIX NINETY TWO
MANNUM CONSULTANT. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH SENATOR CORTESE WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE FIRST. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR- BUT LET ME
JUST PERSONAL THANK YOU AND-
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THE WORKING
WITH US CREATING THE SPACE IN
THE TIME FOR US TO WORK OUT
THESE FINAL MOMENTS ON THE
BILL- THANK YOU TO THE
DISABILITY COMMUNITY AT LARGE
FOR THEIR ENGAGEMENT- AND WHAT
I BELIEVE WILL BE THERE
CONTINUE LONG TERM ENGAGEMENT
NOT JUST ON THIS BILL BUT- WITH
THIS COMMITTEE IN THE FUTURE
WITH ALL OF US IN THE
LEGISLATURE. AND I DO WANT TO
PARTICULARLY THANK- THE BILL
SPONSORS- AND BY A CALL OUT TO
DOCTOR MERION THE ONE FOR HER
HARD HARD WORK IN. HELPING US
PUT THIS TOGETHER WITHOUT I
WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
I. BOATS THANK YOU THANK YOU
CENTER CORTESE THE BILLS MOVE
BY SENATOR PAN MADAM CONSULTANT
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL FILE
NUMBER ONE SB SIX NINETY TWO
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED BUT
FIRST BE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
LEYVA BY LEYVA HI OTRO ABODE HI
THE TUBE BY COURTESY CORTEZ THE
I'D- DELHI BY CLAY. MCGUIRE
MCGUIRE I PAN AM I BELIEVE THAT
BILL ON CALL FOR SENATE GLAZERS
VOTE THANK YOU MEMBERS AND
THANK YOU SO MUCH TURF AND ALL
THOSE WHO CALLED IN THIS WAS A
WONDERFUL. ALL RIGHT WE ARE NOW
GOING TO MOVE THE FILE ITEM TO
WHICH IS SENATOR LEYVA THAT IS
TO ME SO I'M GOING TO TURN THE
GAVEL OVER TO MY VICE CHAIR
SENATOR OCHO BUGS. THANK YOU.
WELCOME. WELCOME SENATOR LEYVA
YOU MAY PRESENT YOUR BILL ON SB
THREE SIX THREE THANK YOU MADAM
VICE CHAIR GOOD MORNING MEMBERS
SENATE BILL THREE SIX THREE
FURTHERS CALIFORNIA'S GOAL OF
PROVIDING EQUAL EDUCTION
OPPORTUNITIES TO ALL STUDENTS
BY REPEALING THE AMERICAN
LEGION'S EXCEPTION TO THE SEX
DISCRIMINATION PROVISIONS IN
THE CALIFORNIA EDUCATION CODE
THE BILL WILL ENSURE THAT THE
AMERICAN LEGION DOES NOT
FACILITATE OR SPONSOR PROGRAM
THAT DISCRIMINATES BASED ON
GENDER. A GIRL CALIFORNIA BOYS
STATE AND GIRLS STATE PROGRAMS
ARE INTENDED TO IMPART A BETTER
UNDERSTANDING OF GOVERNMENT AND
CIVIC RESPONSIBILITIES AS WELL
AS ACTIVE PARTICIPATION IN THE
PRIVILEGES AND RESPONSIBILITIES
OF DEMOCRACY. CALIFORNIA HAS
LONG HELD THAT ACCESS TO
EDUCATION IS A FUNDAMENTAL
RIGHT FOR ALL PERSONS
REGARDLESS OF THEIR GENDER.
ASSEMBLY YOUNG WOMEN
PARTICIPATING IN CALIFORNIA
GIRL STATE ARE NOT AFFORDED
COMPATIBLE CIVICS EDUCATION
OPPORTUNITIES AS YOUNG MEN IN
CALIFORNIA BOYS STATE. EVERY
YEAR WITH THE EXCEPTION OF THE
PANDEMIC APPROXIMATELY ONE
THOUSAND YOUNG MEN PARTICIPATE
IN BOYS STATE VISIT SACRAMENTO
AND THE STATE CAPITAL DURING
THE SUMMER. CALIFORNIA GIRLS
STATE WITH A NINETEEN EIGHT AS
EIGHTIES ERA CAP OF
APPROXIMATELY FIVE HUNDRED AND
FORTY PARTICIPANTS ARE ABLE TO
PARTAKE IN SOME OF THE ASPECTS
OF CIVIC EDUCATION. BUT ARE NOT
AFFORDED THE SAME ACCESS AND
OPPORTUNITY TO THE GOVERNMENT
AS BOYS HEALTH MOST NOTABLY IN
COMING TO SACRAMENTO AND
VISITING THEIR STATE CAPITOL.
ONE CANNOT DENY THAT THE
PRESENCE IN SACRAMENTO AFFORD
OPPORTUNITIES THAT STUDENTS MAY
NOT OTHERWISE HEALTH. IN TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN AN ARTICLE
HIGHLIGHTING A BOISE STATE ALUM
FROM SAN MARINO IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA HE TALKS ABOUT THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TOUR THE
CALIFORNIA SUPREME COURT
CHAMBERS IN THE STANLEY MOSK
LIBRARY AND COURTS BUILDING
ACROSS THE STREET FROM THE
CAPITOL AND ACTUALLY MEETING.
CALIFORNIA CHIEF SUPREMUM COURT
CHIEF JUSTICE TANI CANTIL
SECRETARY HE ALSO TALKED ABOUT
HOW HE LEARNED ABOUT THE
EXECUTIVE BRANCH FROM GOVERNOR
GAVIN NEWSOM ADDRESSING THE
BOYS STATE CONFERENCE ALL OF
WHICH HAPPENED HERE IN
SACRAMENTO. OTHER INEQUITIES
ALSO EXIST SUCH AS APPLICATION
FEES REGISTRATION FEES CAREER
FAIRS AND THE LEARNING OF
OUTDATED SONGS THAT FOCUS MORE
ON THE APPEARANCE OF YOUNG
WOMEN. ONLY THE WOMEN ARE
REQUIRED TO PAY ANY FEES. WHEN
WOMEN HAVE BEEN AND CONTINUE TO
BE LEGISLATIVE LEADERS SUCH AS
SENATE PRO TEM TONI ATKINS IT
IS IMPORTANT THAT YOUNG WOMEN
ARE ALSO EXPOSED TO AND LEARN
DIRECTLY FROM THESE
TRAILBLAZERS AS PART OF THE
GIRLS STATE PROGRAM. IN THE
WORDS OF SALLY RIDE THE FIRST
WOMAN IN SPACE YOU CAN'T BE
WHAT YOU CAN'T SEE. SO IT'S
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT THAT YOUNG
WOMEN ARE NOT DISADVANTAGED AND
ARE ALSO ABLE TO VISIT THE
HALLS OF POWER IN SACRAMENTO
AND THE CAPITAL. FIFTY YOUNG
MEN PARTICIPATING EMPLOYEES
STATE TO ALSO. I ALSO WANT TO
OFFER THAT WE DID RECEIVE A
LETTER FROM THE AMERICAN LEGION
AUXILIARY INDICATING THEIR
DESIRE TO BRING. THEIR GIRL
STATE PROGRAM TO SACRAMENTO. AS
WE MOVE FORWARD WITH THIS BILL
WE LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING
CONVERSATIONS WITH BOTH THE
AMERICAN LEGION. AND THE
AMERICAN LEGION AUXILIARY TO
ADVANCE OUR COMMITMENT TO
GENDER EQUITY. IN SUPPORT I
WOULD NOW LIKE TO INTRODUCE
JESSICA CENTER WITH EQUAL
RIGHTS ADVOCATES AND SHALL BE A
DAHLE WHO IS A TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN GIRLS STATE ALARM.
MEMBERS WOULD APPROPRIATE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU SENATOR LEYVA
WILL NOW MOVE ON TO OUR LEAD
WITNESSES- BUT DO WE HAVE
JESSICA STENDER ON THE ONLINE.
YES I'M HERE THANK YOU PLEASE
PERCENT GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN
OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS
JESSICA STENDER AND I'M AN
ATTORNEY WITH PEOPLE RIGHTS
ADVOCATES A NONPROFIT LEGAL
ORGANIZATION DEDICATED TO
PROTECTING AND EXPANDING
ECONOMIC AND EDUCATIONAL ACCESS
AND OPPORTUNITIES FOR WOMEN AND
GIRLS. SB THREE SIX THREE
ADDRESSING THE GENDER BASED
INEQUITY THAT IS PERPETUATED BY
AN OUTDATED EXCEPTION TO THE
FACT DISCRIMINATION
PROHIBITIONS ARE STATE
EDUCATION CODE. SECTION FORTY
PROGRAMS ACTIVITIES OF THE
AMERICAN SECONDARY EDUCATIONAL
INSTITUTION WITHIN COLLUDED
MIRROR SIMILAR SECTION AT THE
FEDERAL LEVEL. THE EXCEPTION
UNDER TITLE NINE OF THE IN THE
POLITICAL CON. WELL IT NEEDS
ARE THE IN INTENDED TO EASE
ORGANISING LIKE AMERICAN.
LEGALLY MANDATED FROM AND GIRLS.
ANY SUCH RATIONALITY OF. AT ANY
IN TIME. AND AS FAR OUTLIVED
AND PURPORTED TO. ESPECIALLY
TRUE HIS WITH KID AND BASED.
FINE THE FACE OF EXTENT PURPOSE
OUR STATE AND CIVIL RIGHTS LAW.
THE OPPOSITION THAT THE CREAN A
BETA LAW HELLO LONG IN THE
INTERVIEW. OF NINE PROVIDE.
LIKE OTHER FEDERAL RIGHTS LAW.
I DON'T MIND PROVIDE NEARLY OF
OR MINIMAL BASELINE OF
PROTECTION AGAINST BASED
DISCRIMINATION. UPON WHICH THE
LOCAL TRADE TO CREATE A
PROTECTION I THINK THIS OF A
SIMILAR. ON TITLE MY IS NOT.
CALIFORNIANS THE THIS ALLOCATED
I'M JUST EXCEPT UNDER LAW WHICH
IN THE FACE THE GREAT. OF THE
LAW. PARTICIPATING IN PROCESS
IS PER. HE DID NOT PROVIDE
SUBSTANTIALLY OPPORTUNITIES TO
GROW WITH NO JUSTIFIABLE BASIS
FOR THE DIFFERENCES. ALLOWING
GENEROUS COMMUNICATION
ESPECIALLY WHILE USING PUBLIC
RESOURCES AND ENGAGING WITH OUR
STATE LEGISLATURE FLIES IN THE
FACE OF THE VALUES OF OUR
STATE. SB THREE SIX THREE
PROVIDE A SIMPLE FIX BY
REMOVING THE BADLY NEEDED
ATTENTION FROM THE
NONDISCRIMINATION LANGUAGE
EDUCATION CODE TO ENSURE THAT
OUR LONG LIVE UP TO THEIR
PURPOSE. OF PREVENTING FACT
BASED DISCRIMINATION IN
EDUCATIONAL PROGRAMS AND
ACTIVITIES FOR THE PURPOSE. I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR I.
LOW. THANK YOU MUCH OF THE SEND.
WE WILL NOW MOVE ON TO OUR
SECOND LEAD OPPOSITION WITNESS
I MEAN SUPPORT WITNESS. SHELBY
ANGLE. PLEASE PROCEED. HELLO MY
NAME IS SHELBY AND ALL I
ATTENDED GIRLS STATE IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN AND RETURNED AS A
JUNIOR COUNSELOR IN TWENTY
NINETEEN. WHEN I FIRST ATTENDED
GIRLS STATE I WAS SO EXCITED TO
BE SELECTED TO PEPPER REPRESENT
MY SCHOOL IN SUCH A PRESTIGIOUS
PROGRAM AND ALL THE PROGRAM
POWERING. ALONGSIDE THE
COMMUNITY ALLOW ALL THE
AMBITIOUS YOUNG WOMEN FROM
ACROSS THE STATE WHAT WE
LEARNED ABOUT GOVERNMENT. THANK
YOU BACKROOM GIRL STAPLER ABOUT
WHAT MY MALE COUNTERPARTS DID
ACTUALLY STATE. NOT ONLY WAS IT
A LARGER PROGRAM WITH TWO BOYS
FROM MY SCHOOL ATTENDING
REGULARLY COMPARED TO THE ONE
THAT HAD BEEN GROWING STATE.
CAPITOL THE REPRESENTATIVE
OFFICES IN THAT SHOPPERS IN
REPRESENTATIVE BETA
PARTICIPATED IN A CAREER NIGHT
WHERE CALL DROPS AND LAW
ENFORCEMENT. THEY WERE EVEN
AWARDED CERTIFICATES.
RECOGNIZING THEIR ACHIEVEMENT.
NONE OF A LOT OF WERE AFFORDED
US. ABOUT LIKE WE WERE JUST.
INTO I THOUGHT YOU BOARD
LEADERS LASTLY THEY'RE HAVING A
DOCTOR TO SURELY OF OUR-
POLITICS SO AND NETWORKING
OPPORTUNITIES THE BOYS YOU SEE.
SO MANY DOORS OPEN TO THEM WERE
LEFT LOCKED. I THOUGHT ABOUT
THE TONE IN A- SONG THE GIRL.
ABOUT BOYS IN ATHENS GA OUT OF.
GIRL WALKING DOWN THE STREET.
THE PROGRAM I STRUCTURE. WHEN I
GOT THE LOCATION ISSUE WITH
CONCRETE BOB. I'VE BEEN TOLD
MANY DIFFERENT COMPUTING ANSWER
ALSO NOTE THAT THEY DON'T WANT
TO CHANGE BECAUSE OF THE
INCONVENIENCE. ABOUT RADA. EVEN
WHEN I PUT IN THE EFFORT
ADVENTURE THE CAPITAL TO GET
THE TICKET THE GIRL SINGER. THE
NUMBER PROVIDED ME WITH THE
INFORMATION NEEDED DESPITE
SAYING THEY WOULD. CHECK IN FOR
ME. BUT THE CHANGE IN THE
MILLIONS OF YOUNG WOMEN IN THE
STATE DESERVE BETTER I NEED.
YOU TO VOTE YES ON THAT SPELL
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MUCH I
MISS ANGLE WE WILL AT. NOW
MOVES ON TO OUR- A ROOM HERE IN
ROOM TWENTY TWO OH THREE DO WE
HAVE ANY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
SB SIX THREE THREE SIX THREE.
SEEN NONE DO WE HAVE ANY
WITNESSES IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY
WHO WISHES TESTIFIED IN SUPPORT
OF SB THREE SIX THREE CE. NINE
THANK YOU NUMBER ONE TWO
WITNESSES WANTING TO TESTIFY
VIA TELECONFERENCE SERVICE
MODERATE IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
PROMPT INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB THREE
SIX THREE WE WILL BEGIN. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH IF YOU WOULD LIKE
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT ONLY OF
S. B. THREE SIX THREE PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT
THIS TIME A. T. T. OPERATOR
WILL GO AHEAD GIVE YOUR LINE
NUMBER OFFLINE. AND THEN PLACE
YOU BACK INTO THE QUEUE SO
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. MADAM CHAIR IF YOU JUST
GIVE US A FEW MOMENTS HERE WE
DO HAVE. NUMBER PARTICIPANTS
QUEUING UP. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MODERATOR IN IF YOU WOULD
AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME GIVE ME
THE TOTAL NUMBER OF PEOPLE
WAITING TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT.
AT THIS TIME WE HAVE FOR. AND
WE WILL BEGIN TODAY WITH WINDS
SIXTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
JOHN THANK YOU TO IT YEAH. IT'S
GOING TO HIGH SUPPORTIVE THOUGH.
THANK YOU AND WE'LL GO TO LINE
FORTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU GOOD MORNING I'M
SHARING I'M FREE FORMER MAYOR
FRESNO LONG AGO PARTICIPANT IN
GIRL STATE THAT REPRESENTING
THE NATIONAL WOMEN'S POLITICAL
CAUCUS BOTH THE CAUCUS AND I
ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE
BILL THANK YOU. THANK YOU WE
WILL GO LINE THIRTY SIX NEXT.
HELLO MY NAME IS TURNING THE
DARI AND DO NOT CAL POLY CAN
WITH THE BEST PHONE NINE SPORT
OF THE. THANK YOU M. AND I'M
SURE WE HAVE- LOOKS LIKE FOR
MORE AT THIS POINT IS TO KEEP
YOUR- UPDATED AND YOUR WILL GO
TO LINE SIXTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI MY NAME IS SEBASTIAN IS ARE
YOU I'M A STUDENT AT UNIVERSITY
OF CALIFORNIA SANTA CRUZ I'M
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. ONE MOMENT
WHILE. WE WILL GO TO ONE
SEVENTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MY NAME IS IZZY DEMPSEY AND I'M
A STUDENT AT PORTLAND COMMUNITY
COLLEGE AND I'M IN SUPPORT OF
THE STYLE. THANK YOU. AND IT
SHOWED. EXCUSE ME SIR YOU WOULD
YOU PLEASE MUTE YOUR PHONE.
THANK YOU AND WE'LL GO TO LINE
SIXTY ONE. NECKBEARD YOU KNOW-
REPRESENTING BALLARD VETERANS
ALLIANCE OF ORANGE COUNTY WE
ARE IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU ONE
FORTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS VERA DARLIN AND I AM
THE TWENTY EIGHTEEN CALIFORNIA
GIRL ST ONE. REPORTER THE BILL
THANK YOU. THANK YOU ONE
SEVENTY ONE YOU ARE OPEN. HI
THERE MY NAME IS SUE TO BETTER
GO BY STEPHEN CRONIN AND I TEN
UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA SANTA
CRUZ I WOULD LIKE TO EXPRESS MY
SUPPORT FOR SENATE BILL THREE
SIX THREE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
M. MADAM CHAIR THERE IS NOBODY
ELSE QW ON THE REGULAR LINE WE
DO HAVE SOMEBODY QUEUED UP ALSO
ON THE S. B. A. LINE. S. B.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO GO TO THAT.
I'M SURE THANK YOU. OKAY. ONE
SEVENTY ONE YOU ARE OPEN.
MODERATOR FOR CLARIFICATION
PURPOSES- CAN YOU DEFINE THE S.
B. A. LINE. I AM SO SORRY WHAT
WAS THAT. THE S. B. LINE S. B.
A. LINE WOULD YOU MIND DEFINING
WHAT EXACTLY IS THE SB A LINE
OKAY I. I THINK IT WAS SOMEBODY
LEFT OVER FOR THE LAST ONE THAT
WAS A LINE FOR THE HEARING
IMPAIRED. ONE OF THE PREVIOUS
BILL BUT I THINK IT WAS JUST
SOMEBODY LEFT OVER THEY TOOK
THEMSELVES OUT TO Q. THANK YOU
SHOULD I. DISCONNECT THAT
BRIDGE. YES YES PLEASE. OKAY
THANK YOU. HAVING AND-
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
CHECK THE LINES ONE MORE TIME
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE HEARD
FROM ALL THE- WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OF SB THREE SIX THREE
PLEASE.
MODERATOR. I'M SORRY
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO I WAS ON MUTE IF YOU WOULD
LIKE TO SHOW YOUR SUPPORT FOR
SB THREE SIX THREE. PLEASE SHOW
US ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME TO
SHOW SUPPORT FOR SB THREE SIX
THREE. THANK YOU MODEL WE DO
HAVE ONE QUEUING UP ONE MOMENT.
WE WILL GO TO LINE FOURTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
DALY WATSON AND I'M A FORMER
DELEGATE I ATTENDED GIRLS STATE
IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN AND I
AM IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
THANK YOU. AND WE HAVE ONE MORE
INTERNET IS ONLINE SEVENTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS
IMMINENT UNANDERRA TO PREVIOUS
PARTICIPANTS STRONGLY SUPPORT.
THANK YOU I DON'T KNOW WHETHER
PARTICIPANTS QUEUED UP AT THIS
TIME. THANK YOU MODERATOR
HAVING HEARD FROM ALL
SUPPORTERS WILL NOW FOLLOW THE
SAME PROCESS IN HERE FROM ANY
OPPOSITION. WE DO HAVE TO LEAD
OPPOSITION WITNESSES WE HAVE
KIMBERLY MCKINNEY- DR KIMBERLY
MCKINNEY. FROM THE AMERICAN
LEGION AUXILIARY DEPARTMENT OF
CALIFORNIA GIRLS STATE CHIEF
COUNSELOR AND TIM ABU DARA
CHIEF COUNSEL FOR THE BOYS
STATE PROGRAM AMERICAN LEGION
DEPARTMENT OF CALIFORNIA- DR
MCKINNEY ARE YOU ON THE LINE.
YES I AM PLEASE PROCEED MA'AM.
HELLO MADAM CHAIR AND SENATORS
I AM DOCTOR KIMBERLY MCKINNEY
CENTER LEYVA IT IS A PLEASURE
TO SPEAK WITH YOU AGAIN AFTER
YESTERDAY'S LEGISLATIVE ACTION
DAY AND NOW TESTIFY IN REGARDS
TO HOW THIS COMMITTEE'S WORK
ALSO IMPACTS MY VOLUNTEERISM IN
THE COMMUNITY. THANK YOU FOR
SHARING ABOUT THE LETTER THE
AUXILIARY SENT YOUR OFFICE ON
MONDAY ROPOSING A NON
LEGISLATIVE SOLUTION THAT WOULD
RETURN ALAY GIRL STATE
SACRAMENTO WE BELIEVE THIS
PROPOSAL TO MOVE MOVING GIRL
STATE CAN PROVIDE THE EQUITABLE
OPPORTUNITIES THIS BILL SEEKS
TO SUPPORT WITHOUT HAVING
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES TWO
GIRLS STATE AND BE AN IMPORTANT
STEP IN OUR PROGRAM'S
EVOLUTION. LIKE MANY OF YOU ON
THIS COMMITTEE EQUITY IS ONE OF
MY CORE VALUES I SERVE AS THE
LEAD SAMBAR DINO COUNTY ACTUAL
WOMEN'S LEADERSHIP NETWORK
CREATED CALIFORNIA'S FIRST HIGH
SCHOOL WOMEN'S STUDIES COURSE
THAT WAS SELECTED AS CHIEF
COUNSELOR FOR CALIFORNIA GIRL
STATE IN TWENTY TWENTY.
REMOVING AT CO TWO TO FOUR
ELIMINATES ACCESS FOR GIRLS
STATE TO RECRUIT AND SELECT THE
MOST TALENTED AND DIVERSE
STUDENTS FROM OUR PUBLIC
SCHOOLS IT IS THROUGH OUR
RELATIONSHIP WITH SCHOOLS THAT
WE ARE ABLE TO OFFER THE
EXPERIENCE TO UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES AND SELECT STUDENTS
WITH DIVERSE ETHNIC RELIGIOUS
GEOGRAPHIC AND SOCIOECONOMIC
BACKGROUNDS BY BLOCKING ACCESS
TO PUBLIC SCHOOLS DISPARITIES
BETWEEN STUDENTS WITH GREATER
SOCIAL CAPITAL AND THOSE
WITHOUT WILL GROW. AT CO TWO TO
FOUR ALSO PROTECTS OUR SINGLE
GENDER PROGRAMS THAT IS
PROVIDING TIENEN SPACE FOR
DELEGATES TO GAIN THE NECESSARY
SKILLS TO BE A LEADER IN ANY
FIELD THEY CHOOSE WE AIM TO
FACILITATE OPPORTUNITIES FOR
DELEGATES TO BE THEIR AUTHENTIC
SELVES AND ENCOURAGE THEM TO
TAKE RISKS MAKE MISTAKES AND
FIND THEIR VOICE. IN THE LEARN
HOW TO ADVOCATE. IT IS IT
AWESOME TO SEE THIS GIRL
FAILING NOT FOUND VOICE PART
BECAUSE OF THIS. SPACE GIRL
STATE PROVIDED. HOWARD WOMEN
EMPOWER WOMEN ARE ALL WOMEN
LEADERSHIP TEAM SELECT STRONG
FEMALE STAFF MEMBERS AND
SPEAKERS WITH DIVERSE RACES
RELIGIONS AND GENDER IDENTITIES
TO GUIDE THE DELEGATES. OUR
VOLUNTEERS ARE LEADERS IN THE
BUSINESS HEALTH EDUCATION
SCIENCE AND POLITICAL FIELD TO
DEDICATE THEIR TIME TO SERVE IN
THE DELEGATES. WHO TEN GIRLS
STATE I THE CURRENT PUBLIC
SCHOOL ADMINISTRATOR I KNOW THE
CRITICAL TOPICS THIS COMMITTEES
DEALING WITH I URGE YOU TO VOTE
NO AND ALLOW US TO WORK WITH
THE AUTHOR OF THE BILL AS
PROPOSED. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH DR
MCKINNEY- DO WE HAVE MISTER TIM
DARRAGH. ON THE LINE. GOOD
MORNING EMILY HER. YES SIR CAN
YOU HEAR ME YES WE CAN'T KEEP A
GOOD MORNING SENATOR LEHMAN
MEMBERS OF THE SENATE EDUCATION
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS TIM ABBOTT
YOU'RE A SENIOR. I'VE BEEN
SERVING AS THE CHIEF COUNSEL OF
THE AMERICAN LEGION CALIFORNIA
BOYS STATE PROGRAM SINCE TWO
THOUSAND AND NINE I'M HERE TO
SPEAK TO YOU TODAY IN
OPPOSITION TO SENATE BILL THREE
SIXTY THREE THIRTY KILLING AT
THE EXEMPTION CURRENTLY
PROVIDED TO FAIL A GIRL STATE
AND OUR PROGRAM. AND IN FULL
SUPPORT OF THEM THE NON
LEGISLATIVE SOLUTION THAT WOULD
BRING ILLEGAL STATE BACK TO
SACRAMENTO. GUIDING PRINCIPLE
IN CALIFORNIA BOYS STATE IS A
LEVEL PLAYING FIELD EVERY
DELEGATE ARRIVES WITH NO
ADVANTAGE OVER ANOTHER THIS
GIVES EVERY DELEGATE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO EXCEL AND PURSUE
WHATEVER ELECTED OR NON ELECTED
OFFICE THEY WISH. POTENTIAL
DELEGATES ARE NOMINATED BY
THEIR SCHOOLS AND CHOSEN BY
LOCAL SPONSORING AMERICAN
LEGION POST. THE DEMOGRAPHIC OF
OUR PARTICIPANTS 4% STOP
STUDENTS FROM THEIR RESPECTIVE
SCHOOLS REGARDLESS OF GEOGRAPHY
OR SOCIO ECONOMIC FACTORS
AMERICAN LEGION BOYS STATE
PROGRAM IS A WEEK THAT SEEKS A
LIFETIME. THE BEST EVIDENCE WE
CAN OFFERS TO WELL KNOWN ALUMNI
OF OUR PROGRAM YOU IN TRADE
AMBASSADOR GETTING BASKET IS
WHO IS THE SON OF IMMIGRANTS
IMMIGRANT PARENTS ATTENDED BOYS
STATE AND WENT ON. TO BE BOTH
AN AMBASSADOR AND DIRECTOR OF
THE PEACE CORPS AND FORMER
MONEY MAYOR ANDRE QUINTERO CAME
FROM A DISADVANTAGED AREA WAS
SELECTED BOYS STATE GOVERNMENTS
FROM DISK COMMUNITY FOR NEARLY
TWENTY YEARS. IT LOCAL ELECTED
POSITIONS. THE ACCESS TO OUR
HIGH SCHOOL. PARTNERS AS CHIEF
COUNSEL STATED WOULD DEPRIVE
MANY FEEL FEMALE AND MALE. LIKE
MAYOR CONTAINER OF THE
OPPORTUNITY TO LEARN HOW OUR
SYSTEM OF GOVERNMENT IS
SUPPOSED TO WORK. WE LIKE GIRLS
STATE BELIEVE THAT TEACHERS AND
COUNSELORS IN OUR SCHOOLS THOSE
CLOSEST TO STUDENTS. ARE THE
BEST RESOURCE TO RECOGNIZE
CURRENT LEADERS IN THEIR
SCHOOLS IN OUR LEADERS OF
TOMORROW. ELIMINATING THAT
PARTNERSHIP WOULD HAVE ACCESS
TO BOTH PROGRAMS ONLY TO THOSE
IN THE KNOW. WE KNOW THERE HAS
BEEN OVER TWENTY FIVE YEARS
SINCE GROCERY LAST CONDUCTED
THIS PROGRAM IN THE SACRAMENTO
AREA WELL BOYS FEEDING GROW
STATE OR SPONSORED. BY TWO
COMPLETELY SEPARATE
ORGANIZATIONS AS DOCUMENTED IN
OUR OPPOSITION STATEMENTS. THE
AMERICAN LEGION AUXILIARY
SPONSORING GIRLS STATE AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF CALIFORNIA
SPONSORING BOYS STATE. BOTH
ENTITIES SHARE A COMMON MISSION
WITH THESE PROGRAMS TO INSTILL
THE IMPORTANCE OF CIVIC
RESPONSIBILITY. CAN REGION
CALIFORNIA BOYS STATE PROGRAM
IS COMMITTED TO SUPPORTING THE
GIRL STATE RETURNED TO
SACRAMENTO AND CONNECTING THEM
WITH ALL THE LOCAL SACRAMENTO
RESOURCES. THAT HAVE SUPPORTED
BOYS STATE SENATORS WE ASK THAT
YOU EMBRACE AND NON LEGISLATIVE
SOLUTION PROPOSED BY THE
EXEMPLARY BY VOTING NO ON
MOVING SB THREE SIXTY THREE
FORWARD CHIEF COUNSEL MCKINNEY
AND I REPRESENT ALL OF THE
VOLUNTEERS THAT MAKE THESE
PROGRAMS HAPPEN. YES FROM THE
GROUND UP TO THE FUND RAISING
TO. TO PAY FOR THE STUDENTS TO
COME TO THE PROGRAM TO THE ALL
VOLUNTEER STAFF WE ASK THAT YOU
SUPPORT OUR EFFORTS FOR ALL OF
OUR USING CONTINUE TO SUPPORT
OUR EFFORTS FOR LEADERS OF
TOMORROW. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR ABU DAR.
WE WILL NOW MOVE ON TO
WITNESSES HERE IN ROOM FORTY
TWO OR THREE DO WE HAVE ANY
WITNESSES I'M HERE IN ROME FOR
FORTY TWO OR THREE SEEN NONE.
DO WE HAVE ANY WITNESSES IN
ROOM TWENTY FORTY. TWO IST WHO
WISH TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION
OF SB THREE SIXTY WE SEE NONE.
THANK YOU WE WOULD NOT MOVE ON
TO WITNESSES READY TO TESTIFY
VIA THE TELECONFERENCE.
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
PROMPT INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION. SB THREE
SIX THREE WE WILL BEGIN. THANK
YOU MIKE IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO- SB
THREE SIX THREE PLEASE PRESS
ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO ON YOUR
TOUCH TONE PHONE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MODERATE IF YOU WANT
WE WILL BUILD. I THINK STATE.
POLICE SAID AT ONCE IT'LL TELL
YOU IF YOU'RE INTO OUR QUEUE SO
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO AGAIN. ND WILL BEGIN
TODAY WITH WIND TWENTY FIVE.
HELLO. YOUR OPEN. HELLO WE CAN
HEAR YOU. PLEASE CALL WRITING
BEVERLY YOUR HONOR MY NAME IS
BEVERLY TAYLOR I'M A CALIFORNIA
EIGHTY ELLIEBAMBER I WALKED A
LITTLE CALIFORNIA GROW EIGHT
CONSTITUTION CALIFORNIANS CITY
MOM. BOND HERE I OPPOSE. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU AN EXCELLENT
LINE TWENTY FOUR. PLEASE ON
MUTE. TWENTY FOUR. THE MORNING
CARE MEMBERS MY NAME IS SET TO
READ WHICH READ GOVERNMENT
RELATIONS REPRESENTING AMVETS.
IRMA CALIFORNIA MILITARY
OFFICERS ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA
COUNCIL OF CHAPTERS IN STRONG
OPPOSITION TO THE PROPOSED BILL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ARE MOVING
ALONG WE WILL TOO LINE THIRTEEN.
FIND. THIRTEEN I THINK THEY
TOOK THEMSELVES OUT ACUTE-
WE'LL GO TO LINE TWENTY SIX. BY
TWENTY SIX ARE YOU MUTED PLEASE
ON MUTE YOUR PHONE. HI MY NAME
IS ELAINE CHAO I AM AN AMERICAN
THESE OTHER CALIFORNIA GIRL
SILANIS. AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL
AS IT IS WRITTEN. THANK YOU M.
LINE TWELVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
MY NAME IS SAMANTHA PATRICK I
AM A TWO THOUSAND TEN GROWTH
STATE ALUMNI AND I OPPOSE THAT.
THANK YOU AND NEXT WE'LL GO TO
LINE THIRTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO CAN YOU HEAR ME OK. WE
GET HELLO. YOU THANK YOU
APOLOGIES HI MY NAME IS LORN
BALANCED AND I IN THE LA
CALIFORNIA GIRL A LOT NOTHING.
THREE THOUSAND SEVENTEEN
SESSION AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THANK YOU AND AS A REMINDER OUR
GOAL AND IT ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO- SHOW
OPPOSITION TO SB THREE SIX
THREE AND WE'LL GO TO LINE
SEVENTY FOUR. PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING. I LIVE IN APPLE
VALLEY I AM A SEVENTY TWO YEAR
MEMBER OF THE AMERICAN LEGION
AUXILIARY I HAVE WATCHED YEARS
OF GIRLS BECOMING WONDERFUL
REPRESENTATIVES OF OUR COUNTRY
I OPPOSE THIS BILL. THANK YOU
AND WE'LL GO TO LINE SIXTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE SIXTY
NINE. PLEASE ON MU SIXTY NINE.
HELLO I'M NANCY BROWN PART.
PAST NATIONAL PRESIDENT
AMERICAN LEGION AUXILIARY FIFTY
YEAR VOLUNTEER CALIFORNIA GIRLS
STATE AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL AS
WRITTEN. THANK YOU. AND AS A
REMINDER PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. ANNEX WE WILL
GO TO LINE SEVENTY SEVEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. BY SEVENTY SEVEN YOU
ARE OPEN. THE NEW. SEVENTY
SEVEN- MOVING ALONG WILL ONE
MOMENT. PLEASE WE'LL GO TO LINE
TWENTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO MY NAME IS MAGGIE TAYLOR
AHEARN I'M AN AMERICAN LEGION
AUXILIARY GIRLS STATE ALUM FROM
TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN CHANNEL
HELD HIGH SCHOOL CURRENTLY
RESIDING IN SAN JOSE CALIFORNIA
AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL AS
BRITNEY. THANK YOU ONE TWENTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY
NAME IS DOMINIQUE BELMONT I AM
IN LA LA CALIFORNIA GIRL TAYLOR
NINETY THOUSAND FOURTEEN AND
AYE OPPOSED TO CELEBRATE. THANK
YOU ONE TWENTY NINE. YOU ARE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU MY
NAME IS TRISH TOWARD AMERICAN
LEGION AUXILIARY NUMBER AND
APOSS COUNSELOR OF CALIFORNIA
GIRL STATE AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL AS WRITTEN. PROGRADE ENTER
THE FINAL A REMINDER LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
OPPOSE THIS BILL S. B. THREE
SIX THREE PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
AT THIS TIME. AND ONE MOMENT
PLEASE. WE DO A ONE MORE
PARTICIPANT QUEUING UP. ACTED
THEY TOOK THEMSELVES OUT TO Q.
WHILE WE DO HAVE ANOTHER ONE
QUEUING UP ONE MOMENT. TO BE
WITH US MOMENTARILY. AND WE
WILL GO TO LINE THIRTY PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS CAITLYN
BOX AND I'M IN A REALLY
CALIFORNIA GIRLS PLAY A LONG
NIGHT AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THANK YOU. AND NEXT WE WILL GO.
TO EIGHT THREE. WHAT THE CLOVER
LINE SEVENTEEN. YES MY NAME IS
DON HARPER HI AM NINE THE
LEGISLATION COMMISSION FROM
AMERICAN LEGION DEPARTMENT
CALIFORNIA- EMAIL ADDRESS.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU EMPLOYEES
ONE MOMENT. JERRY SO NO ONE
ELSE QUEUED UP AT THIS TIME
THANK YOU MODERATE IF YOU MIGHT
IF YOU WOULDN'T MIND PLEASE
CHECK IN THE LINES ONE MORE
TIME TO MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE
HEARD FROM ALL OUR WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION TO SB THREE SIX
THREE PLEASE. THANK YOU. FINAL
REMINDER UP PLEASE PRESS. ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO TO SHOW
OPPOSITION FOR S. B. THREE SIX
THREE THANK YOU. AND WE GOT A
COUPLE MORE CUED UP WE WILL GO
TO LINE SEVENTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS CINDY
NEWMAN AND I AM OPPOSED TO THIS
BILL I AM A PUBLIC SCHOOL.
PERSON WHO HAS BENEFITED FROM
ACCESS TO ALL TYPES OF PROGRAMS
THANK YOU. THANK YOU M. WE WILL
GO TO LINE SEVENTY EIGHT PLEASE
GO AHEAD. YES THIS IS BILL
MILLER CAN YOU HEAR ME OK. YES
SIR. MY NAME IS BILL MILLER A
MUCH THIRTY EIGHT YEAR NUMBER
OF THE AMERICAN LEGION IN THE
NINETEEN SEVENTY THREE GRAD
FROM THE CONNECTICUT- BOISE
STATE. SERIOUS OPPOSITION TO
THIS BILL AS WRITTEN THANK YOU.
AND THANK YOU WE WILL GO TO ONE
MOMENT PLEASE MADAM CHAIR. NEXT
WE'LL GO TO LINE THIRTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS
AVAILABLE YEAH AND I'LL CLOSE
THIS BE THAT'S RIGHT TO. THANK
YOU. WHY TWENTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THEY TOOK THEMSELVES
OUT- I'M SURE WE HAVE NO OTHER
PARTICIPANTS QUEUED UP THANK
YOU MODERATOR THANK YOU TO ALL
OUR SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION
WITNESSES WILL NOW BRING THE
DISCUSSION BACK TO OUR MEMBERS
TO ANY OF OUR MEMBERS HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS AT THIS
TIME. SENATOR DALY. SO I HEARD
A LOT OF COMMENTS ABOUT- HAS
WRITTEN THAT DIED AT THE TEST
NAY IN THE OPPOSITION HAS MY
FIRST I WANNA SAY BOTH MY SONS
WENT TO BOISE AND I'M HOPING MY
DAUGHTER WILL BE ABLE TO GO AND
I'M HOPING TO BILL GOAL HERE IN
SACRAMENTO SO I. I'M TRYING TO
GRASP. I KNOW YOU'RE TRYING TO
DO BUT SO CAN YOU CAN YOU MAYBE
EXPLAIN A LITTLE BIT ON WHERE
YOU'RE HEADED OR WHAT THE
OPPOSITION IS THERE SOME
NEGOTIATIONS OR NOT IF WE CAN
ACCOMPLISH WITHOUT LEGISLATION
WOULD BE AWESOME BUT I. CAN YOU
MAYBE EXPAND ON A LITTLE BIT.
THANK YOU CENTER DOLLARS SO WE
ALWAYS WORK WITH THE OPPOSITION
WE'VE HAD MANY CONVERSATIONS
MANY MEETINGS WITH THEM AND
THIS BILL IS JUST. I WILL FIRST
SAY I HAD NO IDEA THAT BRINGING
PARITY TO THESE PROGRAMS WOULD
BE CREATE SO MUCH OPPOSITION WE
JUST WANNA MAKE SURE THAT YOUNG
WOMEN HAVE THE SAME
OPPORTUNITIES THAT YOUNG MEN
HAVE. AND WHEN THIS WAS FIRST
BROUGHT TO MY ATTENTION I'D
SPOKEN AT A GIRL STATE- MEETING
IN CLAREMONT AND THAT THE
REQUISITE FIVE HUNDRED AND
FORTY SO THAT'S ALREADY YOU
KNOW NOT PARITY THE BOYZ HAVE
THOUGHT BUT THOUSAND. WERE
THERE THEY WERE AMAZING WAS A
GREAT EXPERIENCE AND THEN
WITHIN A COUPLE WEEKS I WAS UP
HERE AND I SEE THOUSAND BOYS
RUNNING AROUND THE CAPITAL AND
I'M LIKE WHERE THE GIRLS. AND
THEY SAID ALL THAT YOU KNOW THE
GIRLS DON'T GET TO COME TO
SACRAMENTO SO I CIVIL THAT
SEEMS WRONG IF YOU CAN'T SEE IT
YOU CAN'T BE IT AND WE LOOK A
LITTLE FURTHER INTOIT WE SEE
THAT THE GIRLS HAVE TO PAY FEES
THERE'S A SEVENTY FIVE DOLLAR
APPLICATION FEE IS SIXTY
DOLLARS- ANOTHER FEE THAT SIXTY
DOLLARS. ALL WE'RE TRYING TO DO
IS CREATE PARITY WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT THE SAME
OPPORTUNITIES AFFORDED TO THE
YOUNG MEN ARE FOR TO THE YOUNG
WOMEN AS YOU HEARD. ONE OF THE
LEAD OPPOSITION SAY- TALKED
ABOUT TWO MEN WHO ONE WAY I
KNOW VERY WELL THE GREAT
EXPERIENCE THEY HADAND LEAD
THEM TO GOVERNMENT WE WANT
YOUNG WOMEN TO SEE THEMSELVES
AND GOVERNMENT. WE WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE
OPPOSITION WILL CONTINUE TO
TALK TO THEM AND IF WEEK
WHATEVER WE CAN DO. OUR CONCERN
IS THAT WE GOT THE LETTER. WE
JUST WANNA MAKE SURE IT
ACTUALLY HAPPENS IT SHOULDN'T
HAVE TO TAKE LEGISLATION TO GET
THEM TO THINK. ABOUT CREATING
PARITY. I DON'T KNOW IF THE
ANSWERS YOUR QUESTION BUT WE
WILL ALWAYS WORK WITH
OPPOSITION WE BEAR MAY NOT GET
THEIR BUT WE'RE HAPPY TO WORK
WITH THEM. THANK YOU DR PAN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- AND- A
TRANSFIGURED- SERVICES ANSWER
THIS QUESTION BUT I MEAN
FUNDAMENTALLY LEASES I READ
ANALYSIS ALL THE BILL DOES IS
IT SAYS THAT- WE REMOVE AN
EXCEPTION TO. SEX
DISCRIMINATION PROVISIONS. WHAT
YOU THINK INHERENTLY WHY WE
CREATING EXCEPTIONS IN THE
FIRST PLACE THE MAN HEARD
OPPOSITION TESTS MAY TALK ABOUT
THE PROGRAM LIKE SELF
DESTRUCTOR AND BUT TO ME THE-
WHY WOULD THAT BE THE CASE I'M
NOT SURE I'M CONNECTING. I
APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR'S DESIRE
FOR PARITY- I WOULD MAKE NOTE
THAT EVEN THE OPPOSITION I MEAN
PEOPLE POINTED OUT THEY ARE
SPONSORED BY DIFFERENT
ORGANIZATIONS AND SO FORTH SO.
EACH ORGANIZATION DESIGNED
AROUND PROGRAM BUT THIS WOULD
TO ME WHAT THIS WOULD ALLOW AND
MAYBE AGAIN IF I GOT A WRONG
SOMEONE EXPLAINED TO ME THAT IF
A GIRL DECIDES THEY WANT TO GO
TO VOICE BECAUSE THEY GOT A
BETTER PROGRAM THAN. THEY CAN'T
DISCRIMINATE AGAINST THE GIRLS
SO- WHETHER THEY WANT TO DO
PARITY ARE NOT TWO SEPARATE
ORGANIZATIONS TO SEPARATE
SPONSORS. SPONSORING
ORGANIZATIONS- SHOULDN'T THE
STUDENTS HAVE THE CHOICE. TO
DECIDE WHICH PROGRAM THEY GO TO
IF THEY'RE IF THEY'RE GONNA
PERSISTENT HAVING DIFFERENCES.
SO I'M NOT SURE WHAT WE
CREATING EXEMPTIONS IN THE
FIRST PLACE TO DISCRIMINATION
LAWS. AND SO TO ME IT MAKES
SENSE TO PUT THE STILL MAKES A
LOTOF SENSE SO I'M NOT SURE OF
WHERE TO DISCONNECT HIS FOR ME
IN TERMS OF BY THE OPPOSITION
IS SO UPSET ABOUT. REMOVING AN
EXEMPTION THAT. I MEAN IF. THEY
WERE STILL ON TO THE PROGRAM WE
CAN DO THE PROGRAM THEY JUST
CAN'T DISCRIMINATE. IT'S JUST
SOMETHING THAT I THOUGHT THAT
WE WOULD ALL BE IN FAVOR OF THE
OF SO- AND PERHAPS ON OF THE
AUTHOR OR MAYBE THE LEAD
OPPOSITION WANTS TO ADDRESS
THAT. I WOULD JUST SAY CENTER
PAM THANK YOU THAT'S KIND OF
WHAT WE THOUGHT TOO WE DID NOT
THINK THAT THERE WOULD BE THIS
MUCH OPPOSITION TO THE BILL
WE'VE SEEN A BOY SCOUTS OF
AMERICA CHANGE WHEN I WAS A
LITTLE GIRL AND MY- BROTHER WAS
A BOY SCOUT I WANTED TO BE A
BOY SCOUT. AND THEY WOULD NOT
LET ME JOIN I USED TO SIT
OUTSIDE THE MEETINGS AND CRY-
AND NOW THINGS HAVE CHANGED AND
THE GIRLS CAN'T PARTICIPATE IN
BOY SCOUTS IF THEY WOULD LIKE
TO EMPLOYEES CAN PARTICIPATE IN
GIRL SCOUTS IF THEY SO CHOOSE.
SO I THINK YOU SEEN OTHER
ORGANIZATIONS OF ALL AND THAT'S
REALLY ALL WE'RE ASKING OF OUR
BOYS STATE AND THE WOMEN'S
AUXILIARY TAKE A MOMENT OF
INTROSPECTION. ALL WE'RE
LOOKING FOR IS PARITY. AND IF
YOU WANT TO HEAR FROM SOMEONE
ELSE. I'M NOT SURE THE LA. UP
LEAD UP. IS CAN'T A DOCTOR
KIMBERLY MCKINNEY IS SHE STILL
ON THE LINE. JOINT ADDRESSED
THE COURT YES I AM YEAH. SO
WHAT WHAT WE WHAT WE WHAT WE
WANT TO CONTINUE TO CREATE AN
EXEMPTION TO SOMETHING THAT I
HOPE THAT WE CAN ALL AGREE ON.
IN TERMS OF NOT HAVING
DISCRIMINATION AND YOU CAN
OPERATE PROGRAM HOW YOU WANT
BUT YOU CAN'T SCREAM EIGHT. WE
ABSOLUTELY SUPPORT. EIGHTY
BRINGING PARITY TO THE PROGRAM
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING.
WITH US SENATOR LEYVA. AND
MOVING FORWARD ON BEING ABLE
TO. HAVE THIS PROGRAM MOVED TO
SACRAMENTO WE FULLY SUPPORT
THAT AND WE- EMBRACE THE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR OUR
DELEGATES. Q. HAVE SOME OF THE
SIMILAR EXPERIENCES THAT WERE
OUTLINED TODAY. WHAT WAS THE
REASON WHY WE ARE ASKING FOR
THE EXEMPTION IS NOT BECAUSE OF
THE LOCATION OF THE PROGRAM BUT
IT IS BECAUSE OF THE ACCESS IF
WE CHOOSE TO BE A SINGLE GENDER
PROGRAMS. THAT CREATE THE
ENVIRONMENT THAT WE SEEKTO
CREATE AT GIRLS STATE THAT
SUPPORTS WOMEN. AND ALLOWS THEM
TO DEVELOP THEIR VOICE FREE OF.
AS MALE AS DOMINANT BUT FOR
THEM TO BE ABLE TO DO THAT ON
THEIR OWN WE WANT TO WITH THE
EXEMPTION IT ALLOWS US TO
CONTINUE TO RECRUIT THROUGH.
THE PUBLIC SCHOOLS IF THE
EXEMPTION WAS REMOVED WE WOULD
LOSE THAT OPPORTUNITY AND
THAT'S WHAT IT IS NOT ABOUT
EATING SOMETHING WIDELY SAID
HER GRAM SO I SEE THAT I'M
SORRY. INTERRUPT BUT- WHY WOULD
YOU ABILITY TO AND SO SOME
DISAPPEAR IF YOU. DON'T HAVE
EXEMPTS FROM. THAT DOESN'T SEEM
TO I DON'T SEE HOW THIS TO
CONNECT. RIGHT AND I AGREE IF
IT'S THE IF WORD. FOR USING THE
WORD BEFORE USING
DISCRIMINATION AS WHAT WE'RE
ASKING FOR EXEMPTION FROM AND
THAT'S NOT WHAT WE'RE ASKING
FOR EXEMPTION FROM WE'RE ASKING
FOR EXEMPTION TO BE A SINGLE
GENDER PROGRAMS THAT CAN THEN
GO AHEAD. AND STILL CONTINUE TO
RECRUIT AS PART OF IT THE
EXTRACURRICULAR ACTIVITIES THAT
ARE. AFFORDED THROUGH THE
SCHOOL SYSTEM WE WANT TO BE
ABLE TO GAIN ACCESS AND SHOULD
CONTINUE TO PARTNER WITH
SCHOOLS TO BRING THAT IN AND TO
BRING GIRLS TO THE CAPITAL TO
BRING GIRLS TO OUR PROGRAM BUT
WE WANT TO BE ABLE TO DO THE
THINGS THAT ARE GOING TO CREATE
AN OPPORTUNITY FOR WOMEN TO
DEVELOP. EIGHTY EIGHT
GOVERNMENT EIGHT PROGRAM A. AS-
A VOICE THAT IS DONE SO IN A
SAFE SPACE WHERE THEY ARE ABLE
TO DO SO WITH JUST WOMEN. OKAY
ALL RIGHT WELL I AM STILL NOT
SURE I SEE WHERE YOU CAN'T
RECRUIT IN SCHOOLS BUT I HEAR
WHAT YOU'RE SAYING ABOUT. A
GIRLS ONLY PROGRAM- BUT YOU
KNOW WHAT I THIS THIS
DEFINITELY IS A DISCUSSION THAT
DESERVES TO CONTINUE- AND I
THINK THAT I AM STILL VERY
CONCERNED BECAUSE WE DO HAVE
YOU KNOW WE HAVE. I MEAN THE
SUPPLIES EVERYONE ELSE
INCLUDING WE TALKED ABOUT SCOUT
HILLS WITH THE AUTHOR REFERRED
SCOUTING AS WELL- SO- DANTE
EIGHT SO I'M I'M GONNA MOVE THE
BILL BECAUSE I THINK IMPORTANT
TO CONTINUE THIS DISCUSSION-
AND- THEY ALL RIGHT AND FRANKLY
I'M NOT SURE I'M TOTALLY
CONVINCED- THOSE TO THE
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL- SO
CERTAINLY- NOT ONLY MOVING
FORWARD WILL BE VOTING FOR THIS
BILL- BUT- ALSO IT. OFFICIALLY
THAT THE AUTHORS COMMITTED TO
CONTINUING THE CONVERSATION AND
I KNOW THE AUTHOR CERTAINLY.
CARES VERY MUCH ABOUT THE SAID
ABOUT ABOUT THE DOES THE
SUCCESSFUL DEVELOPMENT OF WOMEN
AND. AND THE GIRLS AND THEN OUR
STATE THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
LATER HAND ADDED. BECAUSE TWO
TO THREE CURRENT EXISTS FOR BOY
GROUP SCOUT SCOUTS WHY AM
PROGRAM AND YWCA CROWGRAMS
IT'S A SEPARATE EXEMPTION THAT
CURRENTLY EXISTS BUT WE ALSO
COMPLETELY SUPPORT SENATOR
LEYVA IN HER AND IN HER EFFORTS
AND ALL THE THINGS THAT SHE
DOES TO. BRING GENDER PARITY
AND TO DO THESE THINGS SO JUST
WANTED TO LET YOU KNOW ABOUT
OKAY THAT THAT CENTRALIZING
IT'S NOT IN STATE LAW WE'RE
WE'RE STATE LEGISLATURES THANK
YOU. AT MADAM CHAIR IF I MAY.
THEY CAN STILL HELP SINGLE SEX
PROGRAMS IS LONG DISTANCE
THERE'S SUBSTANTIALLY EQUAL
ACCESS FOR BOTH SEXES OF YOU
WANTED TO BREAK OUT SESSIONS
THAT WERE SOMETHING THAT WAS
CONSIDERED MORE FUNDAMENTALLY
FOR WOMEN- YOU COULD DO THAT
THE BILL WOULD NOT CHANGE ANY
OF THAT. THANK YOU SENATOR
LEYVA AS SENATOR MCGUIRE. SO
MUCH A MATTER VICE CHAIR I JUST
HAVE A QUESTION OF THE LEAD
OPPOSITION WITNESS AND THEN A
FEW QUESTIONS FOR. CARE LEAVERS
WELL IF I COULD GO TO OUR LEAD
OPPOSITION WITNESS PLEASE. THE
CHIEF COUNSELOR YES I'M HERE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH AND REALLY
APPRECIATE YOU BEING WITH US SO
DO SO A COUPLE QUESTIONS- DID
YOU ADVANCE ANY PREVIOUS
LEGISLATION OR- TO BE ABLE TO
BRING PARITY TO THE WOMEN'S
PROGRAM. NO WE HAVE NOT. DID
YOU BRING FORWARD ANY CHANGES
THE WOMEN'S PROGRAM PRIOR TO
THIS BILL WOULD BE IN ADVANCE
TO ENSURE THAT THERE IS PARITY
BETWEEN WOMEN AND MEN. IN TERMS
OF THE EVOLUTION OF HOW WE- RUN
OUR PROGRAMS THE THINGS THAT WE
OFFER AND EXPERIENCE YES THAT
WE ARE CONSTANTLY GROWING AND
EVOLVING AND CHANGING. THE WAY
WE DO BUSINESS AND WE HAVE
ADDED- COLLEGE NIGHT THAT WAS
ADDED LAST YEAR DURING OUR
VIRTUAL SESSION AND CONTINUES
TO BE A PART OF THE PROGRAM. WE
HAVE ALSO DONE AWAY WITH THE
SONGS THAT WERE REFERENCED
EARLIER. AND WE RESPOND TO THE
FEEDBACK FROM OUR DELEGATES.
AND OUR STAFF MEMBERS AT THE
END OF EVERY SESSION AND MAKE
ADJUSTMENTS AND CHANGES AND WE
ARE ALWAYS SEEKING. WHERE IS
THE BEST LOCATION FOR OUR
PROGRAM AND WHERE WE WILL BE
ABLE TO ACCOMPLISH OUR MISSION
OF THE PROGRAM AS WELL. WE DO
BELIEVE THAT PAY TO PARTICIPATE
FEES- IT'S CRITICAL TO THE
SUCCESS OF THEPROGRAM SINCE
BOYS DON'T HAVE TO PAY. I DO
NOT BELIEVE THAT IT IS A
CRITICAL COMPONENT TO THE
PROGRAM THAT WAS ADDED D. D-
FEE FOR. REGISTRATION WAS
ADDED- WITHIN THE LAST TEN
YEARS AND IT WAS ADDED BECAUSE
AS WE HAD A NUMBER OF GIRLS WHO
WERE DROPPING OUT OF THE
PROGRAM THE MORNING OF AND THIS
WAS ALLOWING US. TO HAVE THE
DELEGATES HAVE- AND SKIN IN THE
GAME IF YOU WOULD SAY SO THAT
THEY WOULD NOT DROP OUT OF THE
PROGRAM AND NOT ALLOW US TO SEE
COULD DELEGATE. AND ALTERNATE
IN THE CORRECT AMOUNT OF TIME.
AND THAT IS DEFINITELY
SOMETHING THAT WE ARE WILLING
TO LOOK AT WITH THE AUTHOR AND
TO REMOVE. THE WHY WHEN YOU
BRING THAT UP PRIOR TO THAT
JUST I'M GONNA BE CANDID THE
ONLY REASON YES ONE OF THE
REASONS WHY I THINK THAT YOU'RE
WILLING TO MAKE CHANGES BECAUSE
YOU DON'T WANT THIS
LEGISLATION. IN THIS
LEGISLATION IS FOCUS ON THEIR
**** IS RIDICULOUS YOU'RE
CHARGING GIRLS TO BE ABLE TO
PARTICIPATE IN A PROGRAM THAT
IS FREE TO VOICE WHICH IS B.
CANDIDATES TWENTY TWENTY ONE.
THAT SHOULD NEVER BE I
COMPLETELY AGREE OKAY THE
SECOND PIECES I UNDERSTAND THAT
THERE ARE CHALLENGES IN REGARDS
FACILITIES IN SACRAMENTO WHEN
IT COMES AND SEES YOU SYSTEM.
BUT NOT HAVING GIRLS COME TO
THE CAPITOL I JUST DON'T
UNDERSTAND WHY THAT WAS IN
ADVANCE PRIOR TO THIS
LEGISLATION. BEING INTRODUCED.
YES I NOT OF THE LEADERSHIP
THAT MADE THE DECISION TO MOVE
THE PROGRAM OUTSIDE OF THE
CAPITAL. BUT I AM PART OF THE
LEADERSHIP THAT IS LOOKING TO
WORK WITH THE SENATOR AND
SHOULD. RETURN IT TO THE
CAPITAL. OKAY BUT IT. IS
BECAUSE OF THIS LEGISLATION IN
NOW YOU'RE OPPOSING THE
LEGISLATION EVEN THOUGH YOU
AGREE WITH THE MERITS OF THE
LEGISLATION. SO WHAT IS IT DO
YOU SUPPORT PARITY FORTY
SUPPORT PARITY ON YOUR OWN TIME
IN YOUR OWN AGENDA. YOU KNOW I
ABSOLUTELY SUPPORT PARITY IN
EVERY WAY SHAPE AND FORM WHAT
AYE OPPOSED IN THE WHEN WHAT
THE ORGANIZATION IS ASKING FOR
WITH THE EXEMPTION. IS BY
REMOVING EXEMPTION TO FOR IT
EXAMS. THE ORGANIZATION FROM
BEING ABLE TO RECRUIT ON HIGH
SCHOOL CAMPUSES. THE SCHOOL
CAMPUSES AND SAID THAT IS THE
ONE PIECE THAT WE ARE ASKING
FOR WE ARE HAPPY TO WORK WITH
THE SENATOR FOR AT ON THIS BILL
AND WE'RE HAPPY TO WORK AND
PROPOSED DIFFERENT LANGUAGE
THAT COULD. CREATE THAT AT THAT
COULD REMOVE THE DISCRIMINATION
WHILE STILL ALLOWING ACCESS TO
THE SCHOOLS. OKAY GOTCHA I'M
GONNA BE SUPPORTERS OF THE BILL
JUST. LAST PIECE OF STEAK- AND
ALL LOOK TO THE CHAIR IS I
DON'T THINK IT SHOULD TAKE
LEGISLATION TO BE ABLE TO MAKE
COMMON SENSE CHANGES TO ENSURE
THAT THERE'S COMMONSENSE EQUITY
BETWEEN. MEN AND WOMEN IN
SOCIETY AND BEING COMPLETELY
HONEST ABOUT THIS THE ONLY
REASON WHY WE'RE HAVING THIS
CONVERSATION ABOUT POTENTIAL
CHANGES CAN BECOME INTEGRAL
STATE. IS BECAUSE CENTER LEYVA
HAS INTRODUCED THIS LEGISLATION
AND IS PUT A SPOTLIGHT ON THE
INEQUITIES THAT CURRENTLY EXIST
THAT'S IT. AND SO RATHER THAN
OPPOSED TO LEGISLATION. WHERE
YOU HAVE BOTH BOYS AND GIRLS
STATE OPPOSING THE LEGISLATION.
I WOULD HAVE THOUGHT THAT IF
YOU ARE IN SUPPORT OF THE VAST
MAJORITY THE BILL THAT YOU
WOULD BE EITHER NEUTRAL- AND
ORDERED SUPPORTIVE WITH
POTENTIAL CHANGES SO NATURALLY
BY APPRECIATE YOUR WORK ON
THIS- LOOK FORWARD TO SEEING IF
THERE CAN BE SOME ADDITIONAL.
WORK ON OTHER LANGUAGE BUT I
THINK THE MERITS OF THIS BILL
IS ABSOLUTELY CRITICAL IN YOUR
LEADERSHIP HAS BEEN. REALLY
IMPRESSED WITH THAT AN
ALTERNATIVE RECENTLY TO SEE
SHE'S ONCE A- COMMON ANYTHING
AND HE SAID. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND REQUIRE AND I THINK
YOU HAVE THE SAME FEELINGS THAT
WE HAD WHEN WE MOVE- INTRODUCES
LEGISLATION AGAIN JUST LOOKING
FOR PARITY LOOKING TO MAKE SURE
THAT. YOUNG WOMEN AND YOUNG MEN
HAVE THE SAME ACCESS- I THINK
THAT THE OPPOSITION'S- RESPONSE
TO THE FEES- IS REALLY ON AGAIN
UNFAIR TO WOMEN THE BOYS DON'T
HAVE ANY FEES I'M SURE THERE
ARE BOYS THAT DROP OUT. ON THE
DAY OF SO ARE WE JUST SAYING
THAT YOUNG WOMEN ARE UNRELIABLE
AND WE HAVE TO IMPOSE A FEE ON
THEM TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY
ACTUALLY SHOW UP. I JUST THINK
THAT WE NEED A CHANGE IN OUR
THOUGHT PROCESS AND I HOPE THAT
THIS BILL CAN GET US THERE AND
AS I'VE SAID MANY TIMES BEFORE.
THIS IS ABOUT EQUITY IT'S ABOUT
PARITY YOU CANNOT SEE IT BE IT
IF YOU DO NOT SEE IT. THANK YOU
CENTER REQUIRE THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR. THANK YOU SENATE MCGUIRE
AND SENATE- LEYVA. DO WE HAVE
ANY OTHER COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS
FROM OUR MEMBERS. OKAY I WILL
SHARE SOME OF MY THOUGHTS ON ON
THE BILL I TRULY APPRECIATE THE
EQUITY PART ON TRYING TO FIND
AT PARITY ON THEIR- AS A MOTHER
OF A DAUGHTER WHO ATTENDED BY
CURE SIGNS THE ALL STATE GIRLS
PROGRAM. IT WAS A VERY POSITIVE
EXPERIENCE FOR MY DAUGHTER I
KNOW THAT HER CONCERN WITH THE
PROBE WAS THE FACT THAT SHE WAS
NOT ABLE TO ATTEND- OR GO TO
SACRAMENTO SO THAT WAS THERE.
HER BIGGEST COMPLAINT WITH THE
PROGRAM- WHEN SHE ATTENDED AND
IT REALIZED AFTERWARDS THAT
THERE HER COUNTERPARTS HAD HAD
THE OPPORTUNITY TO ATTEND
SACRAMENTO THAT WAS HER CONCERN-
THE OTHER THING WITH THE FEES I
DID WANT TO MENTION THE FACT
THAT- FOR THE MOST PART THESE
ARE VOLUNTEER ORGANIZATIONS.
AND THE WAY THAT MY DAUGHTER
WAS SELECTED ACTUALLY I MOVED
TO A SCHOLARSHIP- IN ORDER FOR
HER TO BE ABLE TO ATTEND THE
SAID THOSE FEES WERE. PROVIDED
HER WERE PROVIDED TO HER BY
EIGHTY. I BELIEVE. NIGHT OF
PROBABLY SHOULDN'T SAY BECAUSE
I'M NOT 1100% BUT IT WAS ONE OF
THE SERVICE CLUBS ORGANIZATIONS
IN OUR CITY THAT ALLOWED HER
AND- TO BE ABLE TO ATTEND- THIS
THIS COMMUNITY AND IT WAS IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE
ORGANIZATIONS THAT ACTUALLY-
PROVIDE THIS PROGRAM. ON THERE
SO I JUST WANT TO STATE THAT
THAT MANY OF THESE GIRLS DO AT
TEN. ON WITH A FEE BUT MANY OF
THESE- ARE ALSO- COVERED BY THE
SCHOLARSHIPS WITHIN THE LOCAL-
SERVICE ORGANIZATIONS. IN THE-
IN THE AREA. AND ALSO ANOTHER
OBSERVATION THAT I WANTED TO
THE STATE WAS THAT- THIS
ORGANIZATIONS OR THESE PROGRAMS
FOR A GIRL STAYS PRIMARILY. AND
CORRECT ME IF I'M WRONG. DR
MCKINNEY BUT PROVIDED THROUGH
THE VOLUNTEER SERVICE OF MANY
MANY. WOMEN AND- AND I HAVE TO
AND I'M TRYING TO FIND THE
PROPER WAY OF- PRESENTING THIS
FLOOD OF OLDER WISER WOMEN. WHO
ARE AT TRYING TO CONTINUE A
PROGRAMMER A LEGACY THAT HAS
BEEN IN PLACE IN TRYING TO
PROMOTE WOMEN LEADERSHIP AND I
DON'T THINK IT'S BEEN THE
INTENT OF THESE- OF THESE WOMEN
PROMOTING THIS LEGACY OF WOMEN
LEADERSHIP TO HAVE BEEN ANY
LESS THAN EQUAL OR EMPOWERING
FOR WOMEN IT IS DONE HAS BEEN
DONE AND GOOD WILL AND GOOD
FAITH AND- AND AS- I HAVEN'T
BEEN A PARENT WHO ATTENDED- ONE
OF THE ONE OF THE LUNCHEONS-
HONORING THE YOUNG GIRLS. I CAN
TELL YOU THAT THESE WOMEN WERE
ADAM ON RESPECTFUL AND HAD
EVERY INTENT OF EMPOWERING AT
WIDE ARRAY OF DIVERSE WOMEN-
FROM AT DIFFERENT ECONOMIC
BACKGROUNDS TO- ETHNIC
BACKGROUNDS AND IT WAS AN
INCREDIBLE EXPERIENCE TO HAVE
SEEN THESE YOUNG WOMEN- THAT
WERE ATTENDING AS WELL AS
MEETING THE WOMEN WHO ARE
TRYING DESPERATELY TO KEEP A
LIFE A PROGRAM OF CIVIC
SERVICE. AND AND- ON A
VOLUNTEER BASIS SO I DO HAVE A
CONCERN THAT THIS WOULD IMPOSE-
EXTRA BURDENS ON
ADMINISTRATIVELY FOR OUR GIRLS
NOT THAT IT DOESN'T MERIT D.
THE INTENT OF HAVE BEEN WANTING
TO WORK TOWARDS THAT AIM AND
GOAL BUT I THINK- IT WITH EVERY
ORGANIZATION ESPECIALLY A
SERVICE VOLUNTEER ORGANIZATION-
PEOPLE HAVE TO WORK WITHIN THE
MEANS THAT THEY HAVE IN THE
CAPACITY OF THEIR OF THE
MEMBERSHIP WHICH IS VERY VERY
HARD TO COME BY I THINK WE'VE
ALL NOTE NOTED. THE THE
STATISTICS IN THE DATA THAT
SHOWS THAT SERVICE VOLUNTEER
ORGANIZATIONS ARE ESPECIALLY
OLDER ONES ARE BASICALLY DYING
AND THEY ARE VERY MUCH A PART
IN IN ESSENCE AND AN IMPORTANT
PART OF OUR OUR OUR OUR
COMMUNITIES OFFICIALLY IN MIND
I KNOW THAT WE HAVE A VERY
VERY. STRONG SERVICE VOLUNTEER.
IN OUR CITY. AND I RESPECT THEM
I COMMEND THEM AND USUALLY MADE
UP OF OLDER. OLDER GENERATE
OLDER GENERATIONS- BUT WITH
THAT- I AM EXCITED THAT YOU ARE
WORKING WITH THE WITH THE WITH
THE ORGANIZATIONS RIGHT NOW I'M
TRYING TO BRING THAT EQUITY BUT
I AT THIS TIME I WILL NOT BE
ABLE TO SUPPORT THE BILL
BECAUSE IT IS A PRIVATE.
VOLUNTEER PRIMARILY VOLUNTEER
SERVICE ORGANIZATION WHO'S
TRYING TO DO THEIR VERY BEST
WITHIN THE CAPACITY OF- THEIR
VOLUNTEER- ORGANIZATION AND I
THINK THEY'RE ACTING IN GOOD
FAITH AND THEY HAVE BEEN IN
CENTER MCGUIRE WITH REGARDS TO-
THERE THE NEED TO HAVE THIS
BILL IN PLACE IN ORDER TO BRING
THAT PARITY I THINK- THE-
DOCTOR. MCKINNEY DID MENTION
THE FACT THAT THEY HAD ALREADY
IN PLACE SOME OF THE THINGS
THAT THEY HAD BEEN BRINGING
FORTH. IN ORDER TO BRING MORE
PARITY INTO THE PROGRAM- PRIOR
TO SAID THIS IS JUST ANOTHER
COMPONENT THAT THEY WERE
WORKING ON- BUTTHEY HAVE HAD
THE INTENT OF DOING THAT IN
PROCESS NUMBER TEN AND LASTLY-
I DO WANT IT THANK AND
RECOGNIZE SHALL BE AND DON'T-
THE ALUMNI FROM FOR ALL STATE
OF BRINGING FORTH. THIS THIS
IDEA- ORDERS TO LIGHT TO
SENATOR CONNIE LEYVA BECAUSE IT
DOES SHOW THAT THIS PROGRAM IS
EFFECTIVE WITHIN THE INTENT OF
EMPOWERING GIRLS AND THEIR
VOICE AND MOVING FORWARD- WITH
CHANGES IN THEIR COMMUNITIES SO
I COMMEND YOU- MR ANGLE FOR
YOUR- FOR YOUR- FOR YOUR
ABILITY TO MOVE THIS FORWARD
HAVING. A STRONG VOICE AS A
WOMAN SO THANK YOU. AND IF ANY
AT ALL COMMENTS US CONNIE LEYVA
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE I WOULD
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM VICE
CHAIR- TO. ORGANIZATIONS I
GUESS MY COMMENT WOULD BE THAT
BOYS STATE DOESN'T HAVE TO
WORRY ABOUT FINDING AN
ORGANIZATION TO COVER THEIR
FEES AND BOISE STATE AND OF THE
AMERICAN LEGION OPERATES A
VOLUNTEERS AS WELL SO WE'VE GOT
ONE VOLUNTEER PROGRAM WHO HAVE
TO PAY FEES WITH ANOTHER
VOLUNTEER PROGRAM WHO DOESN'T
HAVE TO PAY FEES AND LOOK FOR
SOMEONE TO COVER THOSE FEES SO
THAT IN ITSELF IS A HUGE IN
EQUITY. AND YOUR COMMENT ABOUT
OLDER WISER WOMEN I WOULD SAY
THAT AS A FIFTY FOUR YEAR OLD
WOMAN I CONSIDER MYSELF TO BE
OLDER AND WISER AND IT'S
IMPORTANT TO ME THAT I IMPART
MY WISDOM ON YOUNG WOMEN AND
ONE OF THE REASONS I RAN FOR
OFFICE WAS SO THAT WE CAN
CREATE EQUITY ACROSS THE BOARD
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. I
SEE THIS AS A WAY FOR OLDER
WISER WOMEN TO DO THEIR PART IN
HELPING THE NEXT GENERATION OF
WOMEN BE ABLE TO BE A PART OF
THIS GOVERNMENT WE KNOW THAT
THE CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE ONLY
HOUSE HOUSE THIRTY EIGHT WOMEN
THERE ARE A HUNDRED AND TWENTY
EIGHT HUNDRED TWENTY
LEGISLATORS WOMEN SHOULD AT
LEAST BE SIXTY OR SIXTY WHICH
AT LEAST HAVE SIXTY WOMEN IN
THE CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE.
THROUGH GIRL STATE WE HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO MAKE SURE THAT
YOUNG WOMEN SEE WHAT IT'S LIKE
TO LEGISLATE SO THAT THESE
YOUNG WOMEN CAN RUN FOR OFFICE
AND THEY CAN HELP LEGISLATE AND
MOVE THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
FORWARD ALL WE ARE TRYING TO DO
WITH THIS BILL AND I WILL SAY
AGAIN I HAVE BEEN SHOCKED BY
THE OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL BUT
AGAIN IT'S TWENTY TWENTY ONE
AND IT JUST REMINDS US THAT WE
ARE A VERY SEXIST SOCIETY SO I
ASK MEMBERS FOR AN AYE VOTE
TODAY WE ALWAYS WORK WITH
OPPOSITION ON TEAM LEYVA. BUT
THE WE GET THERE OR NOT WE WILL
CONTINUE TO LISTEN TO THEIR
CONCERNS THIS IS ABOUT PARITY
AND EQUITY FOR ALL THE YOUNG
WOMEN UP AND DOWN THE. STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU MEMBERS.
THANK YOU COUNTY S. HELLO. FROM
THE NEARLY- CONSULTING PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. I AM NOT TWO S.
B. THREE SIX THREE THE MOTION
IS TO PASS BUT FOR BE RE REFER
TO THE COMMITTEE ON RULES LEYVA
HI LEYVA AYE OCHO A NO THE TWO
ABOVE NOTE C. ALL RIGHT
COURTESY I DALY. DEL NOT VOTING
GLAZER. MCGUIRE MCGUIRE AYE PAN.
AND I. THANK YOU VERY WE WILL
HOLD BILL ON CALL ON ROLE FOR
MEMBERS AND WILL READ THE AT
THE GAVEL TO SENATOR ARE IT'S
AN EARLY THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS WE ARE
GOING TO MOVE TO ITEM NUMBER
FOUR WHICH IS S. B. FORTY BY
LEE MON WHO IS PROTEST FROM I
SEE YOU SENATOR LIMóN. WELCOME
PLEASE WHEN YOU'RE. GEN WE
CANNOT RETURN TO THE STATUS QUO
AS IT IS CLEAR THAT THE
EXISTING STRUCTURES WERE NOT
DESIGNED TO WORK FOR ALL SCHOOL
DISTRICTS. SB FIVE FORTY
CREATES HELPS TO CLOSE EQUITY
GAPS THAT ARE COMMONLY
EXPERIENCED IN HISTORICALLY
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES. THIS
BILL IS STATUS IS WITHIN THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION A GRANT PROGRAM TO
PROVIDE TARGETED ASSISTANCE TO
THE TEN LOWEST PERFORMING
SCHOOL DISTRICTS IN CALIFORNIA.
SB FIVE FORTY GRANTS PROVIDE
ABOUT ONE POINT TWO MILLION
EACH TO THE TEN LOWEST
PERFORMING SCHOOL DISTRICTS THE
GRANT DOLLARS WILL BE USED TO
HELP CLOSE ACHIEVEMENT AND ALSO
OPPORTUNITY GAPS BY PROVIDING
RESOURCES FOR PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT. INCREASE THE
FAMILY ENGAGEMENT AND EQUITY
COACHING AN INTERVENTION TO
DETERMINE THE BEST METHOD TO
SCHOOL DISTRICTS CAN USE TO
CLOSE THEIR EXISTING GAPS. IT
IS IMPORTANT THAT THE MOST
UNDERSERVED STUDENTS IN THE
STATE ARE NOT LEFT BEHIND. WITH
ME TODAY ARE DR STEPHANIE GREG
SENT DEPUTY SUPERINTENDENT OF
PUBLIC INSTRUCTION AND MERRY
WALTERS THE ASSISTANT
SUPERINTENDENT AND WE RAN ABOUT
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SENATOR
LIMóN WE WILL FIRST GO TOWARD
LEAD WITNESSES. UP PLEASE
PROCEED. GOOD MORNING THIS IS
STEPHANIE GRACE AND THAT THE
SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION THANK YOU FOR
HAVING ME TODAY I'M HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE STATE OR INTENT
OF PUBLIC INSTRUCTION TONY
THURMOND. I WANT TO THANK
CHAIRMAN CONNIE LEYVA AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE BUT
THE YOU BRING TENANTS PROUD TO
PARTNER WITH SENATOR MILK.
MONIQUE LIMON OFFICER. FIVE
FORTY. THIS PAST YEAR HAS BEEN
AND- CHALLENGING FOR A-vSTEM
ARGUED EDUCATION STRUCTURES
WERE NOT. TO DELAY EDUCATE. IN
A REMOTE IN BY. AND TEACHERS
AND FAMILY OF ALL HIGH TO A GUY
AND HAVE CHAU GREAT RESILIENCE.
THROUGHOUT THE PEN. BUT EVEN
IMMERSING HOPE SIGNS OF MORE
MORE STUDENTS. AND LEARN. BUT
NINE OF OUR TEN DOT SCHOOLS.
OPTIONS IN PERSON EACH AND
DOING NEEDS TO BE DONE IF OPEN.
WE KNOW THAT HIS THAT THE
HISTORIC. THAT EXISTBEFORE THE
CRISIS. I ONLY BEEN BEATEN BY
THIS WEEK CREDIT CHANNEL. YEAR
IN TERMS OF. I CANNOT AND
POLITICAL CRISIS FACED BY OUR
SOCIETY. THIS IS BECAUSE LAYERS
A VERY REAL TRAUMA IN OUR
STUDENTS ESPECIALLY IN THE
STUDENTS HAVE TRADITIONALLY
BEEN UNDERSERVED. INVESTMENTS
WE MAKE NOW MUST HELP OUR
STUDENTS URGE. AND IMMEDIATELY
MOVE FORWARD FROM THIS CRISIS
AND ACCELERATE LEARNING FOR THE
STUDENTS AND FAMILIES HARDEST
HIT BY GLOBAL PANDEMIC. SO EVEN
IF WE FOCUS ON MOVING FORWARD
AND THE FEATURE. BACK TO CAMPUS
EVEN COST. WERE ALSO CALLED
THAT NEED TO VOTE ON FINDING TO
ADDRESS INEQUITIES THAT HAVE
BEEN IN PLACE HISTORICALLY.
THAT HAVE BEEN IMPACTED BURKE
EXACT. BY THIS. THE MAN THAT
MAKE COMES PROVIDED US THE- TO
TAKE OUR LOW GLARE. AND
RENOVATE OUR EDUCATION SYSTEM
CULTURE. THIS BILL SPEAK FORTY
IS ONE OF. PIECE TO TAKING HEAD
ON ISSUE THAT BACK. HERE ARE
SOME STATISTICS. ON OUR-
AFRICAN AMERICANS AT SCHOOL
THAT ARE 4% AFRICAN. OR WHITE
STUDENTS SCHOOL THE ARE ONLY
PERCENT AFRICAN. BY THE TIME
AFRICAN AMERICAN SHE AND HIGH
SCHOOL THEY'RE OFTEN THAN FOUR
ACTED YEARS BEHIND THEIR WHITE.
I JUST MENTIONED FOR AFRICAN
CHILDREN ARE APPROXIMATE THREE
TO FIVE HIGHER THAN BEFORE MANY.
ARE WHITE CHILDREN IN THE
UNITED STATES AGE TO FOUR ONLY
4% OF LATINOS TO HIGH SCHOOL.
87% OF AFRICAN AMERICANS
COMPARED 294% OF WHITE. THE
STATISTICS ARE NOW NEW. AS HAS
BEEN CALLED BETWEEN WHITE
PEOPLE PEOPLE TO COLOR FOR ME
AT PROBLEM DESPITE THAN FORTY
YEARS OF EFFORT TO ELIMINATE IT
FROM THE PHRASE THAT GAP IS
MISLEADING. TO SAY IT IS A
TREATMENT AND PLAY THAT ARE
STUDENTS ARE FEELING UP. MAY
NOT. THERE ARE BARRIERS TO EDGE
THAT INEQUITABLE OUTCOMES THESE
ARE WHAT WE OPPORTUNITY GAPS
AND AS LONG AS THE PROCESS WE
ARE FEEL ARE SO. AT FIVE FORTY
WILL ALLOW THE DEPARTMENT TO
HELP KIND OF A HIGH COOL LIVING
STUDENTS ACCOUNT HAS BEEN TO IN
AN AGGRESSIVE THREE YEAR PASS
THE INVESTMENTS WILL TARGET THE
MOST BECAUSE ACT GAP IN OUR
SCHOOL IN NINETEEN EQUITY
COACHING. RESEARCH SHOWS THAT
STUDENTS AND HIGH NEED BECAUSE
ONE INVEST ARE MADE IN ON
EVIDENCE BASED IN AND
STRATEGIES THAT ARE BOTH TRAUMA
INFORMED AND CULTURALLY. ACCESS
TO TOP EDUCATORS ACROSS NATION
WE DIRECTX IN CLOSING THAT GAP.
YOU CAN USE THE X. TO. THE MOST
OF AND- FOR THE NEED TO
STUDENTS. HE'S EQUITY COACHES
WORK WITH YOU TO E. AND COOL
DISTRICTS. A THREE YEAR PRICE
DESIGNED TO CLOSE EQUITY
OFFERED GAP NURSES.
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT. WE
ALL KNOW AS THE FOR TEACHER
IMPROVE. PRINTER PROFESSIONAL
LEARNING FOR TEACHERS WITHIN
CONTACT. TRANSLATES TO IMPROVE
INSTRUCTIONAL PACK. AND THE
CLASS. THIS WILL HELP INSURE
HIGH NEED SCHOOLS HAVE ADEQUATE
STAFF TO BE STUDENT. TO SCHOOL
WITH A FEW RESTORE. OFTEN HOW
HIGH STAFF TURNOVER AND LOWER.
OF EXPERIENCE. ON GOING
INTENSELY PROFESSION THE-
WALLONNE EDUCATE. WHO WORK IN
CHALLENGING ENVIRONMENTS TO BE
PREPARED. THE END OF THE- NEEDS.
FINALLY FAMILY ENGAGEMENT NEED
TO PREVAIL THE PER PRO LAW. AND
ON OUT READ A FAMILY MANY OF
WHICH HAVE ALREADY FOR
STRUCTURAL BARRIERS THE PAY.
INCLUDING THIS IS A SMALL BUILD
CAN HAVE A IN FOR STUDENTS
ESPECIALLY THOSE HARDEST HIT BY
THE- BY FOCUS OUR ATTENTION
INVEST IMPROVE RESEARCH TO
REDUCE OPPORTUNITY SIXTY CAL'S.
WE WILL UP ALL OUR SCHOOL AND
TEACHERS. THANK YOU SO MUCH AND
WE URGE TO VOTE SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL. THANK YOU DR GREG SENT
ARE YOU TO BOTH YOURS AND OTHER
WITH THE TIME BUT I'M GOING TO
GO AHEAD GIVE MERRY WALTER. ONE
MERRY PLEASE FOR C. MORE
SENATORS VERY WELL- PAYING YOU
STILL FOR THE OP. SPEAK BEHALF
OF THAT FIVE IN THE- SHARE THE
WAY ARE JUST HAS BEEN DOING
OVER THE LAST. YEARS VALUED
FIGHT IS LOOK IN SOUTH. LIKE
HONEY WITH TWENTY THREE
THOUSAND STUDENTS AND 35%
UNDUPLICATED POPULATION. AS A
RESULT OF OUR LOW ONE
DUPLICATED NUMBERS ARE DISTRICT
DOES NOT RECEIVE A GREAT AMOUNT
OF DAHLE CAP DOLLARS TO SUPPORT
OUR EFFORTS TO CLOSE OUR
OPPORTUNITY AND SHE BEGAN. WITH
OUR LIMITED EL CAP DOLLARS OUR
DISTRICT HAS BEEN FOCUSED ON
CLOSING THE OPPORTUNITYGAP
YOUR EQUITY WORK THAT INVOLVES
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT AND
STAKEHOLDER ENGAGEMENT. YOU MAY
WONDER WHY NEARLY TO BALLY IS
FILLING ENGAGED IN THIS EQUITY
WORK THE REASON IS OUR DATA AND
pHIGH COHORT GRADUATION IN ATG
RATE. BUT THERE ARE GAPS IN OUR
EDG RATES FOR UNDUPLICATED
PUPILS AND ARE STUDENT GROUPS
FOCUS. DUE O OUR EQUITY YOUR
WORK OVER THE LAST FEW YEARS WE
HAVE SEEN INCREASES IN THOSE
EIGHTY G. RAISING. CATEGORY OUR
DISTRICT HAS HAD AN INTENSE
FOCUS ON STUDENT LEARNING AND I
COULD LENS OF THE LAST SEVEN
YEARS OUR BOY THAT. AS IN
EQUITY. AND FULLY SUPPORT THIS
WORK OUR- LEADERSHIP UNDER THE-
OF OUR SUPERINTENDENT ON OUR
SIDE ADMINISTRATORS ARE ALL IN
WHEN IT COMES TO THIS WORK. OUR
DISTRICT BEGAN AND THEY ARE
EQUITY WORK BACK IN TWO
THOUSAND FOURTEEN. AND WE HAVE
OFFERED EQUITY INSTITUTE. THAT
ALLOW TOPICS FOR STAFF TO
REFLECT ON THEIR PERSONAL
EXPERIENCES AND BIASES
UNDERSTAND CULTURAL PROFICIENCY
AND APPLY TO THE SCHOOL SITE
AND THE CLASSIC YOU MS WALTERS
HERE WE- PAGE YOU. OKAY WE'RE
NOW GOING TO GO TO ANYONE
SUPPORT HERE IN FORTY TWO OH
THREE SEEING NO ONE WILL GO TO
ROOM TWENTY FORTY SEEN NO ONE
MISTER MODERATOR CAN YOU PLEASE
OPEN UP THE TELEPHONE LINES FOR
THOSE WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF SB FIVE FORTY. AND
IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF SB FIVE FOUR ZERO
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
THE ZERO AT THIS TIME IN
EIGHTEEN T. OPERATOR WILL GO
AHEAD AND GIVE YOUR LINE NUMBER
OFFLINE A PLACE YOU BACKING Q.
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME FOR. SUPPORT ON SB. FIVE
FORTY. AND AGAIN PLEASE PRESS
ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO. MADAM
CHAIR I SEE NOBODY QUEUEING UP
AT THIS TIME THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MR MODERATOR WE WILL NOW
GO TO LEAD OPPOSITION WHICH
THERE IS NONE IS THERE ANY ONE
OF FORTY TWO OR THREE NO ONE
ANYONE IN TWENTY FOURTEEN NO
ONE MISTER MODERATOR AND COME
BACK TO YOU AND ASK FOR ANY
OPPOSITION. TO SB FIVE FORTY.
THANK YOU IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
SHOW OPPOSITION TO SB FIVE FOUR
ZERO. PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED
BY ZERO. MANISHA OPPOSITION FOR
SB FIVE FOUR ZERO. PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO R. S. YES FIVE FORTY
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. AND
MEDICARE NOBODY'S QUEUING UP
THANK YOU MR MODERATOR WE WILL
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
DOES ANYONE HAVE ANY QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS ON THE BILL SENATOR
PAN. THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND
CEREMONY I APPRECIATE WHAT
YOU'RE TRYING TO ACHIEVE WITH
THIS BILL I GUESS MY QUESTION
GOING BACK TO THE ANALYSIS- IT
ANNOUNCES IT MAKES NOTE THAT
YOU KNOW WE HAD A LOW
PERFORMING STUDENTS BLOCK GRANT
PROGRAM AND- WE'RE STILL
WAITING FOR THE- RESULTS FROM
THAT TO THE FINAL REPORTING AS
TO. HOW WELL IT WORKED AND WHAT
WORKED WHAT DIDN'T WORK- I
WOULD ALSO MAKE NOTE IN THE
ANALYSIS THAT- THE BILL TALKS
ABOUT- SPECIFIC- SAMPLE HIRING
AND FUNDING ONE DISTINGUISHED
EDUCATOR EXPERIENCE IMPROVING
PUPIL PERFORMANCE OUTCOMES
WHICH I THINK ON SURFACE SOUNDS
LIKE A GREAT IDEA BUT I'M BUT I
AM INTERESTED IN- HEARING AND I
DID HEAR THE- THE PROPONENTS
TESTIMONY IN TERMS OF THE
EVIDENCE BASE BEHIND THAT I
MEAN I THINK. BRING AN EMINENT
EDUCATORS CAN BE USEFUL IF THE
CULTURE AT THE SCHOOL DISTRICT
IS ONE THAT WOULD YOU KNOW WANT
TO. ACCEPT THAT PERSON BUT-
PERHAPS- YOU CAN SPEAK TO- WHY
THAT PARTICULAR STRATEGY WAS
PICKED UP FOR THE FOR THE BILL
SO BOTH THE ISSUE WITH A BLOCK
GRANT OUR FINDINGS AND THEN-
THE- WHAT THE BILL'S GOING BE
FUNDING. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
THANK YOU SO ALL YOUR BY AND
I'M AND I HANDED A TO THE
STEPPED GREGSON CAN SPEAK A
LITTLE BIT MORE ON THIS. I'M
BUT YOUR FIRST QUESTION WAS
ABOUT THE FRENCH SO BLOCKER
ACTUALLY ENDED- TYPE OF A NEW
IN WORK SO THAT TARGETS MANY
SCHOOL THIS THIS IS A BIT
DIFFERENT. AND SO SHE INTO OF-
WE SHOULD WE FOR THE TO- OF THE
PART ONE BECAUSE ARE TWO DO
STRESS. AND WE SELL IT STILL IN
IF YOU'RE AT THE KNOW THE. TEN
THERE IS NOT OF THOSE STRAIGHT.
THAT WILL. FIX ALL OF IT AND SO
I THINK THERE HAS TO BE
MULTIPLE WAYS TO LOOK AT I MEAN.
ONE WAY TO BE. ONE THE IN ONE
OF THESE TEN YOU KNOW MEANS
THAT YOU. AMONG THE LOWER
PERFORM INSTANCE THAT'S- THAT
IN REQUIRES A D. TYPE OF
INVESTMENT WHICH IS WHY BELIEVE
SHOULDN'T. WAIT I WANT BECAUSE
ARE YOU ENOUGH EVIDENCE TO THAT
WERE GOING TO HAVE TO INVEST IN
DIFFERENT WAYS- YOU ARE IN THE
YOU KNOW. A ONE OF THESE TEN US.
SO OUR SCHOOL DOES SO I THAT'S
WHAT I WILL SAY IT WHY THERE'S
A THE TWO SAT. AND WHY
ADDITIONAL INVESTMENT IS
REQUIRED- IF YOU'RE ONE OF THE
TEN AND I WILL PASS IT OVER TO
DR STEPHANIE GREG SENT TO TALK
ABOUT THE PEOPLE INSTRUCTION
PIECE OF IT. THANK YOU. WITH
APPROACH AROUND YOU. AN AXE TO
COME IN AND WORKING IN HAND
WITH THE DISTRICTS LEADERSHIP
AND HOPE TO DESTROY COURT B.
KERR. TO CHRIS. ON THEIR SHORT
PRACTICES AND SYSTEMS. OFTEN TO
OUR- ADDITION CAN GET IT'S
ENGAGE AND TRAINS IN THEIR OWN.
IT OFTEN GET CHANCE TO STEP
BACK AND READ. AND HAVE A
THOUGHT PARTNER TO BE ABLE TO
LOOK AT THE SYSTEM PRACTICE.
THAT ARE CREATE AN AND BARRIERS
TO. SIX SO BY PER. AN EDGE.
EXPERT TO COME IN. I DO THINK
AND- THERE IS TO HAVE A PART.
THAT CAN REFLECT WITH THEM
THEIR SYSTEM DEMOCRATS. AND
ABLE TO. LOOK AT THEIR- OF
PROFESSIONAL LEARNING. THEIR IN
CASE FAMILY. PLAN AND BE A TO.
THEM SUPPORT STRUCTURE. THAT
CAN AND- THE BALLPARK OF IT.
AND ACROSS. AND EVERYBODY TO
FOLLOW PARTNER AND THIS IS WHAT
THE DO THINK I'D- CAMPER. FOR
THE DISTRICTS. TARGET TO THEIR
NEEDS OKAY AFTER A PROCEED SO
CERTAINLY I ONCE A SUPPORT OF-
MOVING. I DO- YOU KNOW I GUESS
MY- ONE. SERVED ON THE SHOW
THAT WE'RE SAID OUR INVESTMENTS
ARE EVIDENCE. STUFF I DON'T
THIS WITH THE IDEA OF HOW.
SOMEONE BRING DIFFERENT FOR.
BUT THAT USUALLY WORKS. WERE
CALLING FOR AND- ON. A OR-
DISCO SCHOOL TO. IS OPEN TO.
AND ENGAGED THAT PER RIGHT OF
THEY HAVE A COLD WHERE. LIKE
THIS IS THE WAY WE DO THINGS.
YOU BRING IN SOMEONE BY THE
PERSON DOES HAVE ANY THOUGHT.
OR STATE DINNER GOING TO CHANGE
THAT CALL. SO SO I JUST WANT TO
DEKALB OUT THEIR- ASSEMBLY
HAPPY NEW MOVE TO BILL TO PROBE
TIME A- YOUR EFFORTS AND- BY
HOPE IS A BILL OF ALL. WE CAN
TRY TO LOOK AT- YUP TO. AND
HAVE BASED BEHIND THEM SO WE
CAN GET THE MAXIMUM OUT SUCCESS
WHICH I CERTAINLY UNDERSTAND A
CERTAIN AMOUNT THAT'S WHAT YOU
WANTED SHE'S THANK YOU. THANK
YOU CENTER PEOPLE. THANK YOU
SAID PAN FURTHER QUESTIONS
COMMENTS. OKAY VERY GOOD SAN.
TO MOVE THE BILL HAS BEEN MOVED
BY THE- PAN. WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSER LAMAR I SEEM TO BE THAT
TODAY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THERE IS ASK FOR AND I'VE-
THANK YOU SENATOR LOAN MADAM
CONSOLE WE HAVE A MOTION BY PAY
PLEASE THE ROLL ITEM NO FOUR SB
FOUR. THE MOTION TO PAY BUT BE
RE REFER TO THE CA ON OF. LEYVA
BY LEYVA AYE OTOBO. BUT
TROUBLED BY. HI COURTESY I'D-
PLAY. MCGUIRE PAN RIGHT CAN I.
WE WILL THAT OUR BILL ON CALL
FOR A MENTOR MEMBERS TO VOTE
THANK VERY MUCH ALONE. WE ARE
NOW MOVING. FOLLOW FIVE WHICH
IS SB FORTY BY WILK IN MY UNDER.
IS CHAIR TOLD WILL BE. I AM
PLEASED TO PRESENT SB FIVE
FORTY FIVE ON BEHALF OF SENATOR
WILK. I WANT TO FIRST THANK
THAT CHAIR AND THE COMMITTEE
FOR WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR'S
OFFICE TO SUPPORT OUR STATE
STUDENTS. AS AT THE REQUEST OF
THE AUTHOR I WOULD LIKE TO
ACCEPT THE AMENDMENTS NOTED IN
THE ANALYSIS. THE PANDEMIC HAS
FURTHER EXPOSED AND ENTRENCHED
EDUCATIONAL INEQUITIES WHICH
ARE MOST PRONOUNCED AMONG
STUDENTS FROM LAURIE COULD EAT
INCOME FAMILIES. STUDENTS IN
RURAL ENVIRONMENTS AND STUDENTS
WHO ARE ENGLISH LANGUAGE
LEARNERS FOSTER YOUTH. OR WHO
HAVE DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES. WE SEE THAT FOR
MENTAL EFFECTS OF THE PAST YEAR
MANIFESTED IN INCREASED
ABSENTEEISM. STUDENTS RECEIVING
WORSE GRADES AND STUDENTS IN
CRUCIAL DEVELOPMENTAL YEARS
DEMONSTRATING LOWER LITERACY
LEVELS. AS AMENDED THIS BILL
ADDRESSES THESE HARMS BY
MANDATING THAT UPON RECEIVING A
REQUEST FOR PEOPLE TO BE
RETAINED A SCHOOL DISTRICT
OFFER. PEOPLE SPECIFIC
INTERVENTIONS AND SUPPORT
PURSUANT TO AB EIGHTY SIX BOXES
TO PRIOR SEMESTER COURSES IN
WHICH THE STUDENT RECEIVED A D.
OR F. GRADE OR SOME OTHER
FORMER CREDIT RECOVERY.
INFORMATION TO THE REQUESTING
PARENT REGARDING RESEARCH ON
THE EFFECTS OF PUPIL RETENTION
AND THE TYPES OF INTERVENTIONS
AND SUPPORT HAVE BEEN SHOWN TO
BE BENEFICIAL TO PEOPLE'S. OUR
STATE TOO YOUNG AND MOST
VULNERABLE STUDENTS HAVE BEEN
AMONG THOSE HIT THE HARDEST BY
THE PANDEMIC AND SB FIVE FORTY
FIVE WILL GO A LONG WAY IN
MITIGATING THESE IMPACTS AND
GETTING OUR STUDENTS ON THE
RIGHT PATH. WITH ME TODAY TO
PROVIDE EXPERT TESTIMONY AND
FURTHER ADDRESSED THE NEED FOR
THIS MEASURE IS DONNA ARE TO
COLLEGE. AND EDUCATION ADVOCATE
WITH THE CALIFORNIA STATE PTA.
THANK YOU SENATOR OCHO BOOKLET
MAUREEN. PLEASE GO RIGHT AHEAD
MORNING ENSURE LEYVA AND- GOOD
MORNING SENATOR LEYVA AND
MEMBERS OF THE SENATE EDUCATION
COMMITTEE HI AS YOU HEARD MY
NAME IS DONNA ARE TO GIVE IT
SHOULD CREEK AND I AM HERE AS
AN EDUCATION ADVOCATE FOR THE
CALIFORNIA STATE PTA IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF SB FIVE POINT FIVE.
I AM A FORMER TEACHER OF NEARLY
THIRTY YEARS AND THE FORMER
SCHOOL BOARD MEMBER. TODAY I'M
HERE TO SPEAK ON BEHALF OF THE
PGA AS A PARENT AND A
GRANDPARENT THE CALIFORNIA
STATE PTA SUPPORTS GOVERNMENT
ASSISTANCE PROGRAMS INTENDED TO
HELP FAMILIES SURVIVE. CRISIS
AND PROTECT CHILDREN FROM THE
EXTREME. THE PROPERTY. WE
BELIEVE THAT GOVERNMENT HAS THE
RESPONSIBILITY TO PLAN AND
COORDINATE THESE PROGRAMS FOR
CHILDREN IN NEED. WE ADVOCATE
FOR LEGISLATION AND PUBLIC
POLICIES THAT IMPROVE ACADEMIC
ACHIEVEMENT FOR ALL STUDENTS.
AND ELIMINATE THE ACHIEVEMENT
GAP WE ADDITIONALLY SUPPORT
LEGISLATION THAT EMPHASIZES THE
NEED FOR PROGRAMS THAT ADDRESS
LEARNING LOSS ESPECIALLY FOR
DISADVANTAGED HUGHES. MANY
CHILDREN THIS YEAR HAVE BEEN
LEFT BEHIND THE PANDEMIC HAS
INCREASED THE EDUCATION
INEQUITIES AT LOWER INCOME
STUDENTS STUDENTS IN THE WORLD
ENVIRONMENT. IN WHICH LEARNERS
HOLLISTER USED IN HOMELESS
CHILDREN THE STUDENTS MANY OF
WHOM WERE UNABLE TO LEARN
ONLINE FOR A VARIETY OF REASONS
ARE STRUGGLING THEY NEED EXTRA
HELP. SB FIVE FORTY FIVE OFFERS
EXTRA TUTORING AND EXTENDED
LEARNING OPPORTUNITIES. BILL
PROVIDES INFORMATION TO PARENTS
REGARDING THE RESEARCH THAT
SHOWS RETENTION IS NOT ALWAYS
THE BEST COURSE EVEN FOR
STUDENTS WHO ARE STRUGGLING. WE
BELIEVE THAT SB FIVE FORTY FIVE
WILL GIVE PARENTS AND STUDENTS
TO HELP AND INFORMATION THEY
NEED TO OVERCOME THE LEARNING
LOSSES THEY MAY HAVE THAT MAY
HAVE OCCURRED THIS YEAR. IN
CONCLUSION THE CALIFORNIA STATE
PTA URGES YOU TO PASS THE BILL
TO GIVE ARE STRUGGLING STUDENTS
THE EXTRA HELP THEY NEED TO
SUCCEED. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH WE HAVE NO OTHER
LEADS SUPPORT SO WE WILL GO TO
SUPPORT HERE IN FORTY TWO OH
THREE SEEING THAT WILL GO TO
ROOM TWENTY FORTY SEEING THAT
WILL BRING IT TO. THE
TELEPHONIC LINES MISTER
MODERATOR COULD YOU PLEASE OPEN
THE LINES FOR ANYONE WISHING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB FIVE
FORTY FIVE PLEASE. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR IF YOU WOULD LIKE
TO- SHOW YOUR SUPPORT FOR SB
FIVE FORTY FIVE. PLEASE PRESS
STAR BOTH ARE ONE TOLD BY ZERO
EXCUSE ME ONE FOLLOWED BY THE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. TO SHOW YOUR
SUPPORT FOR SB. FIVE FIVE FORTY
FIVE. ONE MOMENT PLEASE. AND AS
A REMINDER PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO TO SHOW
SUPPORT FOR SB. FIVE FOUR FIVE.
I'M SURE NOBODY IS KILLING UP
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE WILL NOW
GO TO LEAVE OPPOSITION I
BELIEVE WE HAVE JEFFREY VACCA
ON THE LINE JEFFREY PROCEED
WHEN YOU'RE READY. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR- JEFF BALK AT
REPRESENTING THE RIVERSIDE
COUNTY SUPERINTENDENT OF
SCHOOLS. I'M PLEASED TO SHARE
WITH THE COMMITTEE THIS MORNING
THAT WHAT THE PROPOSED
AMENDMENTS TO THE BILL. THAT
SENATOR OCHO ABOUT ON BEHALF OF
SENATOR WELCH HAS AGREED TO
ACCEPT. THAT WE WILL BE ABLE TO
REMOVE OUR OPPOSITION TO SB
FIVE FORTY FIVE. IN THE SPIRIT
OF BREVITY ASSEMBLY NOW THAT
THE RIVERSIDE COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION IS WORKING CLOSELY
WITH OUR TWENTY THREE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS. ON THE MOST
EFFECTIVE ACADEMIC
INTERVENTIONS TO SUPPORT OUR
STUDENTS AND THEIR LEARNING
RECOVERY EFFORTS. CONSISTENT
WITH THE LEGISLATURE'S INTENT
IN IMPROVING APPROVING ASSEMBLY
BILL. EIGHTY SIX EARLIER THIS
YEAR. CLOTHING JUST LIKE
EXPRESS OUR- FOR THE WORK OF
MISS LORBER INDICTMENT CENTER
RECOLLECTED AND YOUR COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS AND THANK SENATOR WILK
AND HIS STAFF AS WELL. WE LOOK
FORWARD TO FORMALLY REMOVING
OUR OPPOSITION TO THE BILL WHEN
I WAS A MANAGER AND PERHAPS.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR THANK YOU
VERY MUCH WE'LL GO TO
OPPOSITION HERE IN FORTY TWO OH
THREE SEEING NONE WE WILL GO TO
TWENTY FORTY SEEING NONE MISTER
MODERATOR BACK TO YOU FREE OF
ANYONE ON THE LINE WHO WISHES
TO TESTIFY FIVE. IN OPPOSITION.
TO SB FIVE FORTY FIVE. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR. SO YOU'RE OUT.
FOR SB FIVE FORTY FIVE PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO. AND
WE WILL BEGIN WITH LINE EIGHTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE
EIGHTY SEVEN. EIGHT I WILL GO
TO LINE EIGHTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MICHELLE
MCGEE ANNOYED ON BEHALF OF THE
TORRANCE UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT WE PREVIOUSLY
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE THE
LEGISLATION ABOUT HALF WILL BE
AT A PRACTICE OF REMOVING OUR
OPPOSITION I WITH GRATITUDE TO
THE OFFICE. OR TAKING THEM AND
THEN- AND HERE IN ARKANSAS.
THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU.
AND AGAIN FOR TO SHOW YOUR
OPPOSITION FOR. FIVE FORTY FIVE
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY.
ZERO MADAM CHAIR NOBODY ELSE'S
QUEUING UP THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MR MODERATOR WILL BRING IT BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE DOES ANYONE
HAVE ANY QUESTIONS COMMENTS
CONCERNS. THIS IS A THANK YOU
VERY MUCH WE HAVE A MOTION BY
SENATOR DOLLY. WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE CENTER OF TROUBLES.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THE BILL
HAS BEEN MOVED BY SENATOR DOLLY
MADAM A CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL ITEM NUMBER FIVE SB
FIVE FORTY FIVE THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED BUT FIRST
AMEND AND RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
LEYVA. HI LIVE AUDIO CHOI BOGUE
HI FOR TROUBLED AYE COURTESY
AYE COURTESY AYE DELHI AYE
DELHI AYE GLAZER MCGUIRE. PAN
WE WILL HOLD THAT OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS TO VOTE MEMBERS
FOR A MOMENT- WE'RE GOING TO
SKIP OVER FILE ITEM SIX SB FIVE
NINETY THREE SENATOR GLAZERS
AND WE ARE WAITING FOR SENATOR
BAKER. TO COME TO PRESENT FILE
ITEM EIGHT AND NINE TO WILL
TAKE A BRIEF PAUSE. WE
ABSOLUTELY CAN SO LET'S OPEN UP
THE CONSENT CALENDAR FOR THOSE
WHO DID NOT GET TO VOTE MADAM
US CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. CONSENT TO
VOTING ON A VICE CHAIR VOTING
ONLINE DELHI. DELHI BY MCGUIRE
PAN. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
YES
OVER THE ROLE OF. CONSULTANT
CAN WE OPEN THE ROLE ON SB FIVE
FORTY PLEASE ITEM NUMBER FOUR
SB FIVE FORTY THE MOTION IS TO
PASS BUT FIRST BE REFERRED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
CHAIR VOTING ON A VICE CHAIR
VOTING ON A DAILY. DALY NO
GLAZER MCGUIRE THANK YOU. YOU.
WELCOME SIR BAKER IS GOING TO
PRESIDING BE PRESENTING FIVE M.
EIGHT AND FILE ITEM NINE WE'LL
START WITH FILE ITEM EIGHT SB
SIX FIFTY NINE BEGIN WHEN
YOU'RE READY SENATOR BAKER
GREAT GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS THANK YOU I WON FIRST
THANK THE CHAIR THE COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR WORKING WITH US ON
THIS AND ACCEPTED COMMITTEE.
AMENDMENTS SB SIX FIVE NINE
WILL MAKING COLLEGE MORE
AFFORDABLE FOR STUDENTS MOST IN
NEED. THREE COLLEGE STUDENTS
FACE SIGNIFICANT FINANCIAL
BARRIERS TO ATTENDING COLLEGE
COULD ENROLLMENT FEES BOOKS
TRANSPORTATION HOUSING FOOD
OTHER COSTS. TWO EIGHT STUDENTS
IN THEIR PURSUIT OF HIGHER
EDUCATION FLEXIBILITY NEEDED BY
CUNY COLLEGES TRICKS TO THE CAN
WAIVE OR REDUCE ENROLLMENT
FEES. USE EXISTING LOCAL FUNDS
TO REMOVE FINANCIAL BARRIERS
FOR STUDENTS. TO SUPPORT THEM
WITH YOUR TOTAL COST OF
ATTENDANCE. THREE SIX FIVE NINE
HOURS TWENTY COLLEGE DISTRICTS
TO PROVIDE EXPAND EQUITABLE
ACCESS TO HIGHER EDUCATION. FOR
MARGINALIZED UNDERREPRESENTED
STUDENT POPULATIONS AS WELL AS
THOSE WHO DEMONSTRATE NEED. IT
WILL COST THE STATE ADDITIONAL
MONEY. WRITES COMMITTEE
COLLEGES WITH MORE FLEXIBILITY
TO THE EXISTING FUNDS. TO
REDUCE STUDENT FEES AND ACCOUNT
FOR SOME THESE OTHER COSTS.
IT'S GIVING LOCAL DISTRICTS THE
TOOL THROUGH BARRIERS THERE
KEEPING STUDENTS FROM ENROLLING
FOR COMPLETING THEIR DEGREES.
SAN MATTEO CAN COUNTY COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DISTRICT IN MY DISTRICT
IS AN EXAMPLE OF WHY THIS BILL
WILL BE HELPFUL. BECAUSE
DISTRICT HAS GOT SIX THOUSAND
STUDENTS IN THEIR ELIGIBLE FOR
ITS VERSION OF THE CALIFORNIA
COLLEGE PROMISE PROGRAM. WHICH
PROVIDES FIRST TIME COLLEGE
STUDENTS WITH A MULTI YEAR
TUITION SUPPORT. INDIVIDUALIZED
COUNSELING SUPPORT TEXTBOOK
DOCTORS AND FOOD TRANSPORTATION
INCENTIVES AND HAS BEEN SUPER
SUCCESSFUL. UNDER EXISTING LAW
THEY CAN ONLY FIND TWO THOUSAND
SIX THOUSAND STUDENTS BECAUSE
THE FUNDING LIMITATIONS IN
STATUTE EVEN THOUGH THEY HAVE
DIFFERENT REVENUES THAT COULD
BE USED TO ACCEPT MORE STUDENTS
INTO THE PROGRAM. THIS WILL
BILL WILL GIVE A COLLEGE
DISTRICT. IN EVERY DISTRICT IN
THE STATE THE FLEXIBILITY. TO
THE EXISTING FUNDING TO
REDUCING FEES. PUBLISHED JUNE
COST TO HOPEFULLY ALL THE
STUDENTS ELIGIBLE FOR THE
PROMISE SCHOLARS PROGRAM WILL
BE ABLE TO ATTEND. THANK YOU.
THE WITH ME TO TESTIFY TODAY
OUR DOCTOR MCCAIN. VICE
CHANCELLOR FOR EDUCATION
EDUCATIONAL SERVICE AND
PLANNING THAT'S A MATTEO COUNTY
COMMITTEE COST DISTRICT. GLUES
MON WAS A PROMISE SCHOLAR
STUDENT AT SKYLINE COLLEGE
THANK YOU EXPECTEDLY
RESPECTFULLY URGE AN AYE VOTE
THANK YOU CENTER BECKER EACH OF
YOUR LEAD OF SUPPORT WITNESSES
HAVE TWO MINUTES. PLEASE
PROCEED. MR LEVINE- GOOD
MORNING MADAM MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE IT'S
AN HONOR TO SPEAK TUESDAY IN
SUPPORT OF SENATE BILL SIX
FIFTY NINE SENATOR BAKER. MY
NAME IS DR MEDINA AND THE VICE
CHANCELLOR OF EDUCATIONAL
SERVICES IN PLANNING FOR THE
SENATE DEMOCRATIC GOING TO
COLLEGE DISTRICT. SB SIX OF THE
NINE MAKES TOO SMALL BUT
CRITICAL CHANGES THAT WOULD
ALLOW ME BECAUSE DISTRICTS USE
LOCAL RESOURCES TO EXPAND
ACCESS TO HIGHER EDUCATION.
INCREASE THE NUMBER OF STUDENTS
WHO ARE PART OF THE COLLEGE
PROMISE PROGRAMS IN SUPPORT OF
STUDENTS TOTAL COST OF
ATTENDANCE INCLUDING BASIC
NEEDS SUCH AS FOOD HOUSING.
TRANSPORTATION AND FAMILY CARE.
ASSEMBLY THIS BILL WILL LOCAL
BOARDS. TO ADOPT. THAT REDUCE
OR ELIMINATE ENROLLMENT FEES
FOR STUDENTS BASED ON CRITERIA
SUCH DOCUMENTED FINANCIAL BATES.
ISRAEL ALSO ALLOWS LOCAL BOARDS
OF TRUSTEES TO DEDICATE LOCAL
RESOURCES TO PROVIDE SUPPORT
FOR STUDENTS FROM ACROSS THE
TENDONS IN ORDER TO EXPAND THE
NUMBER OF STUDENTS THAT CAN BE
SERVED IN COLLEGE PROBLEMS
PROGRAMS. BOTH OF THESE CHANGES
WILL ALLOW THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE SYSTEM TO BUILD ON
EXISTING PROGRAMS SUCH AS THE
CALIFORNIA COLLEGE PROMISE
GRANT WHICH IS FORMERLY THE
BOARD OF GOVERNORS ARE BOND
TREE WAIVER AND AB NINETEEN
CALIFORNIA COLLEGE PROBLEMS.
YOU MIGHT REASONABLY ASK WHAT
MIGHT BE CHANGES LOOK LIKE IN
PRACTICE. THE BILL STATE
SMOKABLE OR THE TRUSTEES WOULD
BE REQUIRED TO ADOPT LOCAL
POLICIES THESE COULD FOR
EXAMPLE EXPAND THE CALIFORNIA
COLLEGE PROMISE GRANT PROGRAMS
TO SERVE STUDENTS WHO DO NOT
CURRENTLY QUALIFY. BUT NONE THE
LESS HAVE FINANCIAL NEED
BECAUSE OF THE AREA IN THE
STATE IN WHICH THEY LIVE. HERE
IN SAN MATEO COUNTY FOR EXAMPLE
THE MEDIAN HOME PRICE IS MORE
THAN ONE POINT EIGHT MILLION
DOLLARS WHAT WE AS A COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DISTRICT BENEFIT FROM
THOSE LOCAL PROPERTY TAXES THE
COST OF LIVING CREATES A
TREMENDOUS FINANCIAL BARRIER TO
THE COMMUNITIES WE SERVE. AS
SUCH WE CAN EXPAND OUR ABILITY
FOR FEE WAIVERS TWO HUNDRED OR
EVEN 3100% OF CURRENT
CALIFORNIA COLLEGE PROMISE
GRANT INCOME LEVELS CONDITION
BENEFIT FAMILIES IN SAN MATE
COUNTY THAT. ARE BARELY ABLE TO
MAKE ENDS MEET. WHILE THE FOR
THE EXTRA PRO. HE'S A WORKING
CLASS FAMILIES USER COMMUNITY
OF COLOR AND FOR US IN THE
COUNTY A CALL THIS THIS IS AN
EQUITY IS. NOT ONLY ARE BORED
WAITING USE ANOTHER THAT
BERRIER TO ATTENDING BUT THEY
ALSO OUR SCHOLARS. WHICH OUR
LOCAL PROMISE PROGRAM BY
PROVIDING SUPPORT TO THE TOP OF
ATTENDANCE THIS WOULD INCLUDE
BOOKS SHOULD SECURITY. AND
OTHER BASIC NEEDS ALLOWING US
TO EXPAND ENROLLMENT IN THIS
COMPLETION FOCUSED PROGRAM THAT
HAS MORE THAN DOUBLED TWO AND
THREE YEAR GRADUATION RATES ARE
DISTRICT WE CURRENTLY SERVE TWO
THOUSAND STUDENTS EVERY YEAR SB
SIX AND DO NOT ALLOW US TO MEET
THE DEMAND TO SERVE AS MANY AS
SIX THOUSAND STUDENTS THERE IS
NO BETTER WAY TO IMPROVE THE
LIVES OF STUDENTS THEIR
FAMILIES AND THE COMMUNITY THEY
LIVE AT. AND THE ECONOMY OF THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA THEN TO GET
STUDENTS TO COMPLETE A COLLEGE
DEGREE FOR ALL THESE REASONS
OUR DISTRICT SUPPORT SB SIX
FIFTY NINE THANK YOU NOW LIKE
TO TURN IT OVER TO ONE OF OUR
PROMISE SCHOLARS MARC MARON THE
STUDENT FROM SKYLINE COLLEGE TO
SHARE WITH YOU THE IMPACT THIS
PROGRAM HAS MADE IN HIS LIFE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISTER
GOODMAN GO AHEAD. THE MORNING
WHEN THEY'RE GOING TO BECOME-
MY NAME IS MARGARET. AND ON THE
SECOND YEAR STUDENTS CALLING
COLLEGE. UNIFORMS COLOR PROGRAM
IN THE FALL OF TWENTY NINETEEN
AND I'M ABOUT TO TALK. TO
TRANSFER TO A FOUR YEAR
UNIVERSITY. A I WOULD LIKE TO
SHARE MAKES. AND DORMS FOR.
EACH LOCAL ALWAYS DREAM OF
GOING COLLEGE AND GETTING A
DEGREE FROM. WE ALWAYS
EMPHASIZE THE IMPORTANCE OF
EDUCATION HOLD LIKE CHANGING
YOU COULD BE. AS YOU MIGHT AS
YOU MIGHT IMAGINE HAVING THAT.
IN THE FOLLOWING TO TRY TO GO
TO COLLEGE IT'S CHALLENGING AND
TALK ABOUT IT GETS EVEN HARDER.
WHEN YOU'RE AN IMMIGRANT TRYING
TO LEARN A NEW. LANGUAGE AND
ESTIMATES ON YOUR CULTURE. SO I
JUST OVER THERE IN IMMIGRANT
HAS A- HASN'T GENERATION
COLLEGE. I CAN COME WE THANK
GOD. THE PROMISED FOR IN THE
THING THAT COULD EVER. TO ME.
INTERDIGITAL MY DREAM. FOR THE
BUCK TWO YEARS THE PROMISE CALL.
HELP ME SHE MY WHOLE.
EXPERIENCE ALSO BELIEVE THE
BEGINNINGS OF MY PROFESSIONAL
CAREER. THE PROMISED. IS CLOSE
PROGRAM EMAIL IMMIGRATION
EDUCATION. AND HELP ME TO
FIGURE OUT WHAT I WANT TO DO
AND- IN MY FUTURE WHILE
ENJOYING MY EDUCATION. I
DISCOVERED A LONG PRODUCTION
DESIGN I FOUND A JOB IN THE
MARKETING OFFICE IN MY
COMMUNITY COLLEGE. AND I'M NOT
GETTING A REAL WORK EXPERIENCE
IN SOMETHING THEY'RE GRATEFUL
PASSIONATE ABOUT. AND ALL
BECAUSE OF THIS CALL THE
QUESTION BUT I RECEIVED THROUGH
THE. CONCORD PROGRAM. BORN IN
COMMUNITY THAT I FOUND THROUGH
THE THAT KEY TO MY SUCCESS.
WILL BE OF MY COUNSELORS. THEY
HAVE REALLY ME TO NAVIGATE
SCHOOL OF THE THIRD GENERATION
CULTURE. BEFORE GETTING INTO
THE PROGRAM I DIDN'T KNOW I
COULD MAKE TO A POINT WHERE YOU
KNOW. SO THAT COLLEGE WILL AND
BY NOW I FEEL I'M A BIT. HAVE
YOU KNOW AND MOTIVATION TO
BECAUSE TO THE FIRST PERSON IN
MY FAMILY TO GRADUATE FROM
COLLEGE. I FINALLY FEEL LIKE I
GOING TO ONE MEN WERE FUTURE
GOING I'M GOING TO TALK OR YOU
YOU KNOW. I'M GOING TO GO A
GREEN CARD DESIGN I'M GOING TO
DO BEST TO BY PUT AND BETWEEN.
I JUST WANT I SUPPORT- MIDDLE
SB SIX FIVE NINE BECAUSE THEY
WERE BE WILL ALLOW MORE YOUNG
STUDENTS TO PULL THE- AND
CAREERS AND WAY THAT IS. THINGS
FRIENDS BECAUSE PROGRAM IT TO I
COULD HIRE ANY CHANGE WHICH
OTHERWISE WOULD BE HAVING
POSSIBLE. I WOULD LIKE ME MANY
OTHERS STUDENTS TO RECEIVE SAME
PER. SUPPORT THAT I HAVE
RECEIVED THROUGH THE BOOK.
THANK YOU FOR GIVING ME THAT
THE NEED TO CHECK. I THINK WE
CAN TODAY. THANK THANK YOU WILL
NOW GO TO THOSE AND HERE IN
FORTY TWO OR THREE C. NONE WILL
MOVED OVER TWENTY. SEEING NO
ONE THERE WILL GO TO THE
TELEPHONE MISSED MODERATOR YOU
PLEASE QUEUE UP ANYONE. WHO
SPEAKING IT'S A OF B. C.
FIFTEEN. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
YOU WOULD LIKE TO SHOW SUPPORT
HONEST SIX NINE PRESS FOLLOWED
ZERO RIGHT NOW. COOPER YOU WILL
GO AHEAD GIVE YOUR LINE NUMBER.
AND PLACE YOU BACK IN QUEUE. SO
GOAL PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED
BY ZERO AT THIS TIME. OUR FIRST
QUESTION TODAY WILL COME FROM
ONE THIRTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HOW ARE PLEASE GO LINE
THIRTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING- MANY DEER MAKING
ON BEHALF OF THE FOUNDING
EVERGREEN COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICT VERY MUCH IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU AND AS A
REMINDER FOR EVERYBODY ELSE
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZEROS TO PLACE YOURSELF IN Q.
TO SHOW SUPPORT FOR SB SIX
FIFTY NINE AND NEXT WE'LL GO TO
LINE SIXTY SEVEN. SIXTEEN JOHN
THANK YOU THIS IS JOHN PIMENTEL
AND THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
GRADUATE WHO TRANSFERRED TO THE
UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA JUST THE
WAY THE SYSTEM WAS SUPPOSED TO
WORK- I'M ALSO CURRENTLY A
TRUSTEE OF THE SAN MATTEO
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICT AND
STRONGLY SUPPORT THE BILL.
THANK YOU. THE AND A FINAL
REMINDER PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO TO SHOW
SUPPORT FOR SB. SIX FIFTY NINE.
M. MADAM CHAIR WITH THE COST TO
THE QUEUE PLEASE CONTINUE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MR MODERATOR
MEMBERS WILL NOW GO TO LEAD
OPPOSITION WHICH I AM SHOWING
NONE SO WE WILL GO TO ANY
OPPOSITION HERE FORTY AT FORTY
TWO OH THREE. SEEING NONE LET'S
GO TO TWENTY FORTY SEEING NONE
MISTER MODERATOR BACK TO YOU
COULD YOU PLEASE KEEP ANYONE
WHO WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION. SB SIX FIFTY NINE.
THANK YOU INITIAL OPPOSITION
FOR SB SIX FIFTY NINE PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT
THIS TIME. THE FINAL REMINDER
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO IF YOU'D LIKE TO SHOW
OPPOSITION TO SB SIX FIVE NINE.
OKAY THANK YOU. NOBODY IS
QUEUING UP AT THIS TIME THANK
YOU MR MODERATOR GONNA BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE DOES
ANYONE HAVE ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. OF THE BILL THANK YOU
SENATOR PAN THE BILL HAS BEEN
MOVED BY SENATOR PAN WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE CENTER BAKER.
THANK YOU ARE RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE VERY GOOD
THE BILL'S BEEN MOVED BY CENTER
PAN MADAM CONSULTANT PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ITEM NUMBER
EIGHT SB SIX FIFTY NINE THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
BUT FIRST AMEND AND RE REFER TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
LEYVA HI LEYVA AYE OCHO ABODE.
A TROUBLED COURTESY COURTESY I
DALLY. DAILY AYE GLAZER MCGUIRE
PAN AYE PAN AYE VERY GOOD WILL
LEAVE THAT BILL ON CALL. WILL
NOW MOVE TO FILE ITEM NUMBER
NINE SB SEVEN SIX SEVEN SENATOR
BAKER PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE
READY. I THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS AND ONE ALSO THANKTHE
STAFF FOR ITS WORK ON THIS BILL
AS WELL SEVEN SIXTY SEVEN WHICH
CREATES A DIGITAL EDUCATION
EQUITY PROGRAM. PROVIDE
EQUITABLE EDUCATION EDUCATIONAL
TECHNOLOGY AND NETWORK SUPPORT
TO ALL CALIFORNIA PUBLIC SCHOOL
DISTRICTS. I DON'T NEED TO TELL
YOU HOW A CRITICAL TECHNOLOGY
HAS BECOME IN ALL ASPECTS OF
OUR SOCIETY. FOR THE LAST
TWENTY YEARS. IT IS QUITE AN
INCREASE NEED TO SUPPORT
PREPARE EDUCATORS TO OVERSTATE
THE ART INSTRUCTION. SUPPORTS
THE CURRICULUM DIGITAL LITERACY
STANDARDS AND EFFECTIVE. REMOTE
FOR DISTANCE LEARNING. WEBER
EDUCATORS SCHOOL LACK AT TO.
INFORMATION AND PROFESSIONAL TO
COST EFFECT PLAN. AND IMPLEMENT
CURRENT AND EMERGING
TECHNOLOGIES. PREVIOUS STATE
FEDERAL LEGISLATION AUTHORIZING
STATE REGIONAL LOCAL PROGRAMS
WITH SUFFICIENT BUDGET
ALLOCATIONS DID DO A LOT TO
HELP THIS ISSUE OVER THE PAST
TWENTY FIVE YEARS. HOWEVER
STATE SUPPORT ENDED WHEN
FUNDING WAS CONSOLIDATED UNDER
THE LOCAL CONTROL FUNDING
FORMULA. WITHOUT ACCORDING TO
STATE AND REGIONAL FOCUS ON
POLICY PROGRAMS AND FUNDING
MANY DISTRICTS DO NOT HAVE
EQUAL ACCESS TO THE RESOURCES
NEEDED TO SELECT ACCESS TO
IMPLEMENT TECHNOLOGY
PROTECTIVELY. THE PROVIDE
STUDENTS ACCESS TO THESE
RESOURCES FROM THEIR HOMES. THE
TRANSITION TO DISTANCE LEARNING
DURING COVERT NINETEEN
DRAMATICALLY EXPOSED AND THE IT
STARK INEQUALITIES AMONG SCHOOL
DISTRICTS IN OUR COMMUNITIES.
SB SEVEN SIXTY SEVEN IS A STEP
TOWARDS CLOSING THE DIVIDE IN
CALIFORNIA SCHOOLS. FIRST
DISTRICTS REPAIR A TECHNOLOGY
COMPONENT TO THE LOCAL CONTROL
ACCOUNTABILITY PLAN SIGNAL CAP
TULO PLANNED USE OF FEDERAL
FUNDING TO SUPPORT NEDED
TECHNOLOGY RELATED PROFESSIONAL
LEARNING A TECHNICAL SUPPORT.
PROVIDES A COST EFFECTIVE
APPROACH TO HELP SCHOOL
DISTRICTS IDENTIFY AND SELECT
EDUCATIONAL TECHNOLOGY
APPLICATIONS AND DEVICES
APPROPRIATE FOR SCHOOL
INSTRUCTION. LASTLY IN CONCERT
WITH THE COUNTY OFFICES OF
EDUCATION DEPARTMENT WILL
DEVELOP ANNUALLY EDUCATION
TECHNOLOGY PLANS TO ENSURE
COORDINATION OF INFORMATION
RESOURCES BASED ON LOCAL NEEDS
FOR TECHNOLOGY SUPPORT.
INFORMING FUTURE FUNDING. WITH
ME TO TESTIFY OR LAURIE. CHIEF
TECHNOLOGY OFFICER AT THE
CEMETERY COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION DR BARBER NEMCO WHO
WITH THE NAPA COUNTY
SUPERINTENDENT SCHOOLS AND JOHN
CROTHERS OFTEN LINE TO ANSWER
ANY TECHNICAL QUESTIONS THANK
YOU AND ESPECIALLY REQUEST AN
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU CENTER
BECKER- IS ALWAYS WOULD YOU
LIKE TO BEGIN. YES ARE YOU ABLE
TO HEAR ME WE ARE. OKAY GREAT
HELLO GOOD MORNING AND THANK
YOU ALL FOR- CONSIDERING THIS
BILL I'M HERE- MY NAME IS
LAURIE OLIN AND I AM THE CHIEF
TECHNOLOGY OFFICER FOR THE
SEVENTY- COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION AND I'M HERE TO-
REQUEST YOUR SUPPORT IN YOUR
BODY FOR. SB SEVEN SIXTY SEVEN
AS THAT THAT TECHNOLOGY- BEAT
OR A COUNTY OPPORTUNITY CATION
AND I HAVE BEEN IN. K. TWELVE
EDUCATION FOR WELL OVER TWENTY
FIVE YEARS A LOT OF THE THINGS
THAT I'VE SEEN OVER THE YEARS
IS THAT NEED FOR NOT ONLY- OUR
DEVICES AND ITEMS TO BE
PROVIDED TO STUDENTS AND
TEACHERS BUT FOR THE
ACCOMPANYING. INFORMATION FOR
TRAINING SOMETIMES IT TAKES
ACTUAL CAN HOLDING IF YOU WILL
SHE ACTIVELY ALL OUT THAT
TECHNOLOGY FOR STUDENTS IN WHAT
WE SAW WITH COLD AT NIGHT SHE
IS. HAVING TO PAY THAT OFF A
DIME IT DIDN'T STUDENTS HOME TO
LEARN REMOTELY THE CALLED THAT
HAVE ALREADY IMPLEMENTED ONE TO
ONE- PROGRAMS AND HAD TRAIN
TEACHERS AND STUDENTS THAT.
EXPOSURE TO THIS TYPE OF
LEARNING WERE ABLE TO ADAPT
VERY QUICKLY BUT THOSE THAT
DIDN'T HAVE THAT ARE UNDER
SERVED STUDENTS ARE SOME OF
THEM IT TOOK MONTHS FOR THEM
TO. EVEN GET THE VERY GET ON
AND SOME STUDENTS TO NAVIGATE
COULD CONNECT BECAUSE. OF THEIR
LACK OF ACCESS. HAVE A REGIONAL.
THAT WE USED TO HAVE IN IN
PLACE AT THE THAT WOULD BEEN SO
MUCH EASIER IT WOULD SO BOB
BETTER IN WOULD HAVE ALLOWED
DOES UNDERSERVED STUDENTS AND
SCHOOL INTO. HAD ACCESS TO THAT
KNOW HOW TO INFORMATION TO THE-
TO- THE VICTIM GENERAL AFTER
THAT NEEDED FOR STUDENT FOR
STAFF MEMBERS TEACHERS AND IN
THE CASE CURRENT WORD OR HAVE
TO ADD THEIR THAT HOME WE WOULD
HAVE BEEN SO MUCH BETTER
VERSION HAVE YOUR ALL OVER
INTENSITY ACTUALLY OTHER STARK.
SO I URGE YOU YOU TO CLEAN. UP
THE PORT THIS BILL SO THAT WE
CAN. BRING BETTER EQUITY THE
AREA OF. SUPPORT DISTANCE
LEARNING TO OUR- A THE STATE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
MS NEMCO HAVE TWO MINUTES.
THANK YOU GOOD MORNING AND I
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
TALK TO YOU I'M IN MY- SIX TERM
MY TWENTY FIFTH YEAR THAT THE
COUNTY SUPERINTENDENT OF
SCHOOLS. THANK YOU FUND A LOT
OF TIME THIS MORNING TALKING
ABOUT THE EFFECT OF THE
PANDEMIC AND BE IN EQUITY
ACROSS THE STATE YEAH WHAT KIDS
ARE RECEIVING. OUT WE SPENT
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS WITH
DEVICES BUT DEVICES ARE ONLY AS
GOOD AS WHAT WE DO WITH THEM
THEY CAN DRILL AND KILL WARRANT
THEY CAN BE EXCITING ENGAGING
MOTIVATING AND INTERACTIVE.
BECAUSE OF THE PANDEMIC WE HAVE
GOT AN OBLIGATION TO REACH OUT
AND NOT TO PROVIDE REMEDIATION
TO FILL IN THE GAPS THAT WE
CAUSED BY THIS YEAR BUT WE NEED
TO GO BEYOND WE NEED TO PROVIDE
ACCELERATION AND RICHMOND AND
EXCITING CURRICULUM EXCITING
LESSONS. TEACHERS ARE NOT BORN
WITH THIS ABILITY TO USE
TECHNOLOGY EVEN THE YOUNG ONES
KNOW HOW TO USE THAT PERSONALLY
BUT NOT NECESSARILY IN THE
CLASSROOM WE MUST MAKE SURE
THAT PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT
PROVIDED EQUALLY WITH EQUITY
ACRSS THE STATE PARTICULARLY
RURAL DISTRICT MALL THAT. FOR
DISTRICT BUT DON'T HAVE THE
FUNDING TO PROVIDE THEIR OWN
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT THIS
BILL WOULD ENABLE THEM TO GIVE
THEIR KIDS WHAT KIDS IN NAPA
COUNTY ARE GETTING BECAUSE OUR
VISITORS GIVE US FUNDING TO DO
THE PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT
THAT'S SO IMPORTANT. SO I URGE
YOU TO SUPPORT SEVEN SIX SEVEN
AND AKE SURE THAT EVERY
DISTRICT HAS THE OPPORTUNITY TO
GET THIS KIND. OF PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. MEMBERS WE WILL TO THE IN
SOME HERE IN FORTY TWO OH
THREE. SEEING NONE GO TO ROOT
FOR FOUR. THING WE'LL BRING IT
BACK TO THE PHONE LINE MISTER
TO HAVE ANYONE UP TO IN SUPPORT
OF S. SEVEN SIX SEVEN. YOUR
SUPPORT FOR SB SEVEN SIX SEVEN.
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO. BEGIN TO SHOW YOUR
SUPPORT FOR SB SEVEN SIX SEVEN
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE DO HAVE A
COUPLE QUEUEING UP. IT WILL
BEGIN TODAY WITH WIND FORTY ONE
MADAM CHAIR PLEASE GO AHEAD
FORTY ONE. FORTY ONE IS YOUR
PHONE. HELLO THERE YOU GO WE
CAN'T I AM DOCTOR LISA GONZALES
CHIEF BUSINESS OFFICER IN THE
MOUNT DIABLO UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT MEMBER OF TE
CALIFORNIA ED TECH TASK FORCE
AND TWENTY SEVENTEEN PRESIDENT
OF THE ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
pADMINISTRATORS I SUPPORT SB.
SEVEN SIX SEVEN. MISTER
MODERATOR TO HAVE ANYONE ELSE
IN SUPPORT. YES WE DO THEY'RE
QUEUING UP WITH AN OPERATOR ONE
MOMENT PLEASE. WE WILL GO TO
LINE EIGHTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU FOR HEARING ME TODAY
MY NAME IS ROLAND BAKER I WORK
FOR THE SANTA CRUZ COUNTY
OFFICE FOR MANY YEARS AND WAS A
PRINCIPAL AND WORKED IN
DISTRICTS BEFORE THAT. I
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL AS I
WAS EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF A
STATE WIDE PROJECT TRAINING
ADMINISTRATORS PERFECT THANK
YOU WERE DEVELOPING PROBABLY
MYSELF OR ELLS STRONGLY SUPPORT
IT THANK YOU SIR. NEXT WITNESS.
THANK YOU WE WILL ALIGN NINETY
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI GOOD
MORNING- MY NAME IS JASON
BORGEN I'M THE CHIEF TECHNOLOGY
OFFICER FOR SANTA CRUZ COUNTY
OFFICE OF EDUCATION AND FORMER
BOARD PRESIDENT OF COMPUTER
USING EDUCATORS AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT- L. SEVEN SIXTY SEVEN.
THANK YOU. EXCELLENT AND WE
WILL GO TO LINE ONE ZERO ONE
ONE A ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. I AM
DR PAMELA REDMOND I AM SURE OF
GRADUATE STUDIES AND INNOVATIVE
LEARNING PROGRAM AT TURNER
UNIVERSITY I'M ALSO A BOARD
MEMBER OF NAFTA LEARN. IN A
BOARD MEMBER OF THE COMPUTER
USING EDUCATORS- A GROUP OF-
NORTH BAY I JUST WANTED TO LET
YOU KNOW THAT IF POLICE
DEPARTMENTS BILL AND I THINK
THE BIGGEST NATIONAL FOR A
TITLE WE'RE JUST ASKING FORTY.
S. MODERATOR NEXT COLLEGE. AND
AT THIS TIME WE HAVE NO OTHER
PARTICIPANTS CUED UP WOULD YOU
LIKE ME TO REPEAT. ONE MORE
TIME AND I'M SURE. I KNOW WE'RE
GOOD THANK YOU VERY MUCH. WELL
WE'RE GOING TO GO TO LEAD
OPPOSITION I DO NOT HAVE ANY
LEAD OPPOSITION. LISTED LOOKING
FOR ANY OPPOSITION HERE IN
FORTY TWO OH THREE. SEEING
NONE. LET'S GO TO ROOM TWENTY
FORTY. SEEING NONE THERE LET'S
BRING IT BACK TO YOU MISTER
MODERATED WITH ANYONE WHO'D
LIKE TO QUEUE UP AND SEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF SB. SEVEN SIX
SEVEN. TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION
FOR SB SIX SEVEN SEVEN SIXTY
SEVEN SKEWS ME PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. BY ONE MORE
TIME TO SHOW OPPOSITION FOR
BILL SB SEVEN SIXTY SEVEN
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO. I MANAGER NOBODY'S
QUEUING UP AT THIS TIME THANK
YOU MR MODERATOR WE'RE GONNA
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
IS ANYONE HAVE ANY QUESTIONS
COMMENTS SENATOR PAN. JUST
BRIEFLY- CENTER BACKGROUND I
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS
BILL FORWARD I THINK WE SEEN
CODE HOW PORTENT TECHNOLOGY
REALLY IS ESPECIALLY IN A
CRISIS LIKE WE'RE FACING AND-
CERTAINLY AS WE COME OUT OF
THIS PANDEMIC TECHNOLOGIES GOT
PLAY A MUCH LARGER ROLE. THIS
BILL SO IMPORTANT TO BE SURE
WE'RE ON THE RIGHT TRACK WITH
THAT SO I THINK YOU AND ALSO
MOVE THE BILL THANK YOU. THANK
YOU CENTER PAN ANYONE ELSE WHO
WISHES TO SPEAK ON THE BILL
THING THEN CENTER BAKER WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR COMMENTS I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE THANK YOU SIR. SENATOR PAN
HAS MOVED THE BILL MADAM
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ITEM NUMBER NINE SB SEVEN SIXTY
SEVEN THE MOTION IS TO PASS BUT
FIRST BE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
LEYVA. HI LEVI OCHO ABODE HI
THE CHOI BOGUE AYE COURTESY.
AYE BECAUSE THE I. DALLI- AYE
DALY AYE GLAZER AYE GLAZER AYE
MCGUIRE PAN RIGHT AND I BELIEVE
THAT BELONG CALL THANK YOU
SENATOR BAKER THE REST OF THE
DAY. WE'RE GOING TO MOVE BACK
TO FILE ITEM NUMBER SIX SB FIVE
NINETY THREE SENATOR GLAZERS.
PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU MATTER CHAIR NOW.
SEPARATE SHADES OP. PER TO ADD
FIVE NINETY THREE AND ONE OF
THAT EXCELLENT. STAFF FOR THEIR
WORK WITH MY OFFICE IN CRAFTING
AMENDMENTS TO MAKE THE BILL.
BETTER SB FIVE NINETY THREE
WOULD IMPROVE INDEPENDENT
AUDITS. OF THE NON CLASSROOM
BASED CHARTER SCHOOLS SOMETIMES
CALLED INDEPENDENT STUDY. TO
GIVE US A BETTER CHANCE OF CATS
CATCHING FRAUD. BEFORE IT GETS
OUT OF CONTROL. THIS BILL IS
BASED ON RECOMMENDATIONS FROM
THE SAN DIEGO COUNTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE. WHICH
UNCOVERED AND PROSECUTED MAJOR
SCHOOL FRAUD CASE IN TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN IN TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY. NINE CLASSROOM
BASED SCHOOLS ARE DEFINED AS
SCHOOLS WERE MORE THAN 20% OF
THE INSTRUCTIONAL TIME. AND
OUTSIDE THE CLASSROOM. THE
SCHOOLS CAN BE A HUGE HELP TO
STUDENTS WHO CANNOT ATTEND IN
SCHOOL INSTRUCTION OR WHOSE
FAMILIES FIND AT THAT
INDEPENDENT STUDY IS A BETTER
OPTION FOR THEIR CHILDREN. MANY
OF THE STUDENTS COME FROM
DISADVANTAGED BACKGROUNDS.
INDEPENDENT STUDY IS OFTEN
THEIR LAST CHANCE TO COMPLETE
THEIR EDUCATION. PUBLIC CHARTER
SCHOOLS HAVE LONG EXCELLED IN
THE SPACE BECAUSE OF THEIR
FLEXIBILITY AND COMMITMENT TO
INNOVATION. DURING THE PANDEMIC
THE SPECIALIZED NICHE. SERVE
THE STATE WELL AS PARENTS WERE
LOOKING FOR OPTIONS IN THE FACE
OF WIDESPREAD SCHOOL CLOSURES.
BUT THE SAME TRAITS THAT MAY
MAKE NINE CLASSROOM BASED
SCHOOLS VALUABLE. ALSO LEADS
THE MODEL VULNERABLE TO ABUSE.
ENROLLMENT EXPENSES ANY
ACADEMIC PROGRAM ARE MORE
DIFFICULT TO TRACK IN THE
SCHOOLS BECAUSE THEY DON'T
OPERATE OUT OF A SINGLE
PHYSICAL SPACE. THAT HAS
ALLOWED A HANDFUL OF SHADY
OPERATORS TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF
TE MODEL FOR PERSONAL GAINS.
THE MOST EGREGIOUS OF THESE
CASES WAS THE A. THREE SCHOOL
NETWORK BASED IN SAN DIEGO
COUNTY. THAT'S COOL. THAT'S
COOL OPERATORS STILL MORE THAN
TWO HUNDRED MILLION. IN
TAXPAYER DOLLARS. THE SCHOOL
DID THIS BY CREATING FAKE
ENROLLMENT RECORDS AND THEN
COLLECTING REIMBURSEMENT FROM
THE STATE FOR NON EXISTENT
STUDENTS. EIGHT THREE FUNNEL
THAT MONEY INTO SHELL COMPANIES
CONTROLLED BY THE SCHOOL'S
OPERATORS. THE AUDITORS ARE
SUPPOSED TO SURVEY A RANDOM
SAMPLE OF INDEPENDENT STUDY
STUDENTS EVERY YEAR TO VERIFY
ENROLLMENT. BUT THE AUDITORS
WHO REVIEWED EIGHTY THREES
RECORDS. MISTER AND MISS THIS
FRAUD TESTIFIED TO THE GRAND
JURY THAT THE SCHOOL MANAGERS
HAD SELECTED THE STUDENTS THAT
HE VERIFIED STEERING HIM AWAY
FROM THE PHONY ENROLLMENT. SB
FIVE NINETY THREE WOULD REQUIRE
AUDITORS TO PICK THOSE RANDOM
SAMPLES THEMSELVES FREE OF ANY
DIRECTION FROM THE SCHOOL. THE
BILL WOULD ALSO REQUIRE
AUDITORS TO FLAG ANY
TRANSACTIONS GREATER THAN ONE
MILLION DOLLARS 410% OF THE
SCHOOLS BUDGET AND THE TEST A
RANDOM SAMPLE OF TRANSACTIONS
AGAINST A QUOTE MATERIALITY
STANDARD UNQUOTE. TO ENSURE
THAT THE MONEY IS SPENT FOR
INSTRUCTIONAL PURPOSES. FINALLY
THIS BILL WOULD REQUIRE ANY
INDEPENDENT AUDITOR REVIEWING A
NON CLASSROOM BASED CHARTER
SCHOOL TO COMPLETE A TRAINING
COURSE OFFERED BY THE FISCAL
CRISIS MANAGEMENT ASSISTANT
TEAM KNOWN AS FICK MAD. NO
SAFEGUARD CAN NEVER STOP EVERY
CRIMINAL TO DETERMINE TO CHEAT
THE SYSTEM AND TO STEAL PUBLIC
FUNDS. AND WHILE THE EXAMPLE I
GAVE TODAY INVOLVED A CHARTER
SCHOOL. STILL SCHOOLS ALSO
VICTIMS FINANCIAL FRAUD. BUT WE
CAN DO MORE TO TRY TO PREVENT
THESE CRIMES AND WE CAN DO IT
IN A STRATEGIC WAY. THAT DOES
NOT PUNISH THE MANY ETHICAL
PUBLIC CHARTER SCHOOL MANAGERS
AND TEACHERS WHO ARE THE BEST
INTERESTS OF THEIR STUDENTS IN
THEIR COMMUNITIES AT HEART SB
FIVE NINETY THREE DOES JUST
THAT IRESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
AYE VOTE WITH ME TODAY- ARE
CARLOS MARQUEZ REPRESENTATION
IN EDUCATION AND JEFF RICE
SPEAKING FOR THE A PLUS
PERSONALIZED LEARNING NETWORK
ASSOCIATION THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
SENATOR GLAZERS MISTER MARQUEZ
AND MR RIGHT BOTH HAVE TO
MANAGE MINUTES EACH PLEASE
PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU CARLOS MARQUEZ ABOUT
PROVISIONS IN EDUCATION IN
SUPPORT OF SB FIVE NINETY THREE
AND FIRST THANK YOU SENATOR
GLAZERS FOR YOUR DEALERSHIP ON
THIS IMPORTANT ISSUE. ISN'T AN
EDUCATION IS THAT NON CLASSROOM
BASED CHARTER SCHOOL SERVING
SEVEN THOUSAND STUDENTS IN THE
GREATER SACRAMENTO REGION AND
BAY AREA. YOU'RE A COMBINATION
OF INDEPENDENT THAT THE
UNIVERSITY PRESS AND HOME
SCHOOL PROGRAMS. BEIJING HAS
BEEN OPERATING WITH
TRANSPARENCY INTEGRITY FOR THE
PAST TWENTY YEARS AND WE DO THE
INDEPENDENT AUDIT AND TRAINING
REQUIREMENTS CONTAINED IN SB
FIVE NINE THREE AT THEM THE
BALL AND EFFECTIVE DETERRENT.
TO THE FRAUD PERPETRATED IN
CANYON COUNTY BY LEADERS OF THE
H. THREE CHARTER SCHOOL
NETWORK. SB FIVE NINETY THREE
WOULD CODIFY NEARLY ALL OF SAN
DIEGO DA'S INDEPENDENT AUDIT
POLICY RECOMMENDATIONS AND
FURTHER PROPOSES INDEPENDENT
AUDIT ENHANCEMENTS BEYOND THOSE
RECOMMENDED BY ANTIOQUIA ACT.
AS WE LEARN WORKING CLOSELY
WITH THICK MAT REQUIRING AN
AUTOMATIC FRAUD ON IT AT EVERY
NON CLASSROOM BASED CHARTER
SCHOOL. AS ADVOCATED BY THE
OPPOSITION IS IMPRACTICABLE ON
THE BASIS THAT OF TWO FACTORS.
THE LIMITED CAPACITY OF BROADER
IS IN CALIFORNIA AND THE
EXORBITANT COSTS ASSOCIATED
WITH CONDUCTING SUCH PRODUCTS.
INSTEAD S. B. FIVE NINETY THREE
RETOOL ANNUAL INDEPENDENT
FINANCIAL AUDIT IN A MANNER
THAT TRIAGE IS SCHOOLS. CLEARED
OF ANY IRREGULAR ACTIVITY FROM
SCHOOLS THAT HAVE DEMONSTRATED
IRREGULAR ACTIVITY. THEREBY
PAVING THE WAY FOR POSSIBLE
FRAUD AUDIT OF THOSE IDENTIFIED
SCHOOLS THAT HAVE BEEN ENGAGED
IN A REGULAR ACTIVITY. MASON
BELIEVES THAT THE REFORMS
CONTAINED IN SB FIVE NINE THREE
WILL DRAMATICALLY TO CHARAKTER
TRINITY'S FOR SELF DEALING AND
FRAUD. WHILE PRESERVING ON
CLASSROOM BASED CHARTER SCHOOLS
AT THE NETWORK PUBLIC SCHOOL
OPTION FOR STUDENTS REQUIRE
NONTRADITIONAL LEARNING
ENVIRONMENTS. AND FOR THESE
REASONS WE RESPECTFULLY URGE- I
ABOUT. THANK YOU MISTER MARQUEZ
MISTER RICE. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS
RIGHT FOUNDER DIRECTOR THE A
PLUS PERSONALLY LEARNING THAT
IS SO. WHICH IS A STATE MEMBERS
THIS. COMPRISED OF EIGHTY FIVE
PERSONALIZED LEARNING PUBLIC.
CHARTER SCHOOL MEMBERS SERVING
MORE THAN SEVENTY FIVE THOUSAND
OF CALIFORNIA'S K. TWELVE
STUDENTS. THE A PLUS NETWORK
AND ITS MEMBER SCHOOLS HAVE
BEEN COMMITTED FOR NINETEEN
YEARS TO HIGH STANDARDS OF
INTEGRITY ACCOUNTABILITY
TRANSPARENCY. AND ACADEMIC
EXCELLENCE WE SUPPORT SB FIVE
NINETY THREE BOTH AS A
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT STEP IN
CLOSING PASSED KNOWLEDGE GAPS
AND POTENTIAL LOOPHOLES IN
ANNUAL AUDIT REVIEWS. OF THE
ROCK VARIETY OF MODELS AND
PRACTICES WITHIN THE NON
CLASSROOM BASED CHARTER SCHOOL
SEGMENT. AND IS A STRONG
MEASURE TO PROVIDE IMPORTANT
TRAINING AND PREPARATION. IN
THE UNIQUE KNOWLEDGE AND SKILL
REQUIREMENTS FOR AUDITORS OF
NON CLASSROOM BASED CHARTER
SCHOOLS IN THE FUTURE. FOR
YEARS THE NON CLASSROOM BASED
STATUTORY CLASSIFICATION HAS
BEEN AN UNFORTUNATE MISNOMER
THAT HAS LED TO SERIOUS
CONFUSION MISUNDERSTANDING AND
MISINFORMATION. ABOUT THE
VARIETY OF VERY INNOVATIVE
EDUCATION DELIVERY MILES WITHIN
THE SEGMENT. MANY OF WHICH
INCLUDE PERSONALIZED BLENDED
AND HYBRID LEARNING MODELS FOR
STUDENTS AS WELL AS- NUMEROUS
OPTIONS AND OPPORTUNITIES FOR
LEARNING AT SCHOOL SITE
FACILITIES. FOR UP 280% OF EACH
STUDENT'S INSTRUCTIONAL TIME.
THE REPORT RELEASED THIS WEEK
BY THE CALIFORNIA CHARTER
SCHOOLS ASSOCIATION PROVIDES
THE MOST COMPREHENSIVE THOROUGH
AND ACCURATE ASSESSMENT OF THE
VARIOUS MODELS AND PRACTICES
WITHIN THE NON CLASSROOMS A
SEGMENT WRITTEN. AS THESE
PROGRAMS HAVE EVOLVED AND
ADAPTED THROUGH THE YEARS TO
RESPOND TO THE NEEDS OF THEIR
STUDENTS. AND INDEPENDENT
ANNUAL REVIEW OF THESE UNIQUE
EDUCATION MODELS IN OPERATIONS
REQUIRES SPECIALIZED SKILLS AND
EXPERIENCE IN ORDER FOR AN
OUTSIDE PROFESSIONAL TO
IDENTIFY BOTH GOOD PRACTICES
AND POTENTIALLY QUESTIONABLE
PRACTICES. PROPOSED LEGISLATION
THAT IS SEEKING TO ADDRESS THE
VIOLATIONS OF THE PUBLIC TRUST
UP TO BAD ACTOR. ORGANIZATIONS
IN THE FLAG AND PLUS RECOGNIZE
THE ACTUAL WORK BEING BY THESE
GOOD QUALITY PUBLIC CHARTER
SCHOOLS AND DO NO HARM TO THEM
WHEN SEEKING TO REMEDY
POTENTIAL VULNERABILITIES IN
LAW THAT MAY HAVE LED TO
ABUSES. SB FIVE NINETY THREE IS
A SOUND PROPOSAL IN ACHIEVING
THIS IMPORTANT GOAL IS BASED ON
THE SAN DIEGO DA'S. INDEPENDENT
AUDIT POLICY RECOMMENDATIONS
AND WILL PROVIDE STRONGER AND
BETTER TRAINED INDEPENDENT EYES
IN REVIEWING NON CLASSROOM
BASED OPERATIONS AND PRACTICES
ANNUALLY. THANK YOU TO SENATOR
GLAZER FOR OFFERING SB FIVE
NINETY THREE AND THANK YOU FOR
THIS OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF SB FIVE NINETY THREE
WE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE AS WELL. THANK YOU
MYSTERIES WILL NOW GO TO
SUPPORT HERE IN ROOM FORTY TWO
OH THREE SEEING NONE WILL GROW
TO ROOM TWENTY FORTY. SEEING NO
ONE THERE MISTER MODERATOR
GOING TO GO TO YOU FOR ANYONE
WHO'S COMING UP IN SUPPORT OF
SB FIVE NINETY THREE PLEASE.
THANK YOU AYE MADAM CHAIR TO
SHOW YOUR SUPPORT FOR SB. FIVE
NINETY THREE PRESS STAR FORUMS
ONE FOLLOWED BY THE ZERO PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO TO
SHOW YOUR SUPPORT AND ONE
MOMENT. AND WE WILL GO TO ONE
FIFTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU- MADAM CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS THIS IS ALEX
KAPLER ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CHARTER SCHOOLS
ASSOCIATION. WHILE WE HAVE NO
POSITIONS CURRENTLY ON THE BILL
WE ARE KEY STAKEHOLDER AS WE
REPRESENT NON CLASSROOM BASED
CHARTER SCHOOLS AS PART OF OUR
MEMBERSHIP. AND WE APPRECIATE
THE AUTHOR SPONSORING
COMMITTEES WORK ON THAT I THINK
THESE ARE SENSIBLE POLICY
REFORMS AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING- ON THIS MOVING FORWARD
I'M AT A LARGER CONVERSATION
ABOUT NON CLASSROOM DAY.
CHARTER SCHOOL THANK YOU THANK
YOU. THANK YOU TO SHOW YOUR
SUPPORT AGAIN PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. I'M SURE
NOBODY ELSE'S QUEUING UP AT
THIS TIME THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WE WILL NOW GO TO LEAD
OPPOSITION I HAVE SAID BRAMBLE
THE LEGISLATIVE ADVOCATE FOR
THE CALIFORNIA TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION AND GERMANY'S
ANNIKA A TWELFTH GRADE TEACHER
AT OSCAR DE LA HOYA. ME AN
EMAIL CHARTER HIGH SCHOOL A
GENTLEMAN YOU BOTH HAVE A
LITTLE OVER TWO MINUTES AS
SUPPORT WENT OVER AND THEIR
TIME PLEASE PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE
READY. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
BRAMBELL SPEAKING FOR CTA
RESPECTFULLY IN OPPOSITION TO
SENATE BILL FIVE NINETY THREE
AS IT WAS AMENDED LAST WEEK. WE
RECENTLY ESTABLISHED A
MORATORIUM ON NEW NON CLASSROOM
BASED CHARTER SCHOOLS THAT
WORKS ON THAT THIS YEAR AND
WE'RE VERY CONCERNED THAT THIS
BILL. WILL OPEN TH FLOODGATES
TO CONTINUE THE PROBLEMS THAT
WE'VE SEEN WITHOUT FIXING THEM.
AND I WANT TO LIFT UP TO
PROBLEMS THAT ARE NOT IN YOUR
ANALYSIS FIRST. MANY FAMILIES
HAVE CHOSEN TO PULL THEIR
CHILDREN OUT OF THE PUBLIC
EDUCATION SYSTEM AND HOME
SCHOOL THEIR CHILDREN INSTEAD
AND ROLLING IN THE SCHOOL HAS
BEEN USED AS A WAY TO
SUPPLEMENT VACATION EXPENSES.
WITH FAMILY SPENDING AS MUCH AS
THREE THOUSAND TWO HUNDRED
DOLLARS ANNUALLY SOMETHING LIKE
MULTI DAY FAMILY PASSES TO
DISNEYLAND. HOMESCHOOL BLOGGERS
ARE RIGHT ABOUT HOW CALIFORNIA
PARENTS CAN TAKE ADVANTAGE OF
THIS SCHEME OF THIS KIND OF
ARRANGEMENT IS NOT HAPPENING IN
ANY OTHER STATE IN THE NATION.
SENATE BILL FIVE NINETY THREE
WOULD MAKE IT POSSIBLE FOR THIS
KIND OF ABUSE TO CONTINUE TO
GROW SECONDLY. NOT QUESTION
BASED CHARTER SCHOOLS ARE
DEFINED IN CALIFORNIA LAW
PUBLIC SCHOOLS BUT MOST ARE NOT-PROVIDING ADEQUATE ACCESS TO
SPECIAL EDUCATION STUDENTS A CO
KIND OF EXPLICITLY PROVIDES.
THAT STUDENTS WITH SPECIAL
NEEDS MAY ONLY BE EDUCATED
THROUGH INDEPENDENT STUDY.
STUDENTS IEPS SPECIFICALLY
CALLS FOR AND AS A RESULT OF
LIMITING THEIR EDUCATIONAL
PROGRAM TO NON CLASSROOM BASED
INSTRUCTION THE SCHOOLS CAN
EXCLUDE STUDENTS WHO NEED
SPECIAL EDUCATION. A CONTROLS
IN PLACE WITH THE MATARA
MORATORIUM NOW PREVENT AN
OUTBURST OF NEW PUBLIC SCHOOLS
THAT WOULD NOT HAVE TO SERVE
ALL STUDENTS. BUT SENATE BILL
FIVE NINETY THREE DOES NOTHING
TO FIX THIS LAW. THE BILL
ANALYSIS DOES A GOOD JOB IN
HIGHLIGHTING HOW MANY OF THESE
SCHOOLS TARGET HIGH NEED SCHOOL
DISTRICT AND AUTHORIZERS.
BECAUSE THEY HAVE NO CAPACITY
TO DO OVERSIGHT IT POINTS OUT
THAT THE SCHOOLS ARE COLLECTING
THEIR OWN AUDITORS AND FIRING
THEM IF THEY DON'T HEAR WHAT
THEY WANT TO HEAR. IT
HIGHLIGHTS THOSE DOING THE
OVERSIGHT DO NOT HAVE
INDIVIDUAL STUDENT DATA FOR
THOSE ENROLLED. AND ONE IS NOT
A PHYSICAL CLASSROOM. WHERE YOU
CAN SEE WITH YOUR OWN EYES. BUT
THEIR TEACHER AND LEARNING.
PLACE MISTER IS THE LIKELY
OUTCOME. THE OTHER MAJOR
CONCERNS WITH NON. BASED
CHARTERS LAW AND WE'RE NOT. OF
A HANDFUL OF SHE OPERATE HERE
SENATE BILL FIVE NINETY THREE
DOES PROVIDE SOLUTION AND WE
WOULD ALLOW. BASICALLY THIS
BILL WOULD ALLOW THESE PROBLEMS
TO CONTINUE WE'RE URGING A NO
VOTE. THANK YOU MR BRAMBLE
PHARMACIES IN AGO PLEASE
PROCEED. GOOD AFTERNOON-
MEMBERS OF THE SENATE EDUCATION
COMMITTEE- LIKE I MENTIONED THE
ONE BENCH MANAGER MEETING I
TEACH WILL CREATE GOVERNMENT
AND ECONOMIC ALTERNATELY A AND
MUCH OF THE HIGH SCHOOL IN LA
WHICH IS ONE OF THE GREEN DOT
PUBLIC SCHOOLS I AGREE WITH
EVERYTHING ABOUT THE PARAMETERS
THAT AND THEY URGE YOU TO VOTE
NO ON SB FIVE NINETY THREE. I
WAS ACCUSTOMED TO RECENTLY
READING THE L. A. TIMES ABOUT
WHAT OCCURRED EIGHT THREE
EDUCATION LIKE GREEN DOT EIGHT
THREE OPERATED NINETEEN CHARTER
SCHOOL BUT THE ANIMAL STUDENTS
IN OUR SCHOOL BUT YOU'RE NOT
ACTUALLY DOING SCHOOL WORK FROM
WHAT I READ IN MOMENT WORKERS
WHAT APPROACH THE SUMMER
ATHLETICS PROGRAMS. NUMBER
TWENTY FIVE DOLLARS A HEAD FOR
EACH AFTER EACH PLAYER'S RECORD
IN ROMAN WORKER WOULD GET A
COMMISSION ON HOWEVER MANY
STUDENTS ENROLLED IN THE ADULTS
WHO ARE RUNNING THE SCHOOL
FIGURE OUT WAYS TO GET MORE
MONEY PER CHILD AND MAKE SURE
THAT. I AM WILLING STUDENTS AT
ONE SCHOOL DURING THE SCHOOL
YEAR AT ANOTHER SCHOOL DURING
THE SUMMER AS. IT WAS A
DIFFERENT SCHOOL YEAR. I OF
DOUBLE DIPPING THE- CHARTER.
ABOUT NAME. WHEN I READ IT A
THREE. AND THE- DEAL TO RETURN
THAN TWO. AND MILLION. IN CASH
I COULD. HELP THINK OF ALL OF
THE- THINGS. MY SCHOOL COULD
USE THAT MONEY FOR. LIKE HAVING
REASONABLE CLASS SIZES. AND
THREE PER TURN TO SCHOOL. HOW
THE PLOT HAS ALLOWED NON. BASED
COURSE HARDER SCHOOLS PRETTY
FUNDING. FOR SCHOOL BY MINE. IS
WHY I THINK WE NEED TO THE MORE.
ON NON BASED ON. BASED CHARTER
SCHOOL THAT WE CAN REALLY FIX
CLOCK HELLO SILVA. WHEN IT
COMES TO NON. BASED CHARTER
SCHOOLS AND OF COURSE. OF THE
TOPICS NEW POP WE NEED TO
CONNECTICUT RECALLS TO GET TO
THE ROOT OF THIS. DOING. THE
REAL. THE CLUB PARLANCE MONEY.
RIGHT INSTRUCTIONS SCHOOLS ARE
NOT PICKING PLACE LET'S GO
BUILDING WITH A COMING OUT
AGREED OVER THE YEAR. H. THE
ANY INDICATE FROM CLASS OUR
SCHOOLS MAY EVEN NOT MAY NOT
EVEN NEED MONEY FOR. NOT HARD
TO HOLD THE SAME I AM PROUD TO
BE A CHARGE SCHOOL AS YOU FOR
THE THIRTY YEARS BY THE- A LOT
ALLOWED THE KIND OF THE TO
OCCUR. WE BUT WE NEED BE ABLE
TO WEED OUT THOSE THAT ARE
EDUCATION FOR THE WRONG REASONS
AND THEN BILL OPENED UP THE
DOORS FOR THE BAD ACTOR TO WASH
HIS HANDS OF THE SCANDAL HE
KEEPS STEALING MONEY THAT
SHOULD BE GOING TO SUPPORT
STUDENTS AND COMMUNITIES LIKE.
MINE I URGE YOU TO VOTE NO.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. NOW TO ALL.
TO HEAR AN FORTY TWO OH THREE.
SEEING NONE WILL GO TO ROOM
TWENTY FORTY. SEEING NONE.
MISTER MODERATOR GOING TO BRING
IT BACK TO YOU DO WE HAVE
ANYONE QUEUING UP THAT WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION. SB
FIVE NINETY THREE. THANK YOU.
TO SHOW YOUR OPPOSITION SB FIVE
NINETY THREE PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT THIS TIME.
AND ONCE AGAIN IF YOU'D LIKE TO
SHOW OPPOSITION TO SB FIVE
NINETY THREE PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO. I'M SURE NOBODY IS
QUEUING UP. THANK YOU MR
MODERATOR WE'RE GONNA BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE DOES
ANYONE HAVE ANY QUESTIONS
COMMENTS. CONCERNS SENATOR
CORTESE. THE THIRTY MINIATURE
JUST EARNED- IF IT'S ME TO
PROVE THE CHAIR I JUST WANTED
THEM TO ASKS A WE HAVE OF THE
AUTHOR A COUPLE OF QUESTIONS-
NOT NECESSARILY- DETAILS
BROUGHT A BODY. BECAUSE SUPPORT
OR OPPOSITION- WITNESSES AT
THIS POINT. ONE OF THINGS THAT
CONCERN ME IN READING THROUGH
IT WAS WOULD SEEM TO BE A
RELATIVELY QUICK TURNAROUND ON
THE TRAINING THAT YOU'RE
CALLING FOR HIM TO JUST SAY-
LET ME PAUSE FOR A MINUTE AND
JUST SAY I THINK TO THE EXTENT
THAT THE BILL IS A ATTEMPTING
TO SORT OF BE FOR A POOR-
CREATE ALREADY- STANDARDS. IN
HAND AND TRAINING AND-
PRACTICES STOOD OR APPROPRIATE-
THAT'S A GOOD THING- REGARDLESS
OF. ONE'S FEELINGS ABOUT
WHETHER OR NOT- THIS PARTICULAR
TYPE OF NON CLASSROOM BASED
EDUCATION- SHOULD CONTINUE IN
THE FUTURE AS IT CONTINUES IT
SHOULD BE AUDITED THAT'S MY
FUNDAMENTAL FEELING. BUT WHAT I
BACK TO MY INITIAL CONCERN AS
YOU- HE THE WAY I READ THE BILL
NOT BEEN PERHAPS IT'S BEEN
AMENDED BUT- HE- IS THERE'S
MANDATORY TRAINING- BUT ANYONE
WHO HASN'T TAKEN ON THE
MANDATORY TRAINING BEFORE
TWENTY TWENTY TWO WHICH IS
RIGHT AROUND THE CORNER- IS NOT
QUALIFIED TO AUDIT I THINK I
UNDERSTAND THE IDEA THERE IS
SAID YOU WANT PEOPLE TO HURRY
UP AND GET TRAINED SO THAT THEY
CAN. QUALIFIED AUDIT BUT THE
SAME TIME THERE'S A FEE TO GET
THE TRAINING WHICH I HAVE NO
IDEA READING THE BILL HOW MUCH
OF A BERRY OR NOT THAT MAY BE-
AND THEN IT JUST SEEMS LIKE AN
AWFULLY QUICK TURNAROUND IN NOT
KNOWING HOW MANY PEOPLE GOING
TO QUALIFY- HERE TO SORT OF.
LACK BETTER WORKFORCE THE NEW
ORLEANS STANDARDS- THE NEW
TRAINING STANDARDS ON ON
EVERYBODY SO. I'M IMAGINING
THAT THERE'S A LOT OF TENSION
THERE IN TERMS TRYING TO HURRY
UP- IN GET THE óRDENES THE UC
AUTHOR SEE THE KIND OF TRAINING
YOU SEE IS APPROPRIATE IN PLACE
BUT AT THE SAME TIME I'M
WORRIED ABOUT- THE LACK OF
ENROLLMENT IN THE TRAINING
LEADING TO. HERNE HILL PERHAPS
AN EQUAL OR GREATER PROBLEM-
THAT WE JUST HAVE DISQUALIFIED
AUDITORS NOW WE CAN FIND OF
AUDITORS TO COME IN AND DO THE
WORK THAT NEEDS TO BE DONE
PERHAPS AND PUTTING THAT OUT
THERE FOR YOUR RESPONSE THANK
YOU SENATOR AND I THINK OUR OUR
INTERESTS ARE ALIGNED HERE IN
TERMS OF WHAT WE WANT. WE HAVE
NOT HEARD ANY COMPLAINTS ARE
NOT AWARE OF ANY CONCERNS FOR
THE ARMENIAN COMMUNITY ABOUT
THE TIME LINES THAT HAVE BEEN
SAID IN THE BILL TO ENSURE THAT
THE TRAINING IS DONE I'M
CERTAINLY- WOULD BE OPEN TO ANY
CONCERNS THAT ARE OUT THERE
ABOUT OUR ABILITY TO IMPLEMENT
THIS CORRECTLY THAT'S REALLY
WHAT I WANT I THINK WHAT YOU
WANT AS WELL. SO I'M JUST NOT
AWARE OF ANY AT THE MOMENT-
THAT WOULD BE WOULD HAVE BEEN
RAISED WITH ME BUT I CERTAINLY
THINK THAT WHAT YOU'RE ASKING
FOR CERTAINLY COMPLETELY
ALIGNED WITH WHAT I WOULD LIKE
TO SEE AS WELL. OKAY WHAT IT HE
IS IN. IN THE- A- AT THIS AT
THIS STAGE I DO BELIEVE THE
BILL NEEDS. SOME WORK ON THE
CLIENT TO SUPPORTED TODAY FOR
NO OTHER REASON AS A COURTESY
TO. A COLLEAGUE TO GET THIS
BILL OUT FOR CONTINUED WORK-
IN. YOU KNOW THAT MAY NOT BE
NECESSARY TO THE VOTE TODAY
BUT- THAT'S MY PERSPECTIVE
GOING INTO A SEVENTY THE FIRST
ONE SPEAKING TODAY- I'M- HERE
ON THE DATE ON THE DAIS- THE
OTHER. THE OTHER. CONCERNED I
HAD WHICH IS REALLY ZOOMING OUT
A LITTLE BIT IF IT DOES GO TO.
THE NATURE OF. WHAT SOME OF THE
NON CLASSROOM BASED CHARTERED
OR- ENGAGED IN NOT ALL BUT
SOME- IS THAT THE- LABEL SEEMS
TO COVER A WHOLE LOT OF GROUND
AND INCLUDING YOU KNOW FOLKS
WHO ARE DOING- HERO WHAT I
WOULD CALL VOTE. CONSERVATION
WORK FEEL WORK IN ALL KINDS OF
OTHER THINGS AS WELL BUT THE
NON THE VIRTUAL NON CLASSROOM
DAYS. AREA WHICH I THINK YOU'RE
PRIMARILY FOCUSED ON BASED ON
THE DEIFICATION THAT THAT
OCCURRED WITH SOME OF THE
SCHOOLS. IT HE HE WE'RE HEARING
AS A LEGISLATURE. IN OF COURSE
WEEK WE PASS LEGISLATION AT
LEAST THE MAJORITY OF US DID.
TO TRY TO GET KIDS BACK INTO
CLASSROOMS AS QUICKLY AS
POSSIBLE BECAUSE OF THE SENSE
THAT. WHAT WE PART OF WHAT WE
LEARNED DURING THIS PANDEMIC IS
THAT. HE HE THE CUSTOMER
DUCATION IS ABSOLUTELY
NECESSARY IN A TO THE
ARRANGEMENT OF THE STUDENT-
THAT. THE WE'VE WE'VE BEEN
WE'VE SEEN BILLS COME THROUGH
IN OFFICE AS RECENTLY AS TODAY
DEALING WITH SLIPPAGE DEALING
WITH CONCERNS ABOUT WHAT
HAPPENS WHEN THEY'RE NOT IN THE
CLASSROOM WE DON'T HAVE THIS
THE TEACHERS AT SOME POINT
STANDING IN FRONT OF THE
STUDENTS. I'M NOT ASKING YOU TO
IT NECESSARILY TO ADDRESS. THE
ISSUE I THINK CTA BROUGHT UP-
OR THE UP SOMEBODY ON THE
OPPOSITION SIDE BROUGHT UP
ABOUT. THE CONTINUING
MORATORIUM OR NOT ON ON THIS
TYPE OF. THE VIRTUAL EDUCATION-
BUT I LIKE TO UNDERSTAND WHAT
YOUR SENTIMENT ABOUT THAT IS
GOING FOR IRAQ IN JUST IN THE
BROADER CONTEXT OF NOT WANTING
TO BE AT CROSS PURPOSES- TRYING
TO TRYING TO BE AS UNIFORM AS
POSSIBLE. WITH OUR COLLECTIVE
PHILOSOPHY GOING FORWARD AS TO
WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO PROMOTE-
YOU KNOW IN TERMS OF IN TERMS
OF. THE PUBLIC EDUCATION
SYSTEM- ARE WE REALLY FOCUSED
ON GETTING EVERY CHILD BACK IN
INTO A CLASSROOM- I UNDERSTAND
THERE'S A CHOICE HERE BUT ARE
WE FOCUSED ON OUR RESOURCES
TRYING TO GET KIDS BACK INTO
CLASSROOMS- OR IS THIS AN AREA
THAT. YOU BELIEVE SHOULD HAVE
SOME GROWTH GOING FORWARD.
THROUGH THE CHAIR ON WHEELS
CENTER THANK YOU FOR YOUR
THOUGHTFUL COMMENTS ABOUT THIS
ISSUE YOU KNOW WE HAVE THE
SPIRITED DEBATES HERE IN THE
LEGISLATURE AND THIS IS THIS
AREA AND- I THINK THAT YOU
WILL- WELCOME IN HERE THAT
MANY- DELIBERATIONS ON
LEGISLATION IN THE SPACE NOT
JUST IN THIS NARROW CATEGORY OF
NON CLASSROOM BASED CHARTER
COMPANY THE BROADER QUESTION
INCLUDING THE MORATORIUM-
INCLUDING- A VARIETY OF OTHER
STANDARDS THAT ARE APPLIED OR
DON'T APPLY SO. IT IS A ROBUST
DEBATE THAT WE DO HAVE IN THE
SPACE KEEP IN MIND THAT- NOT
CLASSROOM BASED CHARTERS THAT
WOULD ONLY YOU EAT YOU FIT THAT
CATEGORY THE 220% ARE OUTSIDE
THE CLASSROOM NOT NOT WHAT
WE'VE BEEN EXPERIENCING- HERE
IN THE PANDEMIC IN MOST CASES
SO IT'S A IT'S A NARROWER FRAME
AND EVEN MORE SO IN TERMS OF
HOW IT'S DEFINED. SO LOOK AT IT
THIS THAT IT I THINK YOUR
QUESTION DOES MOVE INTO THIS
BROADER SPACE OF A PUBLIC
CHARTERS AND DAY AND THE ROLE
THAT THEY PLAY AND THE CHOICES
THAT THEY PROVIDE- OR SHOULD
SHOULD OR SHOULD NOT PROVIDE.
TO THE PARENT COMMUNITY- IT. I
TRYING TO STAY PUT ON THIS
NARROWS- THE I THINK THAT WE
WILL AT AT MY GUESS IS THIS
COMMITTEE WILL HEAR BILLS THAT
WOULD GO FURTHER THAN. WHAT YOU
HAVE BEFORE YOU WHEN OTHER
THINGS THAT SHOULD BE DONE THAT
MANY PEOPLE SHOULD BE DONE AND
OTHER PEOPLE THINK. ART SHOULD
NOT BE DONE I THINK YU YOU
WILL SEE. IN THIS LEGISLATIVE
SESSION SOME ADDITIONAL- ABOUT
BILLS IN POINTS OF DEBATE IN
THE SPACE BUT FOR ME AT LEAST
CENTER WITH RESPECT. I'M TRYING
TO STAY THERE- WE'VE HAD THESE
TERRIBLE ABUSES AND MAKES ALL
OF US UPSET AND ANGRY. AND OUT
TRY TO BE VERY RESPONSIVE TO
WHAT THE DISTRICT ATTORNEY HAS
SAID OUR REFORMS THAT WOULD TRY
TO PREVENT THIS IS NOT AND
MATTER. OF MAKE IT ANY EASIER
WE ACTUALLY WANT TO TRY TO STOP
IT THAT'S WHAT THE BILL IS
NARROWLY TAILORED TO TRY TO
DEAL WITH THE EXACT ABUSES THAT
OCCURRED IN THIS CASE.
HOPEFULLY THAT HELPS IN
RESPONSE I KNOW IT'S NOT. THE
BROADER QUESTION THAT YOU HAVE
REYES BUT IT AT LEAST CLOSE TO
MY FOCUS IN THIS BILL. THE NEW
IT JUST ONE MORE A QUICK
COMMENT AND ONE MORE QUESTION-
MADAM CHAIR AND THEN ALL. OF
THEM. WE'LL SEE THE FOR- A AND
I JUST I WANNA MAKE IT CLEAR
THAT WHERE I'M COMING FROM HIS.
OF A LONG WAY BACK AS SOMEBODY
WHO WAS A SCHOOL BOARD MEMBER.
HIMSELF IN NINETEEN NINETY TWO.
WHEN CHARTERED WHEN THE CHARTER
LEGISLATION WAS ENACTED
ORIGINALLY. IN. IT THE
LEGISLATION WAS. WAS OSTENSIBLY
WITH THE INTENT TO INFORM
PRODUCTIVE CHANGE IN THE
OVERALL PUBLIC EDUCATION SYSTEM
AND SO ANYTIME I LOOK AT WHAT
HE THE CHARTER IS DOING TO THIS
DAY ALL THESE YEARS LATER I ASK
MYSELF THE QUESTION ARE THEY
DOING SOMETHING THAT INFORMS
PRODUCTIVE CHANGE IN OUR
OVERALL PUBLIC EDUCATION SYSTEM
IN SO THAT'S WHY RAISE THE
BROADER ISSUE BECAUSE- AUDIT.
WELL THEY'RE IN BUSINESS GREAT
BUT I JUST WANT US I JUST
WANTED TO PUT ON THE RECORD I'M
NOT CONVINCED THAT THE MODEL.
ESPECIALLY AFTER WHAT WE
LEARNED OF THE PANDEMIC IS
ACTUALLY INFORMING- THE KIND OF
PRODUCTIVE CHANGE IN THE
OVERALL PUBLIC EDUCATION SYSTEM
THAT. THE CHARTERS WERE
INTENDED TO DO IN THE FIRST
PLACE THAT WE MAY OR MAY NOT
DISAGREE OR AGREE ON THAT AND
THEN THAT'LL PROBABLY UNTIL
ITSELF LATER- LAST QUESTION-
THE WITH THE- BUS WHICH
REPORTER WHO WITH- BUT MY LAST
QUESTION WITH WITH REGARD TO-
THE. THE ISSUE OF BUT I'M I'M
GONNA I'M GONNA PASS I LOST MY
TRAIN OF THOUGHT THE CENTER
MANAGER AND I APOLOGIZE FOR
THAT AND THERE WAS ONE MORE
PARTICULAR VERY SPECIFIC ISSUE
WITH THE BILL IS CONCERNED
ABOUT AND PERHAPS IF I CAN
RESERVE THE RIGHT TO COME BACK
ON THAT THE- THERE'S TIME LATER
I WILL THANK YOU NO PROBLEM
CENTER COURSE ATV I DON'T THINK
THE CENTER GLAZERS GOING
ANYWHERE- ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS. SENATOR PAM. THANK
YOU AND- IN THE CIRCULATOR-
APPRECIATE YOU TRYING TO
ADDRESS SOME OF THE ISSUES THAT
HAPPENED BUT I GUESS. MY POINT
IS THIS IS A PRETTY NARROW BILL
THIS IS DEALING WITH THE
AUDITING AND- I THINK IT'S THAT
THAT'S ALSO NOTED IN ALICE'S-
AND- WELL MAYBE A MORE RIGOROUS
AUDIT SYSTEM MAY. HAVE PICKED
UP THIS FRAUD EARLIER- I DO
FEEL THERE ARE OTHER RECOMMEND-
ISSUES THAT. REVEALED IN IN THE
CASE AND NOT ONLY THIS CASE BUT
OTHERS IN TERMS OF STUDENT DATA
TRACKING OR DID YOU KNOW THE
FACT THAT WE HAVE THESE LITTLE
SCHOOL DISTRICTS WHO ARE DOING
THE AUTHORIZATION. ZERO TEN
ONLY TO FOCUS ON AUDITING OUR
WAS AND THAT THAT'S WHAT'S-CURRENTLY IN THE BILL- DID DID
THIS THIS IS THE ISSUES AROUND
THE DATA TRACKING AND- THE
CAPACITY OF THE AUTHORIZER TO
ACTUALLY ASIDE FROM AUDITING
MONITORED THE ACTIVITIES OF
THESE- A CHURCH SCHOOLS IS THAT
SOMETHING YOU VIEWS OUTSIDE THE
PURVIEW OF WHAT YOU WANT TO TRY
TO. THE COMPLETION OF THIS BILL
AND LEAVE IT TO OTHERS- SO JUST
WANT TO GET A SENSE OF WHAT A
WHAT THE GOALS WERE FOR THE FOR
THE FOR THIS BILL IN TERMS OF
TRADE DRESS. CERTAINLY THIS
THIS PROBLEM. AND THE CHAIR.
THANK YOU SENATOR. I THINK THE
BILL IS EXACTLY WHAT YOU SEE-
AN ATTEMPT TO TAKE THAT PROBLEM
THAT WE ARE IT WAS IDENTIFIED
THE RECOMMENDATIONS FROM THE
DISTRICT ATTORNEY AS TO HOW WE
COULD TRY TO PREVENT IT IN THE
FUTURE. THAT THERE ARE-
CERTAINLY- DEBATABLE ISSUES-
ABOUT AUTHORIZES AND OTHER
ELEMENTS THAT CAN COME INTO
PLAY IN A BROADER SENSE OF- OF
THE PUBLIC CHARTER- MOVEMENT TO
COMMUNITY- BUT IT'S NOT MY
INTENTION TO- TO. TAKE ON
ANYTHING MORE THAN WHAT YOU'RE
SAYING AND THE BILL TODAY I
THINK YOU'RE GONNA SEE OTHER
LEGISLATIVE PROPOSALS THIS
SESSION THAT ARE GOING TO TOUCH
UPON I THINK SOME OF THE ISSUES
THAT YOU'RE RACING AND WILL
HAVE A ROBUST DEBATE ON THOSE
WITH HEY WHEN THEY COME FORWARD
OKAY I APPRECIATE. THAT
EXPLANATION- I WILL VOTE FOR
THE BILL STAKES I THINK IT
MOVES THINGS IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION BUT I DO FEEL THAT-THIS BILL IS. A LITTLE BIT TOO
LIMITED AND ITS APPROACH BUT OF
COURSE- I KEEP MOVING THE RIGHT
DIRECTION- I THINK AS WE SEE
OTHER LEGISLATION I HOPE THAT
THIS IS IN LINE WITH THAT BUT I
CERTAINLY I WOULD NOT SEE THIS
BILL AS A SUBSTITUTE FOR BROAD
REFORMS ARE NECESSARY TO ENSURE
WE HAVE ACCOUNTABILITY AND DE
DUM. AMONG NON CLASSROOM BASED
CHARTER SCHOOLS BUT- BUT I
WILL- MOVED TO SPILL AT
APPROPRIATE TIME SO WE CAN MOVE
THIS BILL FORWARD THANK YOU
THANK YOU CENTER PAN ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS SIEMENS
AND REPLACE WHICH LIKE TO CLOSE
I THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND THE
COMMITTEE- FOR HEARING THE
BILL. RECOGNIZING THAT THE
PROBLEM THAT I THINK WE ALL ARE
QUITE ANGRY ABOUT- AS EXPLAINED
EARLIER- AND I THINK THIS BILL
THAT'S BEFORE YOU IS VERY
RESPONSIVE TO THE SPECIFIC-
IDENTIFICATION OF THE SPECIFIC
PROBLEMS THAT OCCURRED IN THIS
CASE AND- AND WAYS TO PREVENT
IT FROM HAPPENING AGAIN I THINK
IT'S A LIKE A GOOD IMPORTANT
STEP FORWARD ALTHOUGH. MANY BE
THAT SOME PEOPLE FEEL IT SHOULD
BE BROADER- IN THE IN SCOPE IN
THE IN THE IN THE ORDER OF
THINGS BUT I THINK IT- IT PUTS
ITS SENSES- IT. BRUISES IN THE
CRASH DIRECTION THAT I'VE- ASK
FOR KNIVES. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
SENATOR GLAZERS. I'M A
CONSULTANT WE A BY CENTER
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. FILE
NUMBER SIX SB FIVE NINETY THREE
THE MOTION IS TO PASS BUT FIRST
BE REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS LEYVA. BY LEYVA
AYE OH TROUBLED HI RITUAL BOGA
HIGH CORTESE. CORTEZ THE AYE
DALY AYE DALY AYE GLAZER AYE
GLAZER AYE MCGUIRE. MCGUIRE AYE
PAN ALL RIGHT AND I. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH WE HAVE A FULL HOUSE
EXCELLENT OKAY I NEED A LITTLE
HELP HERE WE HAVE FILE ITEM
TEN. CENTER GLAZER HEARD YOU
WERE PRESENTING THAT I HEARD
CENTER STERN WAS PRESENTING.
WHERE WE OUT HIS PRESENTING
STERN'S BILL- I WAS TOLD THAT
HE THAT THEY THOUGHT THAT HE
MIGHT BE FEELING WELL ENOUGH TO
ATTEND AND HE WOULD DO THAT
STEP IN BUT I'M HAPPY TO DO IT
DEPENDING ON THE WISHES OF THE
COMMITTEE VERY GOOD HAVE WE
HEARD AND HIT OKAY WE'RE
HEARING THAT IT'S GOING TO BE
YOU SENATOR GLAZERS SO WE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH PLEASE PROCEED
WITH FILE ITEM TEN SB SIX
NINETY THREE WHEN YOU ARE READY
I AM NOT INSURANCE THANK YOU
AND IT'S AN HONOR TO PRESENT
THIS BILL ON BEHALF OF SENATOR
STERN- IT'S THE NEVER AGAIN
EDUCATION ACT. SB SIX NINETY
THREE. MEMBERS IN TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN A STUDY FOUND THAT.
41% OF AMERICANS AND 66% OF
MILLENNIALS COULD NOT IDENTIFY
THE SIGNIFICANCE ABOUT SHORTS
LIKE ABOUT THAT. THIS IS JUST
ONE EXAMPLE OF MOUNTING
EVIDENCE THAT THE COLLECTIVE
MEMORY OF THE HOLOCAUST. AND
THIS SYSTEMATIC EXTERMINATION
OF MILLIONS IS UNFORTUNATELY
FADING. THE CONSEQUENCES OF
THIS COLLECTIVE MEMORY LOSS ARE
STARK AND READILY DEMONSTRATED
BY THE RISE IN ANTI SEMITIC
SPEECH AND ACTIONS ACROSS THE
COUNTRY. THE ANTI DEFAMATION
LEAGUE FOUND THAT MORE THAN
FOUR POINT TWO MILLION ANTI
SEMITIC POSTS ON TWITTER IN A
RECENT TWELVE MONTH PERIOD FOUR
POINT TWO MILLION. THIS WAS A
COMPANY BY A 12% RISE IN ANTI
SEMITIC ACTS OF ASSAULT
VANDALISM AND HARASSMENT THE
LARGEST SUCH ANNUAL INCREASE
SINCE NINETEEN SEVENTY NINE. SB
SIX NINETY THREE WILL ESTABLISH
THE GOVERNOR'S COUNCIL ON
GENOCIDE AND HOLOCAUST
EDUCATION. TO TRY TO ELEVATE
AND TACKLED THIS VERY SERIOUS
PROBLEM HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
IT'S MODELED- IT'S BOTTLED UP
OF SIMILAR LEGISLATION ON THE
NATIONAL LEVEL AND IN STATES
SUCH AS PENNSYLVANIA. SB SIX
NINETY THREE ESTABLISHES THE
GOVERNOR'S COUNCIL ON GENOCIDE
AND HOLOCAUST EDUCATION
COMPOSED OF SEVENTEEN EXPERTS
ON GENOCIDE EDUCATION INCLUDING
THE HOLOCAUST. THE COUNCIL IS
TASKED WITH APPROVING AID AGE
APPROPRIATE BEST PRACTICES AND
RESOURCES FOR TEACHERS AND
STUDENTS REGARDING GENOCIDE
EDUCATION INCLUDING THE
HOLOCAUST. THE COUNCIL SERVED
TO PROMOTE GENOCIDE EDUCATION
IT WOULD BE ALLOWED TO
ESTABLISH INDIVIDUAL WORKING
GROUP'S TO PUT TOGETHER BEST
PRACTICES FOR TEACHING ABOUT
THE ARMENIAN GENOCIDE. THE
GENOCIDE AGAINST THE TUTSI IN
RWANDA AND OTHER GENOCIDES
COMMITTED IN AFRICA ASIA LATIN
AMERICA SOUTH AMERICA AND
EUROPE. THE APPROVED BEST
PRACTICES WILL BE AVAILABLE ON
THE- DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION
WEBSITE FOR ALL TEACHERS
INTERESTED IN PROVIDING
GENOCIDE EDUCATION WITHIN
EXISTING CURRICULUM GUIDELINES.
TO BE CLEAR THIS BILL IS NOT A
CURRICULA MANDATE IT SIMPLY
PROVIDES APPROVED BEST
PRACTICES FOR TEACHERS WITH AN
EXISTING GUIDELINES. GENOCIDE
IS A CHALLENGING SUBJECT TO
TACKLE IN THE CLASSROOM. SO
IT'S IMPORTANT TO ENSURE
TEACHERS HAVE UP TO DATE AND
AGE APPROPRIATE AN EXPERT
APPROVED RESOURCES AVAILABLE TO
THEM. HI THIS BILL IS A JEWISH
CAUCUS PRIORITY BILL HAS A WIDE
GROUP OF SUPPORT INCLUDING THE
ANTI DEFAMATION LEAGUE THE
ARMENIAN ASSEMBLY OF AMERICA.
DASA AND THE HOLOCAUST CENTER
THE BILL HAS NO KNOWN
OPPOSITION MANAGE HERE WE HAVE
WITNESSES- AVAILABLE MORGAN
BLOOM SCHNEIDER WITH JEWISH
FAMILY AND CHILDREN'S SERVICES
HOLOCAUST CENTER. AND STEVEN
SMITH FROM THE USC SHOAH
FOUNDATION AND THEY'RE BOTH
PARTICIPATE REMOTELY I
RESPECTFULLY I AM ASKING ON
BEHALF OF SENATOR STERN AND I
THOUGHT THANK YOU VERY MCH
SENATOR GLAZERS. ALL LEAD
WITNESSES YOU EACH HAVE TWO
MINUTES PLEASE PROCEED. DO WE
HAVE MISTER MORGAN BLONDE
SCHNEIDER. PLEASE PROCEED I
PERCENT YES PLEASE HI MY NAME
IS MORGAN BLOM SCHNEIDER AND AS
DIRECTOR OF THE JSE OF
HOLOCAUST CENTER I'M CALLING IN
TODAY IN SUPPORT OF SB SIX NINE
THREE I'M HONORED TO BE HERE
TODAY PARTNERING WITH SENATOR
STERN AND SENATOR GLAZERS IN
PURSUIT OF THE JST OF PUBLIC
COMPANIES MISSION WHICH AIMS TO
INSPIRE MORAL COURAGE AND
SOCIAL RESPONSIBILITY IN FUTURE
GENERATIONS BY FOSTERING A
DEEPER UNDERSTANDING OF THE
HOLOCAUST AND PATTERNS OF
GENOCIDE. EACH YEAR THE
HOLOCAUST CENTER REACHES MORE
THAN TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND
STUDENTS AND TEACHERS FROM
HUNDREDS OF SCHOOLS. YOUR
MEETING WITH SURVIVORS AND
THEIR DESCENDANTS OF
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT
WORKSHOPS FOR TEACHERS STUDENT
SEMINARS AND A WORLD CLASS
LIBRARY OF FOURTEEN THOUSAND
BOOKS. I WANT TO SHARE WITH YOU
AN ALARMING STATISTIC FOLLOWING
THE HOLOCAUST CENTER WORKSHOP
THIS FALL PARTICIPATING
EDUCATORS REPORTED THAT 90% OF
THEM HAD WITNESSED ANTI
SEMITISM ON THEIR CAMPUSES.
THANK IS MADE EVEN MORE
CONCERNING THE WHEN THE RECENT
WORDS US SECRETARY OF STATE
ANTONY BLINKEN ARE CONSIDERED.
COULD HATRED OF THE JEWS TEND
TO GO HAND IN HAND WITH HATRED
OF OTHERS INCLUDING LGBTQ PLUS
PEOPLE PEOPLE OF COLOR PEOPLE
WITH DISABILITIES AND REFUGEES.
CURRENTLY ONE OF THE GREATEST
CHALLENGES IN HOLOCAUST AND
GENOCIDE EDUCATION IS THAT
TEACHERS ARE MANDATED TO
INCLUDE LESSONS ON THE
HOLOCAUST BUT THEY ARE LARGELY
LEFT ON THEIR OWN TO DEVELOP
THOSE LESSONS. CURRENTLY NO
STATE OR FEDERAL FUNDING TO
SUPPORT CORRESPONDING
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT. AS A
RESULT MANY SIMPLY USE THE
LESSONS THEY THEMSELVES LEARNED
AS A STUDENT DECADES AGO. TEACH
THE HOLOCAUST TODAY. I SHARE
THIS WITH YOU AT THAT
HIGHLIGHTS THE GREAT NEED RIGHT
NOW TO IDENTIFY AND ADOPT BEST
PRACTICES TO THE CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS AND FACILITATE
EFFECTIVE INSTRUCTION ON THE
HOLOCAUST AND GENOCIDE. AND
THAT IS WHAT THIS CRITICAL
LEGISLATION WILL DO AND
PARTICULARLY APPRECIATE THAT
MONITORS DURING CHOSE TO
INCLUDE THE FOLLOWING LANGUAGE
THANK ARAMBULA I'M HERE OVER
YOUR TWO MINUTES WE'RE GOING TO
GO TO THE NEXT WITNESS THANK
YOU VERY MUCH HELLO. MISTER
SMITH PLEASE PROCEED. THANK YOU
MOBILE I THANK YOU SENATOR
PLATE AND STERN FEEL LEADERSHIP
MY NAME IS STEPHEN SMITH
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF U. S. T.
CHAU FOUNDATION. OUTSIDE THE
FIFTY FIVE THOUSAND TESTIMONIES
OF THE HOLOCAUST AND GENOCIDE
GLOBAL DIGITAL EDUCATION
PROVIDER. NOT FORCING ONE
LEADERS. BUT I NEED FOR
LEADERSHIP BECAUSE HEY THERE'S
A RISE AND HATRED KNOWLEDGE. B.
WE JUST HEARD A RECENT SURVEY
SHOWS THAT YOUNG PEOPLE DO NOT
KNOW WHAT HAPPENED DURING THE
HOLOCAUST LET ALONE OTHER
GENOCIDES. SHE WROTE CURRICULUM
ADDRESSING THE HOLOCAUST IS NOT
BEEN UPDATED SINCE NINETEEN
NINETY EIGHT. THERE'S A LOT OF
CALIFORNIA TO LEAD ON THIS
TOPIC NATIONALLY. TO BEST
PRACTICE PROVISION GIVES
TEACHERS AUTONOMY AND CHOICE IT
PROVIDES TOOLS SKILLS AND
EXPERTISE THE PROPOSED
GOVERNOR'S COUNCIL CONVENES
EXPERTS OVERNIGHT DACIANS
UNEDUCATED ANOTHER. BEST
PRACTICE YOU KNOW THE STATE'S.
FOR YOU WILL BEST PRACTICE
GUIDELINE. SET BY THE FIVE COME
IN. HOLOCAUST REMEMBER A LOT.
THREE THANK. MISTER VISION FOR.
DIVERSE IF YOU COULD. HEY WILL
AND A MEETING MY ONE TEMP
GUATEMALA CHAU CHEN. AND JEWISH.
IN PALESTINE. ARE YOU ABLE. THE
ETHNIC STUDIES CURRICULUM THE
CITY EDUCATED STUDENTS WILL
LEARN WHICH I'M FROM OTHER P.
STORE. FOR ITS DIGITAL BALLOT
IS THE WAY TOP AND JET. DID YOU
KNOW THE WAY ALSO IN DIGITAL
AND YOU FOR HOLOCAUST GENOCIDE
STUDIES WORLDWIDE OVER A
HUNDRED THOUSAND TEACHERS
NATIONALLY GET THE HOLOCAUST
AND GENOCIDE VISUAL CONTENT
FROM USC ALONE. WE WANT TO
ENSURE A CALIFORNIA TEACHERS
BENEFIT. FROM MEDIA EDUCATIONAL
INNOVATIONS TO. BY THE JENNIFER
SURVIVORS HAVE ENTRUSTED THEIR
STORIES TO YOU IF SHOAH
FOUNDATION HERE IN CALIFORNIA
WE HAVE A TOP CALIFORNIAN
CHILDREN TO LEARN FROM THEM TO
OUR ACTUAL RESPECTFULLY ASK THE
COMMITTEE FOR AYE VOTE. TO THE
NEVER AGAIN EDUCATION ACT SB
SIX NINE THREE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH WE WILL NOW GO TO. A
WITNESSES TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT
HERE IN FORTY TWO OH THREE
SEEING NONE WILL GO TO TWENTY
FORTY SEEN NONE WE WILL BRING
IT BACK TO MISTER MODERATOR
PLEASE OPEN THE LINES FOR
ANYONE WISHING TO TESTIFY. IN
SUPPORT. OF SB SIX NINETY THREE
PLEASE. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
IF YOU LIKE TO. SHOW YOUR
SUPPORT FOR SB SIX NINETY THREE
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND WE WILL
BEGIN TODAY WITH LINE ONE OH
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE OF
FOUR I THINK YOU TOOK YOURSELF
OUT THERE YOU GO WELL PROJECT.
PLEASE GO AHEAD ONE OF FOUR.
THANK YOU COAST BERGEN BEHALF
OF THE SIMON WIESENTHAL CENTER
IN THE JEWISH PUBLIC AFFAIRS
COMMITTEE J. PACK IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
SIXTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI GOOD
AFTERNOON CALVIN DOLLARS
REPRESENTING THE LOS ANGELES
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICT THE
LEGISLATIVE AND PUBLIC AFFAIRS
COMMITTEE WILL BE DISCUSSING
THE BALL NEXT WEEK AND THE
STAFF HAS RECOMMENDED TO
SUPPORT THE COMMISSION. THANK
YOU ABOUT SORRY THANK YOU THANK
YOU. AND AS A FINAL REMINDER TO
SHOW YOUR SUPPORT FOR SB SIX
NINETY THREE PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. I'M SURE
NOBODY ELSE WAS QUEUING UP.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR
MODERATOR WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE
LEAD OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL
BUT WE WILL GO TO FORTY TWO OH
THREE SEEING NO ONE HERE IN
OPPOSITION WILL GO TO TWENTY
FORTY SEEING NO ONE THERE
MISTER MODERATED WE HAVE ANYONE
COMING UP WHO WISHES TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION TO SB. SIX NINETY
THREE. SHOW YOUR OPPOSITION-
FOR BILL SIX SP SIX NINETY
THREE PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME. ONE ZERO TO SHOW
OPPOSITION FOR BILL SB. SIX
NINETY THREE. I'M SURE NOBODY'S
QUEUING UP AT THIS TIME THANK
YOU MR MODERATOR WILL BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE TO HAVE
ANY QUESTIONS COMMENTS CONCERNS
SENATOR PAM THANK YOU AND I
WANNA THANK CENTER STERN FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD
APPRECIATE CERTAIN GLAZER
PRESENTING AT- I GUESS MY COULD
BECOME AND I JUST WANNA MAKE IS
THAT FORTUNY GENOCIDE STILL IS
OCCURRING SO. YOU KNOW WE
TALKED THEY MADE REFERENCE TO
THE ARMENIAN CAMBODIAN RWANDA
GENOCIDE CIVILS THE HOLOCAUST
OF BUSINESS THAT WE HAD DURING
THE RANDOM MUSLIM MINORITY THAT
WAS JUST A COUPLE YEARS AGO.
AND FRANKLY- TALKING ABOUT THE
ROLE- SOCIAL MEDIA AND OTHER
TYPES OF MEDIA HAVE IN TERMS
OF- ITS POTENTIAL INCITING HATE
AND EVENTS AND ACTUALLY
GENOCIDE IS THE MOST EXTREME
EXPRESSION OF THAT- AND- IT I
THINK I'S IMPORTANT THAT
THAT'S PART OF THE DISCUSSION-
THIS YEAR'S THEME AND HOLOCAUST
REMEMBRANCE DAY IS FOR MANY
SURVIVORS AS IT BEGAN WITH
WORDS. RIGHT SO. WE CAN TEACH
PEOPLE ABOUT THE- OUR WHAT'S
AND SO FORTH BUT IT BEGAN WITH
THE WORD. AND THE I THINK THE
INCREASE IMPORTANT BECAUSE
THOSE TO LOOK AT EACH OF THESE
GENOCIDES FOOD BECAUSE WE- WE
REMEMBER THESE LESSONS NOT JUST
AS HISTORY. BUT AS A WAY TO
ADDRESS THE FUTURE. AND SO I
WOULD POINT OUT THAT NEW YORK
TIMES ACTUALLY REPORTED THAT
FACEBOOK ACTUALLY WAS HARNESSED
BY THE MILITARY TO PUT OUT
PROPAGANDA FACED- FALSE NEWS
INFLAMMATORY POSTS THAT LED TO
THE- DOWNSIDE OF THE RAIN GOT.
IN FACT FACEBOOK ITSELF REFUSE
THE BAND- HOLOCAUST DENIAL
UNTIL LITERALLY TWENTY TWENTY
WHICH IS JUST LAST YEAR- SO.
IT'S NOT JUST THE PAST
CONVERSATION IT'S A
CONVERSATION ABOUT THE FUTURE
AND WHAT TYPE OF POLICIES WE
WANT TO ENSURE THAT WE PREVENT.
FUTURE GENOCIDE AND HATE AS
WELL SO CERTAINLY NOT VERY MUCH
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL I HOPE
WE CAN CORPORATE SOME THIS
CONCEPTS IN THE EDUCATION SO
IT'S ALL IT'S NOT JUST ABOUT
THE PAST ABOUT THE FUTURE. AND
WOULD CERTAINLY BE HAPPY TO
MOVE THE BUILT APPROPRIATE
TIME. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
CENTER PAN ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS SEEING NONE. OF MR
GLAZER CENTER BECAUSE WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE THANK YOU AT
MADAM CHAIR AND I. I WOULD NOTE
THAT THE- YOU KNOW THE BILL
CREATES A COUNCIL OF GOVERNORS
COUNCIL AND IT IT DOESN'T
SPECIFICALLY SAY IT'S ONLY
ABOUT THE- THIS HOLOCAUST ABOUT
GENOCIDE EDUCATION AND I THINK
SENATOR. SACRAMENTO IS MADE
IMPORTANT POINT ABOUT HOW
WORDS. ARE THE TRAIL THAT LEAD
TO THESE. TERRIBLE ACTS AND-
I'M I'M SURE AND I HOPE. THAT
THE TESTS TO KIND OF.
THOUGHTFUL EXAMINATION AT THIS
COUNCIL WOULD PUT IT IN CAJUN
IT'S A GREAT HONOR TO PRESENT
THIS BILL ON BEHALF OF THE US
SENATOR STERN THE NEVER AGAIN
EDUCATION ACT. AND ON HIS
BEHALF I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
NEITHER. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
SENATOR GLAZERS THE BILL HAS
BEEN MOVED BY SENATOR PAN AM
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. FILE ITEM NUMBER TEN SB
SIX NINETY THREE THE MOTION IS
TO PASS BUT FIRST BE REFERRED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS LEYVA. BY LEYVA
AYE OCHO ABODE HI THE TROUBLED.
BY PARTISI I VERTIV IDEA. TELL
I CLICK. AYE GLAZER AYE MCGUIRE.
ACQUIRE PAN. ALL RIGHT AND I
THINK THAT BILL L. SEVEN Z.
MEMBERS OF THAT DON'T TO ADD A
THANK YOU VERY MUCH YOUR
SERVICE TODAY. AND FOR THOSE
THAT DO WE ARE GOING TO START
WITH FILE ITEM ONE SB SIX
NINETY TWO. A MAN I'M A
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS FILE NUMBER ONE
SB SIX NINETY TWO THE MOTION IS
TO PASS BUT FIRST BE REFERRED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. CHAIR HOLDING
ON A VICE CHAIR VOTING ON A
GLAZER HI. THE BILLS OUT. ZERO
MOVING TO FILE ITEM NUMBER TWO
SB SIX THREE SIXTY THREE PLEASE
HOLD THE ABSENT MEMBERS. FILE
NUMBER TWO SB THREE SIXTY THREE
THE MOTION IS TO PASS BUT FIRST
BE REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
RULES CHAIR VOTING ON A VICE
CHAIR VOTING NO. DELHI DELHI
NOT VOTING GLAZER. GLAZER NOT
VOTING THE BILLS OUT FOR. TWO
ONE THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE THE FILE ITEM FOR
SB FIVE FORTY PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. THE ITEM NUMBER
FOR SB FIVE FORTY THE MOTION IS
TO PASS BUT FIRST BE REFERRED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS CHAIR VOTING AYE
VICE CHAIR VOTING ON HIGH
GLAZER AYE. GLAZER AYE MCGUIRE.
CHOIR HI THE BILLS OUT SEVEN
ZERO MOVING TO FILE ITEM NUMBER
FIVE ZERO FIVE FORTY FIVE
EXCELLENT. SIX ONE PARDON ME OF
FILE ITEM FOUR IS OUT SIX ONE
MOVING THE FILE ITEM FIVE SB
FIVE FORTY FIVE PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. PHONE NUMBER
FIVE SB FIVE FORTY FIVE. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
THE FIRST AMENDED AND RE REFER
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS CHAIR VOTING I
FACED HER VOTING AYE GLAZER AYE
GLAZER AYE MCGUIRE- I PAN RIGHT.
HI THAT BILLS OUT SEVEN ZERO
THANK YOU FILE ITEM SIX SB FIVE
NINETY THREE THAT BILL IS ALSO
OUT SEVEN ZERO MOVED TO FILE
ITEM SEVEN SB SIX TO- SORRY
THAT WAS PULLED FILE ITEM EIGHT
SB SIX FIFTY NINE PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS ITEM NUMBER
EIGHT SB SIX FIFTY NINE THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
BUT FIRST AMEND AND RE REFER TO
THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. CHAIR VOTING ON
A VICE CHAIR VOTING AYE GLAZER
AYE GLAZER AYE MCGUIRE ACQUIRE
I ACCEPT THAT BILLS OUT SEVEN
ZERO FILE ITEM NUMBER NINE SB
SEVEN SIXTY SEVEN PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS FILE NUMBER
NINE SB SEVEN SIXTY SEVEN THE
MOTION IS TO PASS BUT FIRST BE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS CHAIR VOTING AYE
VICE CHAIR VOTING ONLINE
MCGUIRE. ACQUIRE I SAID THAT
BILLS OUT SEVEN ZERO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MEMBERSHIPS ON CALENDAR TO
CENTRAL. I KNOW IT WHEN ARE YOU-
PLEASE OPEN THE ROLE AND
CONSENT CALENDAR. CONSENT
CALENDAR CHAIR VOTING AYE VICE
CHAIR VOTING I'D REQUIRE- I
PANTAI AND I ALL RIGHT THE
CONFIG CALENDAR HAS BEEN
CONFIRMED SEVEN ZERO. THANK YOU
TO ALL OF THE INDIVIDUALS WHO
PARTICIPATED IN PUBLIC
TESTIMONY TODAY IF YOU WERE NOT
ABLE TO TESTIFY TODAY PLEASE
SUBMIT YOUR COMMENTS OR
SUGGESTIONS IN WRITING TO THE
SENATE EDUCATION COMMITTEE OR
VISIT OUR WEBSITE YOUR COMMENTS
AND SUGGESTIONS ARE IMPORTANT
TO US AND WE WANT TO INCLUDE
YOUR TESTIMONY IN THE OFFICIAL
HEARING RECORDS. THANK YOU AND
WE PURCHASED APPRECIATE YOUR
PARTICIPATION THANK YOU AGAIN
FOR TO EVERYONE FOR THEIR
PATIENCE AND COOPERATION WE
HAVE CONCLUDED THE AGENDA THE
SENATE COMMITTEE ON EDUCATION
IS. ADJOURNED.